TO ORDER GOOD AFTERNOON IN
RESPONSE TO THE COVE IN
NINETEEN EMERGENCY AND TO
PROTECT THE PUBLIC LEGISLATORS
EMPLOYEES WE MUST LIMIT
NONESSENTIAL GATHERINGS AT IT
HERE TO SOCIAL DISTANCING AND
FACE COVERING GUIDELINES. AND
COMPLIANCE WITH THOSE ORDERS
THE SENATE HAS MADE NECESSARY
ADJUSTMENTS TO NORMAL PRACTICES
IN ORDER TO ENSURE THAT THE
PUBLIC CONTINUES TO HAVE ACCESS
TO THE LEGISLATIVE PROCESS. TO
ALLOW THE PUBLIC ACCESS WE'VE
ADMITTED MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
TO HEARING ROOM CITY EXTENT
THAT SOCIAL DISTANCING
REQUIREMENTS ALLOW I WILL BE
USING A TELECONFERENCE SERVICE.
FOR THESE INDIVIDUALS FOR THOSE
IMAGES WHO WISH TO TESTIFY
TODAY. FOR ALL INDIVIDUALS
WISHING TO PROVIDE PUBLIC
COMMENT THE PARTICIPANT TOLL
FREE NUMBER AND ACCESS CODE IS
POSTED ON OUR COMMITTEE WEBSITE
AND IT WILL BE DISPLAYED ON THE
SCREEN. AND I WILL ANNOUNCE IT
NOW. TODAY'S PARTICIPANT NUMBER
IS. 877-336-4437 AGAIN EIGHT
SEVEN SEVEN. THREE THREE SIX
FOUR FOUR THREE SEVEN AND THE
ACCESS CODE IS. EIGHT TWO SIX
EIGHT FOUR TWO EIGHT AGAIN.
EIGHT TWO SIX EIGHT FOUR TWO
EIGHT FOR DETAILED INSTRUCTIONS
ON HOW THE TELECONFERENCES THEM
WORKS PLEASE REFER TO THE
SENATE AND OUR COMMITTEE
WEBSITE. WHEN WE MOVED TO
PUBLIC COMMENT YOU WILL BE
PROMPTED BY A MODERATOR TO THE
L. ONE THEN ZERO FOR SUPPORT IN
OPPOSITION. PRESS THIS ONLY ONE
TIME AND PLEASE WAIT PATIENTLY
FOR AN OPERATOR TO ASSIGN YOUR
LINE NUMBER. THIS CAN BE A
SHORT WAIT. ONCE YOU RECEIVE
LINEUP YOU'LL WAIT IN THE QUEUE
FOR THE MODERATOR TO CALL YOUR
LINE NUMBER AT THAT TIME YOU'LL
BE A MUTED AND YOU ARE NOW
READY TO ADDRESS THE COMMITTEE.
PLEASE NOTE AND FOR- FOR US TO
HEAR YOU CLEARLY AND TO AVOID
ACOUSTIC FEEDBACK. YOU MUST
MUTE THE DEVICE YOU'RE WATCHING
THE HEARING ON PRIOR TO GIVING
TESTIMONY OVER THE PHONE. IN
ADDITION PLEASE BE SURE YO GOT
THE PROCREATIVE. FROM YOUR
PHONE. IT IS IMPORTANT THAT WE
WERE ABLE TO HEAR YOU AND THAT
WE DO HEAR FROM YOU AND WE
THANK YOU FOR YOUR PATIENCE. I
WILL MAINTAIN DECORUM DURING
THE HEARING AS IS CUSTOMARY AND
ANY INDIVIDUAL WHOSE DISRUPTIVE
MAY BE REMOVED FROM THE REMOTE
MEETING SERVICE ARE HAVE THE
CONNECTIONS MUTED. WHILE EVERY
EFFORT HASBEEN MADE TO
STREAMLINE THE HEARING PROCESS
AND CONDUCT HEARINGS AND THOSE
CLOSE TO THE SAME MANNER AS IS
CUSTOMARY. THERE MAY BE SOME
LAG TIMES FOR PARTICIPANTS TO
ADJUSTING TO THE NEW USE OF
ONLINE TOOLS OR TECHNOLOGIES.
THESE BE RESPECTFUL AND PATIENT
SO ALL INTERESTED PARTIES CAN
BE HEARD. MAKE NOTE TODAY WE
HAVE THIRTEEN BILLS ON TODAY'S
AGENDA WE ARE NOT HEARING FILE
ITEM NUMBER SEVEN EIGHTY EIGHT
OH EIGHT BY CENTER STONE. FILE
ITEM NUMBER THIRTEEN EIGHTY
THREE SIXTY NINE BY SARAH COM
LAGER WAS HEARD LAST WEEK AND
IS FOR VOTE ONLY TODAY SO WE'RE
NOT HEARING TESTIMONY ON THE
BILL TODAY BECAUSE WE'VE HEARD
TESTIMONY IN LAST WEEK'S
HEARING. WE DO HAVE ONE ITEM
UNDER PROPOSED CONSENT CALENDAR
FILE ITEM NUMBER. NINE EIGHTY
THIRTEEN OH SIX BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER AROUND A LOT. I
WOULD ALSO NOTE THAT CENTER
GROVE WILL NOT BE PRESENT AT
DID TODAY'S HEARING. THE BILLS
WILL BE HEARD AND FOLLOW ORDER
THAT ORDER MAY BE MODIFIED
BECAUSE OF THE VEIL ABILITY
BILL AUTHORS PRESENT AND THEN
NEED TO COMPLETE THE HEARING
AGENDA IN A TIMELY MANNER. SO
WITH THAT- I WOULD NOTE THAT WE
DO NOT YET HAVE A PRESENCE OF A
QUORUM WE WILL BEGIN AS A
SUBCOMMITTEE- FOR BILL
TESTIMONY DUE TO THE
CONSTRAINTS REGARDING. THE
LENGTH OF HEARINGS TECHNOLOGY
CONSIDERATIONS AND CLEANING
PROTOCOLS. HI IS THE COMMITTEE
CHAIR MAY INSTITUTE TIME LIMITS
ON TESTIMONY. EACH SIDE WILL
COMMIT WILL BE PERMITTED AN
EQUAL AMOUNT OF TIME TO BE
DETERMINED BY THE CHAIR. FOR
PRIMARY WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
AND OPPOSITION I WILL PERMIT
TWO WITNESSES FOR TWO MINUTES
PER WITNESS OR MAXIMO FOUR
MINUTES ON EACH SIDE. ALL
OTHERS WISHING TO TESTIFY MUST
LIMIT THEIR COMMENTS TO THEIR
NAME AFFILIATION AND POSITION
ON THE MEASURE. I DO HOPE TO
HEAR FROM EVERYONE WHO WISHES
TO TESTIFY TODAY. HOWEVER
BECAUSE WE DO HAVE A DEFINITE
IN TIME FOR THE HEARING ANY
FOLLOWING HEARING AFTER THIS
ONE- I MAY LIMIT THE TOTAL TIME
FOR ALL COMMENTS ON A BILL TO
ENSURE THE COMMITTEE'S ABLE TO
COMPLETE OUR HEARING AGENDA
TODAY IN A TIMELY MANNER.
EVERYONE WHO HAS THE
OPPORTUNITY EVERYONE HOWEVER
DOES HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
SUBMIT TESTIMONY ON ANY BILL
BEING HEARD TODAY ON THE HEALTH
COMMITTEE WEBSITE. SO WITH THAT
I BELIEVE WE HAVE OUR FIRST
AUTHOR HERE TODAY. SO WE'LL
BEGIN WITH ITEM NUMBER ONE
EIGHTY SIXTY ONE BY SUMMER
GABRIEL- WELCOME. PLEASE BEGIN.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
CHAIR AND I WANT TO THANK YOU
AND YOUR COMMITTEE STAFF FOR
YOUR THOUGHTFUL ATTENTION TO
THIS BILL AND WE WILL BE
ACCEPTING THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS
TODAY. AND I'M PLEASED TODAY TO
PRESENT ASSEMBLY BILL SIXTY ONE
AS SMALL RESTAURANTS ACROSS
CALIFORNIA CONTINUE TO STRUGGLE
TO SURVIVE. IT'S CRITICAL THAT
THIS BODY FACILITATES EXPANDED
OUTDOOR DINING FOOD PREPARATION
AND SERVICE OPTION. IN THIS
BILL WOULD EMPOWER LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS IN A. B. C. TO
PROVIDE MUCH NEEDED REGULATORY
RELIEF. TO SUPPORT STRUGGLING
RESTAURANTS ACROSS THE GOLDEN
STATE. NEIGHBORHOOD RESTAURANTS
ARE THE BACKBONE OF COMMUNITIES
ACROSS CALIFORNIA BUT TOO MANY
OF THEM ARE BARELY HANGING ON
BY A THREAD. OUTDOOR DINING
OFFERS A LIFELINE IN AN
EXCITING OPPORTUNITY. TO
ENCOURAGE RESTAURANTS TO RE
DISCOVER NEW USES FOR THEIR OWN
SPACE. AS WE CONTINUE RE
OPENING OUTDOOR DINING IS
LIKELY TO BE CRITICAL FOR THE
NEAR FUTURE. AN ABC SIXTY ONE
INTEREST CALIFORNIA FULLY
SUPPORTS OUR SMALL BUSINESSES
AND I WILL SAY. ON A PERSONAL
LEVEL WITH THREE. VERY YOUNG.
UNVACCINATED CHILDREN OUTDOOR
DINING IS CONTINUE TO BE PART
OF OUR FAMILY'S PLAN FOR THE
FORESEEABLE FUTURE SO. WE ARE
PROUD OF THIS BILL WE'RE PROUD
TO PARTNER WITH THE CALIFORNIA
RESTAURANT ASSOCIATION ON THIS
EFFORT. AND HERE WITH ME TODAY
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL. R. MATT SUTTON THE SENIOR
VICE PRESIDENT OF GOVERNMENT
AFFAIRS AT THE CALIFORNIA
RESTAURANT ASSOCIATION. AND
MADELINE ALFANO THE OWNER OF
MARIA'S ITALIAN KITCHEN WHERE
MY WIFE AND KIDS HAD DINNER ON
MONDAY NIGHT IN ENCINO AND-
MADELINE I'M SORRY FOR THE MESS
THAT THEY MADE. WITHOUT WOULD
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AND I
VOTE. THANK YOU SO MUCH CENTER
GABRIEL APPRECIATE YOU ARE
WORKING WITH MY STAFF AND
TAKING THE AMENDMENTS WILL
BEGIN WITH WHAT BUT THIS IS A
FORCE. IN SUPPORT- BEGAN WITH
THAT MATCH CERTAIN CALIFORNIA
RESTAURANT ASSOCIATION UP IN
THE GALLERY WELCOME YOU HAVE
TWO MINUTES. FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY. THANK YOU GOOD
AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN SENATORS
MATT SUTTON WITH CALIFORNIA
RESTAURANT ASSOCIATION WE ARE
THE SPONSOR. OF THE LEGISLATION
AND HOPEFULLY YOU HAVE SEEN IF
NOT EXPERIENCE MANY OF THESE
NEW REINVENTED OUTDOOR DINING
SPACES THROUGHOUT. YOUR
DISTRICT'S AB SIXTY ONE IS
REALLY ABOUT CONTINUING THOSE.
FOR A TEMPORARY PERIOD OF TIME.
AS THE RESTAURANT COMMUNITY.
BEGINS THE LONG ROAD TO
RECOVERY. WHAT THE BILLS TO.
DOES IS THE GLASS. ABC OFFERED-
WHAT'S CALLED A TEMPORARY
CATERING AUTHORIZATION AND THAT
PIECE. ALLOWS FOR THESE OUTDOOR
DINING SPACES YOU KNOW AGAIN
AND REINVENTED SPACES SO THESE
ARE NOT YOUR RESTAURANT PATIOS
THESE ARE AREAS THAT ARE
ADJACENT TO RESTAURANTS. OR
ANOTHER CREATIVE SPACES THAT
CITIES HAVE OFFERED. THE KEY
HERE IS A. B. SIXTY ONE ALLOWS
FOR A STREAMLINED PROCESS FOR
RESTAURANTS. TO ACTUALLY
ACHIEVE THAT SPACE WITH ALCOHOL
SERVICES WELL. THE SECOND PIECE
THAT'S IN HERE THAT I THINK IS
DIRECTLY RELATED TO THE
JURISDICTION OF THIS COMMITTEE.
DEALS WITH- THE CALIFORNIA
RETAIL FOOD CODE ALLOWING SOME
FLEXIBILITY. AGAIN WITH THE
IDEA THAT OUTDOOR DINING IS
GOING TO BE A PRIORITY FOR MANY
PEOPLE. INCLUDING THE REFERENCE
THAT THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER MADE
AND THIS PORTION ALLOWS A
STREAMLINED PROCESS FOR WHAT'S
CALLED SATELLITE FOOD
PREPARATION WHICH IS REALLY
LIKE FOOD PREPARATION. AN
EXAMPLE WOULD BE LIKE HAVING A
COFFEE CART OR SOMETHING
SIMILAR- YOU STILL GO THROUGH
ALL THE SAME PROTOCOLS- BUT YOU
DON'T HAVE A LOT OF THOSE
BARRIERS ON THE FRONT END AND
SO. THERE'S COUNTLESS PROGRAMS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE- ON THESE
REINVENTED DINING PROGRAMS A.
B. SIXTY ONE IS THE BRIDGE.
THAT ALLOWS RESTAURANTS TO
CONTINUE TO SERVE THE PUBLIC IN
THIS WAY- AND TAKE SOME OF THE
FLEXIBILITY THAT THE ABC WAS
GOOD ENOUGH TO OFFER. AND
EXTENDS THOSE UP FOR A FEW
YEARS AS RESTAURANTS CONTINUE
TO CLIMB OUT OF THE STRUGGLE
WERE AND SO THANK YOU SO MUCH.
THANKS VERY MUCH NO MODERATOR
PLEASE BRING ON THE LINE
MANDOLIN ALFANO FROM MARIA'S
ITALIAN KITCHEN TO PROVIDE
TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT- YOU HAVE
TWO MINUTES ACTUALLY CAN HAVE A
LITTLE MORE SO TO GIVE YOU MORE
TIME. PLEASE BEGIN IN MY OWN
YES YOU ARE. MANNEQUIN OKAY
THANK YOU CHAIRMAN JANET
CENTERS I MADELINE O'CONNOR THE
OWNER PLEASE CHANGE YOUR CHIN
WITH A CASUAL NEIGHBORHOOD
LOCATIONS THROUGHOUT THE
GREATER LOS ANGELES AREA. I'M
ALSO THE PROUD CHAIRMAN OF THE
CALIFORNIA RESTAURANT
ASSOCIATION BOARD OF DIRECTORS.
THE MARINES IN BUSINESS FOR
OVER FORTY YEARS AND WE HAVE
SURVIVED EARTHQUAKES RIOTS.
FIRES FLOODS AND HOW THAT WILL
WILL PANDEMIC BUT BECAUSE OF
THE CLOSE. DOWN TO LOCATIONS
CURRENTLY. EIGHTY SIX ALL OUT
SOME BIG TO COME OUT OF THE BAD
AND HOPEFULLY WITH YOUR HELP.
THE MADE THE LAST THE TANGIBLE
TO ASSIST WITH. COMPANIES IT'S
DIFFICULT EIGHTY SIX ONE OF
FOCUSED ON. THOSE MANY OF THOSE
WONDERFUL PROGRAMS THROUGHOUT
THE STATE THAT ENCOURAGE
RESTAURANTS HAVE EXPANDED THE
OUTDOOR DINING SET FOR. WELL
OVER THE LAST YEAR RESTAURANTS
ISN'T SUBJECT TO ALMOST WEEKLY
OPERATING STATE AND LOCAL
DIRECTIVES WITH REGARDS TO
WHETHER WE COULD OPERATE A
RESTAURANT INSIDE. OUTSIDE HE
GOES TO LIBERATE THE HITS JUST
KEPT ON COMING AND BECAUSE OUR
FOCUS IS HOSPITALITY WE WORK TO
KEEP OUR DOORS OPEN TO SERVE
OUR EMPLOYEES OUR CUSTOMERS AND
OUR COMMUNITIES. RESTAURANT
OWNERS LEARN TO TURN THESE
OBSTACLES INTO OPPORTUNITIES.
NOW THAT WE ARE ALLOWED BY THE
STATE TO OPEN WITHOUT CAPACITY
LIMITATIONS PHYSICAL PHYSICAL
CAN. BEGIN THAT LONG ROAD TO
RECOVERY. IT IS IMPORTANT NOTE
THOUGH THAT RIO THE STEEP WHITE
RESTAURANT NEED TO NOT WE OPEN.
MANY STILL STRUGGLE TO STACK UP
ADEQUATE LEVELS. AFTER DINING
IN A SERVICE TO THE REGULATORY
RELIEF PROVIDED BY THE ATC AT
THE OFFICE OF THE PANDEMIC HAS
BEEN A LIFELINE FOR TO SERVE
OUR GUESTS. IN EACH CONTINUE
REQUIREMENT. AMAZING TEAM
MEMBERS. I CHURCH ITSELF RUSSIA
THIRTY I READ MANY CALLS I KNOW
THIS TO BE TRUE FOR COUNTLESS
OTHER RESTAURANTS THROUGHOUT
THE STATE. EIGHTY SIXTY ONE
FIFTY SIX EMERGENCY ROOM FOR ME
PROVIDED BY THE ABC IN THE
SPRING OF TWENTY TWENTY ALLOW
THE STREAMLINED PROCESS FOR
RESTAURANTS TO GET APPROVAL
SIXTY EXPANDED OUTDOOR DINING.
FOR BEING ITALIAN ALFRESCO
DINING AS I LIKE TO CALL. IT
MAKES THEM LAUGH BEYOND THE
PANDEMIC IN EACH OF THE
RESTAURANT RECOVERY PERIOD.
THIS WILL BE CRITICAL AT THE
RESTAURANT WITH COVERING
CALIFORNIA WILL TAKE SEVERAL
YEARS ASSUMING WE COULD TAKE
GOOD POLICIES LIKE THOSE MAYBE
SIXTY ONE. AND MAKE THAT
HAPPEN. THIRTY SEVEN NO FURTHER
HARM. TO THE STAGE RESTAURANT.
AFTER THAT AT. MAY A POSITIVE
SOLUTION ON THE- NOT JUST A
BUSINESS IT'S- FOR YOUR CALL.
WHO LIVE THE LEAGUE WRAP UP.
TOLD ME HELLO THEY LOVE IT
THANK YOU MUCH I REALLY
APPRECIATE SUPPORT FOR THE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH YOUR TEST.
WILL MOVE ON TO A DISH WITNESS
IN SUPPORT OF AB SIXTY ONE WILL
BEGIN THE PUBLIC GALLERY SCENE
ON PUBLIC GALLERY MOVED TO ROOM
AT TWENTY FORTY SEEN ON ROUTE
TWENTY FORTY. MODERATOR PLEASE
OPEN THE LINES FOR WITNESSES
WHO WISH TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT
OF EIGHTY SIXTY ONE. NAME
ORGANIZATION POSITION ONLY.
THANK YOU MR CHAIR OR COMMENT
IN SUPPORT AND EIGHTY SIXTY ONE
PLEASE PRESS ONE AT THAT ZERO.
THAT COMMAND AGAIN ONE SEVEN
ZERO. YEAH. LINE ONE HUNDRED
FORTY THREE OR MIKE AT THE.
GOOD AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS. HOP ON BEHALF OF THE
CITY OF SAN DIEGO AND STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU NEXT LINE.
ONE HUNDRED THIRTY FIVE. GET UP
IN THE FUTURE MEMBERS MARTHA
GUERRERO REPRESENTING THE LOS
ANGELES COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS AND SUPPORT. THANK
YOU NEXT LINE. ONE HUNDRED
FIFTY THREE. I CAN'T REMEMBER
pMONICA AND LOS ANGELES MAYOR
ERIC GARCETTI IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU NEXT LINE. ONE HUNDRED
FORTY FIVE. GOOD AFTERNOON MR
CHAIRMAN SENATORS CLIFF COSTA
BEHALF OF THE BOWLING CENTERS
OF SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK YOU
NEXT TIME. MR SURE THERE ARE NO
FURTHER COMMENT AT THIS TIME.
THANKS VERY MUCH WILL NOW MOVE
TO OPPOSITION TO EIGHTY SIXTY
ONE- WE DO HAVE ONE LEAD
OPPOSITION WITNESS SO MODERATOR
PLEASE BRING ON THE LINE
MICHAEL SUPER FROM THE- ALCOHOL
JUSTICE- SINCE THE PROPONENTS
SAID TWO WITNESSES AND RECEIVED
FOUR MINUTES- ALLOW YOU UP TO
FOUR MINUTES SO THAT YOU DON'T
HAVE TO TAKE ALL THE TIME YOU
DON'T WISH- PLEASE- BEGIN WHEN
YOU'RE READY. THANK YOU GOOD
AFTERNOON- GERMAN FANS HELP
COMMITTEE MEMBERS- I MIGHT SKIP%
THE DIRECTOR OF PUBLIC AFFAIRS
AT ALCOHOL JUSTICE. AND I
APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY
TODAY TO RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE AB
SIXTY ONE. AND LIKE THE
COMMITTEE TO UNDERSTAND- OUR
REASONING BEHIND THIS POSITION.
AS OUR COMMUNITIES RECOVER FROM
THIS MOST SEVERE HEALTH CRISIS
OF OUR LIFETIME. THE EXPANSION
OF ALCOHOL CONSUMPTION I SHOULD
NOT BE OUR PRIORITY WITH ALL
DUE RESPECT TO THE ALTAR AND
OUR SHARED CONCERN FOR THE MANY
SMALL BUSINESSES THAT HAVE
SUFFERED THROUGHOUT THE
PANDEMIC. RELIEF FOR THEM
SHOULD NOT COME AT THE EXPENSE
OF THE PUBLIC HEALTH AND SAFETY
OF ALL CALIFORNIA RESIDENTS AND
VISITORS. ACCORDING TO THE
CENTERS FOR DISEASE CONTROL A
CALIFORNIA CURRENTLY SUFFERS
MORE ANNUAL ALCOHOL RELATED
HARM THAN ANY OTHER STATE. OVER
TEN THOUSAND FIVE HUNDRED
ALCOHOL RELATED DEATHS OVER A
HUNDRED AND EIGHTY THOUSAND
EMERGENCY ROOMVISITS. FOURTEEN
POINT FIVE BILLION IN STATE
COSTS AND THIRTY FIVE BILLION
IN TOTAL COST EIGHTY. THAT
EQUALS NEARLY A THOUSAND
DOLLARS PER RESIDENT FOR TWO
DOLLARS AND FORTY FOUR CENTS
PER DRINK. THIS ANNUAL
CATASTROPHE OF ALCOHOL RELATED
HARM HAS BEEN ACCELERATING OVER
THE PAST TWENTY YEARS. A NEW
WORLD HEALTH ORGANIZATION STUDY
PUBLISHED JUST YESTERDAY. IN
THE JOURNAL LANCET ONCOLOGY
FOUND THAT ONE OUT OF SEVEN NEW
CANCER CASES IN TWENTY TWENTY
FOUR IT SHOULD BE ABLE TO
ALCOHOL. INSTEAD OF ENCOURAGING
ALCOHOL CONSUMPTION. WE SHOULD
BE FOCUSED AT THIS TIME ON HARM
REDUCTION. NOT RUBBER STAMPING
THE EXTENSION OF COLD IT
ALCOHOL DEREGULATION IN AB
SIXTY ONE SUCH IS EXPANDED
ALCOHOLIC BEVERAGE SALES AND
OUTDOOR DINING IN PUBLIC AREAS
SUCH AS SIDEWALKS AND STREETS.
WHICH BY THE WAY ALSO POSE A
SIGNIFICANT THREAT ADA
COMPLIANCE WITH PEOPLE WITH
DISABILITIES. WHAT WE REALLY
NEED OUR PUBLIC HEALTH%
STRATEGIES TO REDUCE ALCOHOL
AVAILABILITY AND CONSUMPTION TO
BRING TRUE ELIEF TO ALL
RESIDENTS AND THE STATE. NOT
JUST THE BUSINESSES THAT DEPEND
ON ALCOHOL CONSUMPTION TO
REMAIN PROFITABLE. WE
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR NOBLE
ON A. B. SIXTY ONE THANK YOU.
THANKS VERY MUCH WHEN I MOVED
ON TO ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION TO AB SIXTY ONE
AGAIN PUBLIC GALLERY SCENE ON
THE PUBLIC GALLERY LET'S MOVE
TO ROOM TWENTY FORTY C. NORMAN
TWENTY FORTY MODERATOR PLEASE
OPEN THE LINES FOR WITNESSES
WHO SHOULD TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION TO AB SIXTY ONE
NAME. ORGANIZATION AND POSITION
ONLY. FOUR COMMENTS IN
OPPOSITION TO EIGHTY THREE
SIXTY ONE PLEASE PRESS ONE AT
THAT ZERO. COMMENT AGAIN. ONE
ZERO. AND WE DO HAVE A COMMENT
COMING THROUGH ONE MOMENT
PLEASE WHILE WHILE WE PROVIDE
THEM WITH CAROLINE OKAY. YEAH.
ONE MORE MOMENT PLEASE I
APOLOGIZE. EDIT LINE ONE
HUNDRED FORTY SEVEN YOUR MIKE
AT THE. I'M LEARNING MY UNCLE
MANNY FROM CALLING ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA ALCOHOL POLICY
ALLIANCE- YARD STRONG
OPPOSITION TO IT THE WIND
REALLY CALL INTO QUESTION THANK
YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT
LINE THANK YOU. THANK YOU
THANKS LINE. IT'S BETTER CARE
WE HAVE NO FURTHER COMMENT THAT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH- WELL NOW
THEN BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE OF THE QUESTIONS COME
IN SOME COMMITTEE MEMBERS. YES
SIR GONZALEZ. Q. TO THE AUTHOR
HAPPY TO CO AUTHORED THIS BILL
I KNOW MANY- I THINK YOU YOU
DID THIS AT THE RIGHT TIME WITH
GOOD INTENT TO ENSURE THAT OUR
SMALL BUSINESSES- CAN BETTER
GET BACK AND RECOVER- AND A LOT
OF THEM HAVE I'VE REACHED OUT
TO MANY OF OUR OFFICES I'M SO
GLAD TO SUPPORT AND MOVE THE
BILL WHEN APPROPRIATE IF WE
HAVE A COMMITTEE THAT TO DO SO.
WHEN WE HAVE A COMMITTEE TO DO
SO. ALL RIGHT THANK YOU- YEAH
WE DON'T HAVE A QUORUM YET SO
WE CAN'T TECHNICIANS. YET BUT-
KEEP THAT IN MIND- ACTUALLY-
SUMMER GAY BRO I APPRECIATE.
WHAT YOU'RE DOING IN THE BILL-
I CERTAINLY HEAR THE OPPOSITION
IN TERMS OF THEIR CONCERNS
ABOUT THE NEGATIVE EFFECTS OF
ALCOHOL BUT- I DON'T BELIEVE
YOUR BILL IS SUCH THAT. WOULD
PROMPTS- THAT IS- CONCERNS
SIGNIFICANTLY ALTHOUGH
CERTAINLY BUT THERE MAY BE
INDIVIDUAL INCIDENTS- BUT I
THINK THAT'S FOR LOCAL
GOVERNMENT TO ADDRESS- AND
CERTAINLY WE'VE HAD EXPERIENCE
WITH THIS IS AN EXTENSION OF AN
EXISTING- A SITUATION THAT-
THAT THAT WE SEEN ACTUALLY. IN
GENERALS HAD A MORE POSITIVE
EFFECT IN MY MIND- THAT I'VE
HEARD- IN TERMS OF NOT ONLY
HELPING THE BUSINESS BUT ALSO.
HELPING THE COMMUNITY AS WELL-
YOU GET ACCESS TO- TO. THAT
RESTAURANTS AND FOOD HERE IN
CALIFORNIA AS E ARE STILL
STRUGGLING WITH A PANDEMIC IN
CREATING A SAFER OPTION FOR
PEOPLE THAT PEOPLE ARE MORE
COMFORTABLE WITH. SO WITH THAT
I WOULD LIKE TO CLOSE. YEAH
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MR CHAIRMAN
I WANT TO THANK SENATOR
GONZALEZ FOR HER FOR HER
SUPPORT- I WOULD JUST SAY ONE
THING I'M I'M A LITTLE BIT TO
BE TOTALLY HONEST MYSTIFIED BY
THE OPPOSITION- YOU KNOW I AM.
I AM NOT AWARE OF ANY PUBLIC
HEALTH RESEARCH THAT SUGGESTS
THAT FOLKS ARE MORE LIKELY TO
ORDER A GLASS OF WINE IF THEY
SIT OUTSIDE. I AM AWARE OF A
LOT OF PUBLIC HEALTH RESEARCH
THAT SAID FOLKS ARE MUCH SAFER
FROM COVERED IF THEY SIT
OUTSIDE SO THIS BILL IS NOT
JUST ABOUT PROTECTING SMALL
BUSINESSES WHICH I THINK IS AN
URGENT MARTY AND IN AND OF
ITSELF. WOULD BE WHICH WOULD
JUSTIFY THE MEASURE BUT IT'S
ALSO ABOUT PROTECTING PUBLIC
HEALTH AND SAFETY AND HARM
REDUCTION IN ALL OF THE THINGS
THAT THE OPPONENTS AIRPORT TO
THEMSELVES. ON BEHALF OF SO
MANY SMALL BUSINESSES UP AND
DOWN. THE STATE THAT ARE BARELY
HANGING ON BY A THREAD FOR WHOM
THIS OFFERS A LIFELINE WOULD
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AND I
BOTH. THANK YOU SO MUCH CENTER
GABRIEL AGAIN- ONCE WE HAVE A
QUORUM- WE LOOK FORWARD TO
TAKING UP YOUR BILL UP FOR A
VOTE. THANKS VERY MUCH ALL
RIGHT. LET'S NOW MOVE ON TO
ITEM NUMBER TWO EIGHTY NINETY
SEVEN BY SUMMER IN THIS AREA. I
SEE IN HERE. SO JUST. GIVE US A
MOMENT TO TIDY UP THE PODIUM.
ALL RIGHT WELCOME. PLEASE BEGIN
WHEN YOU'RE READY. THANK YOU MR
CHAIR AND SENATORS AT LEAST ONE
SENATOR RIGHT NOW A. B. NINETY
SEVEN TO PROHIBIT. FOR A BIT
THANK YOU. THREE NINETY SEVEN
WOULD PROHIBIT A PLAN TO HEALTH
PLANS BEGINNING OF. AB NINETY
SEVEN WOULD PROHIBIT A HEALTH
PLAN BEGINNING JANUARY TWO THE
TWENTY TWENTY TWO FROM IMPOSING
A DEDUCTIBLE ON AN INSULIN
PRESCRIPTION OVER FOUR MILLION
CALIFORNIANS SUFFER FROM
DIABETES WHICH MEANS. FOR THESE
CALIFORNIANS INSULIN IS AN
ESSENTIAL PART OF A HEALTHY
LIFE. HOWEVER BETWEEN
200-072-2000 EIGHTEEN THE PRICE
OF INSULIN HAS INCREASED OVER
TWO HUNDRED AND SIXTY TWO
PERCENT. THIS IS THE
SKYROCKETING PRICES
UNATTAINABLE FOR MANY
CALIFORNIANS OFTEN CAUSING
UNDUE BURDEN. ON OUR HEALTHCARE
SYSTEM AND FORCING MANY WHO
CAN'TAFFORD THEIR MEDICINE TO
SELL FRESHEN AND LEADER BEING
ADMITTED TO AN EMERGENCY ROOM.
ACCORDING TO THE STUDY
PUBLISHED IN THE JOURNAL OF
AMERICAN MEDICINE IN TWO
THOUSAND EIGHTEEN. NEARLY 26%
OF DIABETICS PRESCRIBED.
INSULIN REPORTED COST RELATED
UNDER USE LEADING TO POOR
GLYCEMIC CONTROL AND POTENTIAL
HEALTH PROBLEMS THAT ARE EVEN
MORE COSTLY AND POTENTIALLY
DEADLY. DUE TO THE PANDEMIC AS
PEOPLE BEGIN TO LOSE THEIR JOBS
THE STATISTICS WERE ONLY
FURTHER EXACERBATED ESPECIALLY
FOR PEOPLE OF COLOR. ACCORDING
TO CALIFORNIA HEALTH BENEFITS
REVIEW PROGRAM CHIPPER.
ANALYSIS APPROXIMATELY ONE OUT
OF THREE CALIFORNIANS IN THE H.
C. N. DEPARTMENT OF INSURANCE
REGULATED PLANS USING INSULIN
FOR ROUGHLY 360-007-0050 PEOPLE
WOULD BENEFIT FROM EXEMPTING
INSULIN FROM INSURANCE
DEDUCTIBLES. WHICH CHIPPER ALSO
FOUND A PREPONDERANCE OF
EVIDENCE THAT HIGHER COST
SHARING. REDUCES APPEARANCE TO
INSULIN AND LOWER COST SHARING
INCREASES APPEARANCE TAKE
INSULIN AND THAT COST SHARING
FOR INSULIN IS EFFECTIVE IN
IMPROVING ADHERENCE TO INSULIN
IN PATIENTS WITH DIABETES.
PROPONENTS OF MY BALL WILL BILL
WILL SAY THAT EIGHTEEN NINETY
SEVEN WILL RAISE PREMIUMS BY
OVER TWENTY FOUR MILLION
DOLLARS. BUT ACCORDING TO
CHIPPER AB NINETY SEVEN WOULD
INCREASE TOTAL NET ANNUAL
EXPENDITURES BY TEN MILLION. OR
ONLY ROUGHLY LESS THAN 1% FOR
ENROLLEES- THAT'S LESS THAN ONE
DOLLAR. TO GO FURTHER ACCORDING
TO ACCORDING TO THE SENATE
BUDGET SUBCOMMITTEE ON HEALTH
AND HUMAN SERVICES CALIFORNIANS
SPENT TWO HUNDRED AND NINETY
TWO BILLION ON HEALTHCARE IN
TWO THOUSAND FOURTEEN TEN
MILLION IS LESS THAN ONE HALF
OF 1% OF THAT NUMBER. BY
LIMITING COST SHARING FOR
INSULIN A. B. NINETY SEVEN WILL
MAKE INSULIN MORE AFFORDABLE
FOR ONE THIRD OF THOSE WHO USE
INSULIN ON STATE REGULATED
PLANS DECREASE OUT OF POCKET
EXPENSES BY AN AVERAGE OF 50%
DECREASE HOSPITAL VISITS THAT
CAN INCREASE UNNECESSARY
EXPOSURE TO CURRENT AFFAIRS OR
WHATEVER FUTURE PANDEMIC
VIRUSES MAYBE. AND DECREASE
EMERGENCY HOSPITAL VISITS AND
AS MENTIONED EARLIER WITHOUT
EVEN RAISING THE COST OF
PREMIUMS BY A DOLLAR TODAY I AM
JOINED BY DR FRANCISCO PO OF
THE NATIONAL ADVOCACY COMMITTEE
OF THE AMERICAN DIABETES
ASSOCIATION AND MICHELLE LU CEO
OF HEALTH TRUST. THANKS SO
MUCH- CENTER IN THIS AREA AND-
WILL NOW BRING. ON THE LINE THE
WITNESS IS TESTIFYING IN
SUPPORT SO MODERATOR PLEASE
BRING ON THE LINE MICHELLE LIU
FROM THE HEALTH TRUST N.
FRANCISCO PREETA FROM THEN
NATIONAL F. AND AMERICAN
DIABETES ASSOCIATION BEGAN
WITH- MICHELLE LU- YOU HAVE
FOUR MINUTES BETWEEN THE TWO IF
YOU'LL GIVE ME TWO MINUTE
WARNING SOME SHOW LOU GIVE YOU
TWO MINUTES. PLEASE BEGIN WHEN
YOU'RE READY. THANK YOU GOOD
AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE MY NAME IS
MICHELLE A SERVICE HE HE GO TO
HELP TRACK A CO SPONSOR OF
EIGHTEEN NINETY SEVEN THE HELP
OF THE NONPROFIT OPERATING
FOUNDATION CENTER DAY WITH A
MISSION TO BUILD HEALTH EQUITY
AND TELECOM DAILY. FOR OVER A
DECADE WE'VE PROVIDED COMMUNITY
HEALTH EDUCATION FOR PEOPLE
LIVING WITH DIABETES.
SUPPORTING THEM TO BETTER
ANAGE THEIR CONDITION AND LIVE
A HEALTHIER LIFE. THROUGH THIS
WORK WE'VE HEARD OVER AND OVER
AT THAT. TIME CALIFORNIA. IN
ORDER TO HAVE ACCESS TO INSULIN.
EXCELLENT CONVALLIS AS IT'S NOT
UNCOMMON TO ASK A STATE OF
CALIFORNIA MANY RESIDENTS A
PULL UP TO HALF OF THEIR INCOME
TOWARD HOUSING FORCING PEOPLE
TO CHOOSE BETWEEN PAYING RENT.
PUTTING FOOD ON THE TABLE OR
BUYING THEIR LIFE SAVING
MEDICATIONS MANY PEOPLE WHO
FACE HIGH OUT OF POCKET COSTS
FOR EMPLOYMENT OR NOT THAT
HEARING TO THEIR CARE PLANS ARE
AND THERE INSTEAD RATIONING
THEIR INSULIN. WHICH CAN
QUICKLY LEAD TO SEVERE HEALTH
COMPLICATIONS AND EVEN DEATH.
EIGHTY NINETY SEVEN PROVIDES A
REASONABLE COST EFFECTIVE
APPROACH FOR ADDRESSING THE
SOCIO ECONOMIC IMPACT OF
DIABETES AND WILL IMPROVE THE
LIVES OF TENS OF THOUSANDS OF
CALIFORNIANS. BY INCLUDING
INSULIN FROM THE TECHNICAL
REQUIREMENTS IMPOSED BY HEALTH
PLANS. WE'RE SO PROUD TO WORK
WITH A FAMILY MEMBER NECESSARY
AND MERICAN DIABETES. FAIL AND
INCREASING COST OF INSULIN HAVE
BEEN A CONCERN FOR YEARS NOW
HELLO AND FINANCIAL
RAMIFICATIONS OF COPING
NINETEEN HAVE EXACERBATED THE
RISKS ASSOCIATED. IN CALIFORNIA
MORE THAN THREE MILLION PEOPLE
HAVE BEEN DIAGNOSED WITH
DIABETES AND THE PREVALENCE
INCREASES WITH OLDER
POPULATIONS COMMUNITIES OF
COLOR AND THOSE WITH BOTH
FAMILY INCOME. COVE IN NINETEEN
MADE A BAD SITUATION WORSE FOR
MANY PEOPLE LIVING WITH
DIABETES WHICH IS WHY EIGHTY
NINETY SEVEN- MORE IMPORTANT
THAN EVER TO PROTECT PEOPLE
LIVING WITH DIABETES. TEN
MINUTES ALL AFFECT THE INSULIN.
HELLO KITTY PREACHES NEW TO
LEAD ON THIS ISSUE AND VOTE I.
NINETY SEVEN THANK YOU SO MUCH.
THANKS VERY MUCH- MODERATE
PLEASE BRING ON DR FRANCISCO
PRIO FROM THE AMERICAN DIABETES
ASSOCIATION YOU HAVE A MINUTE
FORTY NINE SECONDS. HI GOOD
AFTERNOON- THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS I HOPE YOU CAN
HEAR ME YES PLEASE AGAIN. YES
MY NAME IS DR CONSISTS OF THREE
UP ON HERE ON BEHALF OF THE
AMERICAN DIABETES ASSOCIATION
AND I CHAIRED THE ASSOCIATION'S
NATIONAL ADVOCACY COMMITTEE.
I'VE BEEN A PRACTICING
PHYSICIAN IN SACRAMENTO AREA
FOR OVER THIRTY YEARS AND
ADVOCATE FOR PATIENTS WITH
DIABETES AND I'M ASKING YOUR
SUPPORT FOR A. B. NINETY SEVEN.
THIS IS MODERN LEGISLATION
AIMED AT REDUCING THE COST OF
INSULIN FOR CALIFORNIANS WHO
RELY ON IT TO LIVE. AS YOU
HEARD BETWEEN THREE AND FOUR
MILLION CALIFORNIANS HAVE
DIAGNOSED DIABETES AND
APPROXIMATELY 30% OF THOSE
INDIVIDUALS NEED INSULIN TO
LIVE. PLEASE COST OF
PRESCRIPTION DRUGS HAVE
BLOODIED OUTSIZED BURDEN ON
EVERYDAY AMERICANS EVEN THOSE
WITH INSURANCE. AND ONE
IMPORTANT PHONE USERS ARE
REPORTING THAT THEY CANNOT
AFFORD THEIR MEDICATION AT THAT
STAGE. OR RATIONED DOSES TO PAY
FOR OTHER LIFE ESSENTIALS LIKE
RENT INCLUDING UTILITIES.
BOEING WITHOUT NEEDED INSULIN
CAN RESULT IN THE RAPID ONSET
OF SICKNESS OR DEATH DURING THE
PANDEMIC RATIONING OF DOES THIS
KERRY INCREASED RISK AS STUDIES
SHOW THAT PEOPLE WITH DIABETES
PARTICULARLY THOSE WITH POORLY
CONTROLLED GROUP CALLED
HORRIBLE. ARE INCREASED RISK
FOR DEATH AND COATED NINETEEN.
FIRST DEATH CERTIFICATE I FIND
THEM THE RESULTS OF THE
COMPANY'S NINETEEN PANDEMIC WAS
IN A PATIENT OF MINE WITH
DIABETES- THE TUBERCULOSIS BUT
YOU HEARD FOUND THAT EIGHTY
NINETY SEVEN WOULD HELP ONE
THIRD OF CALIFORNIANS USE
INSULIN FOR IN. PLANS THAT OUR
DEPARTMENT OF MANAGED HEALTH
CARE DEPARTMENT OF INSURANCE
REGULATED- EIGHTY NINETY SEVEN
WOULD HELP PEOPLE WITH DIABETES
BY EXEMPTING INSULIN COULD
DEDUCTIBLES AND WILL PROVIDE
FIRST DOLLAR COVERAGE
ELIMINATING THE EXORBITANT
COSTS WERE INFORMED
PARTICULARLY AT THE BEGINNING
OF EACH PLAN YEAR WHEN THE
DEDUCTIBLE LIMIT RESETS FOR
MOST PEOPLE. IN LIGHT OF MY
COME ABOUT. BETWEEN COLBERT
NINETEEN DEATHS AND DIABETES
MAKING SURE THE CALIFORNIANS
ARE ABLE TO AND HEAR THEIR
ENCOURAGEMENT. IS EXTREMELY
IMPORTANT THANK YOU HEARD THAT.
THANK YOU THAT THAT THIS WILL
NOT ONLY REDUCE THE RISKS
ASSOCIATED WITH CODE BUT IT CAN
REDUCE THE RISK OF OTHER
DIABETES COMPLICATIONS AND
PLACED THE EMPHASIS WHERE IT
MATTERS I'M KEEPING PEOPLE
HEALTHY PREVENTING COSTLY
DEFACING THESE RAPIDLY
COMPLICATIONS. I RESPECTFULLY
IN THE- ONE OTHER POINT ABOUT
SURE BUT NOW IT'S ACTUALLY
ABSOLUTELY AT THE TIME YOUR
TIME IS UP I APPRECIATE IT-
THANKS SO MUCH DR- WE ACTUALLY
DO HAVE- DESCRIPTION TO
SUBURBAN ALLISON ANALYSIS
APPRECIATE YOUR TESTIMONY- BUT
TO BE FAIR I HAVE TO GIVE EQUAL
TIME ON BOTH SIDES. SO THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR TESTIMONY
WILL NOW TAKE ADDITIONAL
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OF
EIGHTEEN NINETY SEVEN NAME OR
Z. POSITION ONLY BEGIN WITH THE
PUBLIC GALLERY. THEY KNOW WHAT
PUBLIC LET'S MOVE THROUGH
TWENTY FORTY SEEN ON ROUTE
TWENTY FORTY MODERATOR PLEASE
OPEN THE LINES FOR WITNESSES
WHO WISH TO. TESTIFY IN SUPPORT
OF EIGHTEEN NINETY SEVEN NAME
ORGANIZATION AND POSITION ONLY
THANK YOU. OR COMMENT IN
SUPPORT OF EIGHTEEN NINETY
SEVEN PLEASE PRESS ONE AT THAT
ZERO. THAT COMMAND AGAIN ONE
ZERO. WELL I DON'T ONE HUNDRED
FIFTY FOUR OF YOUR MY GET UP.
MR MEMBERS RYAN SPENCER ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA PODIA
ETTRICK MEDICAL ASSOCIATION AND
THE AMERICAN COLLEGE OF OBGYN
STRETCHES NINE IT'S A PORT
THANK YOU NEXT LINE. LINE. ONE
HUNDRED SIXTY EIGHT. MEDIA BORN
REPRESENTING AMERICAN ACADEMY
OF PEDIATRICS CALIFORNIA
DIVISION WE'RE IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU NEXT LINE. LINE. ONE
HUNDRED EIGHTEEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON MEMBERS UNDER I GET
TEARS ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA LIFE SCIENCES IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU NEXT LINE.
THE LIGHT ONE HUNDRED SEVENTY
SEVEN. ONE ONE HUNDRED SEVENTY
SEVEN YOU'RE MY KID UP IN.
WHITE ONE HUNDRED SEVENTY EIGHT.
THANK YOU IN THINKING LOOK IF
YOU'RE TEACHING A PARTNER
HEALTHCARE DISTRICT AND SUPPORT
THANK YOU NEXT LINE. PLAYED ONE
HUNDRED SIXTY NINE. GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIR MEMBERS WERE
STOPPED MAYOR WITH THE AMERICAN
FEDERATION OF STATE COUNTY AND
MUNICIPAL EMPLOYEES AND SUPPORT
THANK YOU THANK YOU NEXT LINE.
ONE ONE HUNDRED FIFTY FIVE. SIX
IS ERIN MCCALLUM AND IN
SUPPORT. OF ADC AT. THANK YOU
NEXT LINE. LINE ONE HUNDRED
SIXTY FOUR. GOOD AFTERNOON
MEDICARE MY NAME IS LINDA KERR
I'M REPRESENTING THE
ASSOCIATION OF DIABETES CARE
AND EDUCATION SPECIALIST AND WE
ARE IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
EIGHTEEN NINETY SEVEN. THANK
YOU NEXT LINE. HEY MISTER CHAIR
THERE ARE THERE'S ONE MORE
COMMENT COMING THROUGH- JUST
QUEUED UP ONE MOMENT PLEASE
WHILE WE PROVIDE THEM WITH
THEIR LIFE NUMBER. ONE MORE
MOMENT PLEASE I APOLOGIZE. AND
NEXT WE WILL GO TO A LINE OF
ONE HUNDRED EIGHTY. WHITE ONE
HUNDRED EIGHTY YEAR MIKE IS
OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON MRSURE
SURE GONZALEZ ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA CHRONIC CARE
COALITION AND STRONG SUPPORT.
THIRTY SIX LINE. THE SURE THERE
ARE NO COM AT THIS. THANKS VERY
MUCH WELL NOW MOVE TO OPPOSITE
TO A NINETY SO WE TO LEAD OFF
WITH. AGAIN TO APIECE TOTAL
IT'S THE TWO IF YOU- LET'S ON
TO THE MODERATOR SLEEPING ON
NICK LOUISA FOR THE CAL
ASSOCIATION OF HEALTH PLANS AND
PRESTON YOUNG FOR THE
CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF COMMERCE-
WILL BEGIN WITH NICK. NICK
LOUISA'S. GREAT THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS- NICKEL
RESERVES ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
HEALTH PLANS ARE. REGRETTABLY
IN OPPOSITION TO ASSEMBLYBILL
NINETY SEVEN- I MEAN WE AGREE
WITH THE AUTHOR IN ONE SENSE OF
COURSE INSULIN IT'S A LIFE
SAVING MEDICATION THAT MILLIONS
OF CALIFORNIANS RELY ON DAILY-
AND SADLY IT'S JUST ONE EXAMPLE
OF A HIGH PRICED DRUG PRICES.
ON THE CRISIS THAT IF WE DO NOT
ADDRESS. I WILL CNTINUE TO
BURDEN OUR HEALTH CARE SYSTEM
AND PUT PATIENTS AT RISK.
REGRETTABLY THIS BILL DOES NOT
HELP THE UNDERLYING PROBLEM.
INSTEAD THIS BILL BY FOCUSING
ON BENEFIT DESIGN. WILL DO YOU
A COUPLE OF THINGS THAT WE
THINK. WILL RESULT IN
UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCES ONE
INCREASE PREMIUMS ON
INDIVIDUALS FAMILIES EMPLOYERS
IN YOUR DISTRICTS. AND OF
COURSE THIS WOULD BE AN
UNFORTUNATE OUTCOME AS WE'VE
SEEN REMARKABLY LOW PREMIUM
INCREASES ARE COVERED
CALIFORNIA OVER THE LAST COUPLE
OF YEARS. GRANTED IT THE OTHER
MENTIONED THE ESTIMATED IMPACT
OF THIS PARTICULAR BILLS MODEST
BUT WE CANNOT LOOK AT IT. IN A
VACUUM WE DO HAVE TO CONSIDER
THIS IN THE CONTEXT OF ALL THE
OTHER MANDATE BILLS. THAT
CUMULATIVELY BE SIMULANTS
HEAVILY INCREASE PREMIUMS ARE
CALIFORNIA BY SIGNIFICANT
DEGREE. NUMBER TWO THE APPROACH
TAKEN. BY M. A. B. NINETY
SEVEN. EMULATED FOR OTHER DRUGS
IN CONDITION COULD FOR OUR PLAN.
DESIGNED OF. WITH FEDERAL RULES.
AROUND BENEFIT DESIGN INOTES
REQUIRE PLANS TO INCREASE OUT
OF POCKET COSTS FOR OTHER
SERVICES. NOW THIS OUTCOME
COMES TO PASS- WE FEEL THE
SUPPORTERS OF THIS TYPE OF
LEGISLATION SHOULD BE PREPARED
TO TELL POLICY MAKERS WHICH
SERVICES WOUD SEE AN INCREASE.
IN OUT OF POCKET COSTS IF THIS
TYPE OF LEGISLATION ENDS UP
THROWING A PRODUCT OUT OF
COMPLIANCE FEDERAL AND STATE
RULES. THERE'S NO CORRESPONDING
EFFECTIVE THIS PROPOSAL- THAT
WOULD LEAD TO ANY REDUCTION IN
THE PRICE OF INSULIN
MANUFACTURERS CHARGE HEALTH
PLANS ARE THE PRECURSORS FOR
THEIR PRODUCTS. WELL IT IS BILL
PASSES THE MANUFACTURERS ARE
FREE TO PRICE OUR PRODUCTS AT
WHATEVER LEVEL INCREASE THE
PRICE ON EXISTING PRODUCTS AND-
WE HAVE SEEN A CONSISTENT PRICE
INCREASED. BY THE MANUFACTURERS
INCLUDING A 55% AVERAGE RISE IN
THE COST OF INSULIN SINCE
TWENTY FOURTEEN TO MINUTES ON
AND HE'S PERFECT PRICES. ARE
GREAT SO LIMITING THE
DEDUCTIBLE DOES NOTHING TO HELP
A LARGER PROBLEM IT JUST
REQUIRES A COPY MADE UP OF ALL
FOR THE BENEFIT DESIGN- IN
THERE FOR THOSE REASONS. WE
OPPOSE THE BILL THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. THEY YOU NOW LET'S BRING
ON PRESTON YOUNG FOR THE
CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF COMMERCE
YOU HAVE A MINUTE AND- I THINK
FORTY FIVE SECONDS. THANK YOU
MR CHAIR COMMITTEE MEMBERS
CRAFTED YOUNG FROM THE
CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF COMMERCE
HERE TODAY AND RESPECTFUL
OPPOSITION TO AB NINETY SEVEN
WELL CERTAINLY WELL INTENTIONED
BUILD UNFORTUNATELY COMES ALONG
WITH UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCES.
OUR PRIMARY CONCERNS WITH
EIGHTEEN NINETY SEVEN ARE THE
COSTS THAT ARE ASSOCIATED WITH
THE BILL DESPITE THE
PRESIDENT'S PLAN REMAINING
UNAFFECTED. BUT EUROPE ANALYSIS
WHICH WAS MENTIONED EARLIER
INDICATED THAT THE BILL WILL
COST IN FULL YEAR PREMIUMS
RIGHT EIGHT HALF MILLION
DOLLARS AN EMPLOYEE PREMIUMS
WOULD RISE NEARLY THREE AND A
HALF MILLION DOLLARS.
ADDITIONALLY AS COMMITTEE
ANALYSIS NOTED AT THE BIGGEST
PREMIUM INCREASE OF THE
EXPERIENCE SMALL REMARK AS-
WELL AS INCREASE ALONG MAY SEEM
TOLERABLE IT MUST BE TAKEN IN
CONTEXT NUMEROUS MANDATES HAVE
BEEN INTRODUCED THIS YEAR AND
COLLECTIVELY THEY INCREASE
PREMIUMS AND HEALTHCARE COSTS
FOR EMPLOYERS. AND EMPLOYEES.
OVER THE LAST FIVE YEARS
AVERAGE FAMILY HEALTH PLAN
PREMIUMS WOULD INCREASE TWENTY
PERCENT. BY TWO THOUSAND TWENTY
KAISER FAMILY FOUNDATION
EMPLOYER HEALTH BENEFITS SURVEY
INDICATED AFTER JOB PAGE
COVERAGE THE AVERAGE ANNUAL
PREMIUM FOR FAMILY COVERAGE
210-003-0040 TWO DOLLARS. WELL
THE B. NINETY SEVEN ADDRESSES
AN IMPORTANT ISSUE WE NEED TO
REMAIN COGNIZANT OF THE
CUMULATIVE IMPACT THESE
MANDATES HAVE UNDERWRITING
HEALTHCARE COSTS UPWARDS.
ADDITIONALLY WE'RE ALSO
CONCERNED THAT THIS BILL WOULD
ENCOURAGE A PIECEMEAL APPROACH
IN ADDRESSING HEALTH CARE
AFFORDABILITY. THE ISSUE SHOULD
BE ADDRESSED HOLISTICALLY
RATHER THAN ON DISEASE BY
DISEASE BASIS FOR THESE REASONS
WERE OPPOSED. EIGHTY NINETY
SEVEN THANKS FOR YOUR TIME
TODAY. THANK YOU- ONE OTHER ON
TO. WITH AN OP. TO EIGHTY NINE
SEVEN OF GOT A CALL GALLERIES
ON THE PA OUT IT'S WAY THROUGH
TO FORTY C. KNOWN TWENTY FOUR.
MODERATOR PLEASE BRING ONTO.
ANY WITNESSES WHO WAS TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION TO EIGHTY
NINETY SEVEN NAME ORGANIZATION
POSITION ONLY. FOUR COMMENTS IN
OPPOSITION TO IT EIGHTY. SEVEN
PLEASE PRESS ONE THE ROW THAT
COMMAND AGAIN ONE. ZERO WHITE
ONE HUNDRED FIFTY SEVEN YOU'RE
MY COULD OPEN. THE CHAIR
MEMBERS JOHN LINGER ON BEHALF
OF AMERICA'S HEALTH INSURANCE
PLANS THAT THE COMMON CAP. ARE
RESPECTIVELY AN OPPOSITION
THANK YOU NEXT LINE. WHITE. ONE
HUNDRED SEVENTY FIVE. HEY ERIN
DRIVERS WITH THEY ASSOCIATION
OF CALIFORNIA LIFE AND HEALTH
INSURANCE COMPANIES IN RESPECT
FOR OPPOSITION THANK YOU NEXT
LINE. MISTER CHAIR THERE ARE NO
FURTHER COMMENT AT THAT TIME.
THANK YOU WE'LL BRING YOUBACK
TO THE COMMITTEE- QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM COMMITTEE
MEMBERS- SENATOR RUBIO. THANK
YOU MR CHAIR AND I WANNA THANK
ALL. EVERYONE THAT CALLED IN-
IN OPPOSITION AND OFTEN SUPPORT
I THINK THIS IS A- VERY
IMPORTANT ISSUE TO DISCUSS SOME
DOUBT THAT PEOPLE ARE GETTING
THEIR THOUGHTS AND- ON I DO.
ACTUALLY HAVE CONCERNS ABOUT
THE CUMULATIVE EFFECTS OF THE
INCREASES I KNOW MAYBE NOT AS
IT PERTAINS TO THIS BILL. BUT
COLLECTIVELY I KNOW THERE'S
BEEN A LOT OF MANDATES- HOWEVER
THIS IS AN ISSUE THAT I THINK
WE CAN ALL AGREE IS A SERIOUS
ONE. I WAS ONE OF THE- CALLERS
NOTED OF SOME OF THE-
INDIVIDUALS ARE HAVING TO
RATION THEIR INSULIN. THEY'RE
HAVING TO CHOOSE BETWEEN THEIR
HEALTH AND PAYING THEIR BILLS
AND JUST. BASED ON THE COST OF
INSULIN I THINK IT'S JUST
UNACCEPTABLE. THAT THEY HAVE TO
CHOOSE BETWEEN THEIR HEALTH IS
SOMETHING AS SIMPLE AS PAYING A
BILL SO I WILL BE SUPPORTING
THE BILL I ALSO WANT TO BE
ADDED AS A CO AUTHOR. I THINK
THIS IS SUCH A LIFE SAVING
MEDICATION THAT NEEDS TO BE
ACCESSIBLE AND AVAILABLE TO
PEOPLE THAT NEED IT. AS THE
COMMITTEE ANALYSIS NOTED THE
COST OF BRAND NAME INSULIN
NEARLY TRIPLED BETWEEN TWENTY
TWO THOUSAND SEVEN AND- TWENTY
EIGHTEEN. AND NO ONE HAS TO.
LEE- SUFFER THE CONSEQUENCES
JUST BECAUSE THEY CAN'T AFFORD
THE MEDICATION I ALSO READ
ANOTHER STUDY BY UCLA HEALTH
WHICH NOTED THAT THE MAJORITY
OF CALIFORNIANS ADULTS NOW HAVE
DIABETES OR PRE DIABETES AND SO
AT SOME POINT OR ANOTHER ALL OF
US WHO MAY HAVE IT AND AGAIN
OVER FOURTEEN OTHER STATES
INCLUDING WASHINGTON DC HAVE
ALREADY MADE ADVANCES IN THIS
PARTICULAR ARENA- ESPECIALLY
BECAUSE WE KEEP HEARING OF THE
PRICES GOING UP AND I THINK
THAT LIMITING THE OUT OF POCKET
COSTS FOR INSULIN WILL HELP SO
MANY OF OUR- DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES AND I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT THAT WE STAND BEHIND
THIS IT WOULD NOT ONLY HELP
THOSE. CURRENTLY ARE NEEDING
THE INSULIN BUT SOME OF US AT
ME IN THE FUTURE- FALL YOU KNOW
VICTIMS OF IT AS WELL SO WITH
THAT I RESPECTFULLY ALSO ASK
FOR YOUR SUPPORT THANK YOU.
OKAY CENTER LATER. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR I REALLY WANT TO
THANK THE AUTHOR FOR BRINGING
THIS BILL FORWARD I WANT TO
ECHO ALL OF THE COMMENTS MADE
BY MY- COLLEAGUE AND ALSO I
WORRY SO MUCH ABOUT CHILDREN
WHO NEED INSULIN AND- AS A
PARENT I CAN'T IMAGINE. HOW
AWFUL IT WOULD BE. TO KNOW THAT
YOU'RE PUTTING YOUR CHILD'S
LIFE IN DANGER BECAUSE YOU
COULD NOT AFFORD. THIS LIFE
SAVING MEDICATION AND CHILDREN
ARE PRETTY MUCH BORN WITH
DIABETES SO IT'S NOT LIKE THEY
DID SOMETHING TO. TO MAKE THIS
HAPPEN. I UNDERSTAND WHERE THE
HEALTH PLANS ARE COMING FROM
BUT WE'VE GOT TO FIGURE THIS
OUT WE CANNOT CONTINUE. TO LET
PEOPLE DIE FROM A DISEASE THAT
OUT THAT WE KNOW IS MANAGEABLE
WE JUST NEED TO MAKE SURE THEY
CAN AFFORD THE MEDICATION SO I
LOOK FORWARD TO SUPPORTING THE
BILL TODAY. THANK YOU. S. C. NO
OTHER- THAT COMES FROM THE
FLOOR- SO SOMEWHERE IN THIS
AREA AND- FIRST OF ALL I DO
APPRECIATE YOU BRINGING THIS
BILL FORWARD I ACTUALLY ONE
ECHO MANY OF THE COMMENTS FOR
MY TWO COLLEAGUES WHO ARE.
CURRENTLY PRESENTS FOR YOUR-
FOR THE PRESENTATION. I THINK
THAT THAT THE CHALLENGE FOR ME
AND AGAIN I ACTUALLY YOU KNOW I
THINK. YOU'RE PUTTING IT FOR
THE GOOD POLICY AND ALL THE
REASONS THAT YOUR WITNESSES
BROUGHT UP AND WHAT- MY
COLLEAGUES HAVE SAID RIGHT WE
SHOULDN'T- THIS IS A LIFE YOU
KNOW IN SOMEONE'S LIFE SAVING
DRUG- THAT DEDUCTIBLE WHICH
WILL BE ELIMINATING IN THIS.
BILL IS A BARRIER TO PEOPLE
GETTING ACCESS TO IT WE DON'T
WANT PEOPLE TO STOP NOT TAKING
THEIR INSULIN. AND ENDING UP IN
THE HOSPITAL OR NAMIBIA
MERCHANTS IN THE HOSPITAL OR
EVEN DYING AS A RESULT OF THAT
AND I. REALLY APPRECIATE THE
SENTIMENTS BEHIND THE BILL. THE
I GUESS THE ISSUE THAT I HAVE
AND WE HAD A SIMILAR BILL HERE
THAT WE PASS OUT THIS COMMITTEE
AS WELL. IS THAT IT'S NOT THE
ONLY DRUG OR CONDITIONAL WEIRD
THIS IS ALSO THE CIRCUMSTANCE
WE HAVE OTHER- CONDITIONS WHERE
WE HAVE YOU KNOW SOMETHING THAT
SIMILAR AGAIN YOU KNOW WHAT IT
IS THE DUCK DOUBLE THE-
PATIENTS CAN'T AFFORD IT. THEY
STOP TAKING THE MEDICATION THEY
END UP IN THE HOSPITAL OR
EMERGENCY ROOM. JUST LIKE- IT'S-
WITH THAT WITH THE DIVING. SO
THE DEFINITELY CHECK FOR ME. IS
THAT- I REALLY APPRECIATE. THIS
THEY DEFINITELY NEED THIS THE
QUESTION IS WHY DO WHAT
EVERYONE ELSE IS IN A SIMILAR
SITUATION JUST BUT THEY DON'T
HAVE DIABETES HAVE A DIFFERENT
DISEASE AND- AND I DO KNOW
THAT- THE- YOU KNOW THE HEALTH
PLANS HAVE TALKED ABOUT NOT
HAVING A DISEASE BY DISEASE
APPROACH ALL RIGHT- SO WHAT WE
DON'T WANT TO HAVE AS WE PASS
THIS BILL WE HAVE THIS AND THEN
SOMEONE LIKE HAS ANOTHER
DISEASE GROUP AND DON'T THEY OF
COURSE NEED IT AND THEN THEN
IT'S SLIGHTLY DIFFERENT ITSELF
BUT EACH DISEASE AND EACH SET
OF DRUGS WE HAVE A SLIGHTLY
DIFFERENT. CO PAY DEDUCTIBLE
WHATEVER ITS INTERESTS THAT WE
HAVE TO NOW WITH THIS KIND OF
LIKE DIFFERENT PATTERNS AND
THAT ALSO PERHAPS ALSO DEPENDS
ON YOU KNOW WHICH DISEASES HAVE
ENOUGH PEOPLE THAT THEY CAN
BOUNCE YOU KNOW EFFORT THROUGH
THE LEGISLATURE RATES OF YOU
HAVE A DISEASE THAT'S EITHER
RARER YOUR PEOPLE ARE- PERHAPS
YOU KNOW IT'S MORE PREVALENT IN
A MUCH SMALLER GROUP OF PEOPLE
PERHAPS A MINORITY GROUPS
THERE'S A LET YOU KNOW THE
POLITICAL WILL- THE ABILITY OF
THE BILLION MOBILE ICE IS THOSE
LAST AND SO FORTH SO THEY DON'T
GET THERE BUT THE OTHER ONES
TOO SO THAT I THINK THAT'S THE
CHALLENGE. THAT THAT THAT THAT
THAT I'M FACING- I'D TRY
PERHAPS YOU CAN ADDRESS- WHY
ONLY DIABETES I'D SEE I THINK
IT'S QUITE EVIDENT MY DIABETES
NEEDS IT GREAT SO I THINK
THAT'S NOT THE ISSUE IT'S LIKE
WHY ONLY DIABETES- WOULD BE
HELPFUL TO HEAR- BUT- CERTAINLY
I AM NOT AND IT YOU KNOW I'M
NOT ASKING MY COLLEAGUES NOT TO
VOTE FOR THE BILL BECAUSE OF
THIS BECAUSE I THINK THAT THE
IDEA COMMITTEE NEEDS IT RIGHT
AND I WANTED AND I AND I AND I
REALLY APPRECIATE MY COLLEAGUES
SAYING THAT THEY'RE GONNA BE
VOTING FOR THE BILL- MY ISSUE
IS THAT. THERE'S OTHER. AS WELL.
AS YOU KNOW ARE WE GONNA. IT
EASY LIKE THIS APPROACH AND
WHAT HAPPENS TO THE PEOPLE WHO
ARE LEFT OUT WHO CAN'T MOBILIZE
A BILL- HEARING SO DON'T THEY
DESERVE THE SAME PROTECTIONS.
RIGHT AND SO I THINK THAT'S
THE- THAT WAS BEHIND THE
LEGISLATION THAT I. AUTHORED
BUT CERTAINLY HOPING TO WORK
WITH YOU AND MAYBE THERE'S
APPROACH WE CAN WORK TOGETHER
AND TRYING TO ADDRESS THIS
LARGER ISSUE SO I REALLY
APPRECIATE YOUR ADVOCACY FOR
THE DIABETIC COMMUNITY BUT
HOPEFULLY. ALSO BOTH YOU AND
THE SPONSOR TO THAT IT CAN YOU
CAN SEE WHY IT MIGHT BE
IMPORTANT TO THINK ABOUT. IT WE
SHOULD DO SOMETHING BROADER-
THAT SO THAT ANYONE WHO'S IN
THIS KIND OF SITUATION WHERE
THERE'S A LIFE SAVING DRUG LIKE
INSULIN. LIKE INSULIN THAT
NEEDS THAT. IT FOR OTHER
CONDITIONS AS WELL. THAT'S A
STANDARD. THAT DAN ANYONE WHO
HAS A CONDITION LIKE THAT WHERE
THERE'S A TREATMENT THAT WOULD
SAVE THEIR LIVES. WOULD THEN BE
ABLE TO NOT HAVE THIS KIND OF
FINANCIAL BARRIERS. FROM THEM
SO AGAIN APPRECIATE YOU
BRINGING THIS BILL FORWARD-
APPRECIATE THE DISCUSSION- PCT
ADVOCACY FROM THE DIABETIC
COMMUNITY- AND- WITH THAT-
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE. THANK
YOU MR CHAIR FIRST OF ALL THANK
YOU. FOR YOUR WORK IN THIS
SPACE AS WELL. THANK YOU FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY. TO ALSO HEAR
THE BILL PREVENTS THE BILL- AND
FOUR IT'LL- MOVE ON TO THE NEXT
STEP. OF THAT I COULDN'T AGREE
WITH YOU MORE. I AND I WAS
SUPPORTIVE OF I'VE BEEN
SUPPORTIVE OF YOUR EFFORTS AS
WELL. SO I DO LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH YOU. ON ANY
OPPORTUNITY IN ADVANCING MORE-
MORE CHRONIC DISEASES SO THAT-
WE ALSO TAKE ADVANTAGE OF THE
ECONOMIES OF SCALE- IF WE'RE
DOING IT FOR ONE WE CAN DO IT
FOR MULTIPLE ONES- IS THE
REASON WHY I STARTED WORKING
SPECIFICALLY IN THE DIABETIC.
SPACE IS BECAUSE WHEN I AM AS
MATIC. AND WHEN I SAW THAT I
DON'T HAVE A CO PAY. ON SOME OF
THE MEDICATION THAT I USE. AND
I SAW THE DISCREPANCY BETWEEN
DIFFERENT DISEASES SOME
CHILDREN ARE AS MATIC THEY
DON'T. TELL TO SOME THINGS ARE
BETTER AFFORDED TO THEM SOME
KIDS ARE DIABETIC BUT THE SAME
OPPORTUNITY DOESN'T EXIST FOR
THEM I JUST FELT THAT IT WAS
SOMETHING THAT NEEDED TO BE
ADDRESSED. AND SO I WANTED TO
MOVE THIS AND I'VE BEEN WORKING
ON IT WITH YOU FOR THE PAST
SOME TIME NOW- BUT THIS THIS IS
NOT A REFLECTION OF ANY OTHER
ISSUES I. AND I ALSO WANT TO
JUST. MENTIONED THAT GIVEN ALSO
WHAT SOME OF THE SENATORS HAVE
SAID A PART OF THE CHALLENGE
ALSO IS THAT- WITH A GROWING
POPULATION OF DIABETICS WE ALSO
I'M JUST TRYING TO ANTICIPATE.
WHAT SOME OF THESE ISSUES ARE
GOING TO BE AND IF WE CAN
HOPEFULLY MAINTAIN. OR CONTAIN
COSTS IN SOME WAYS THAT THIS
WOULD BE ONE WAY THAT THE END
USERS WERE PAID LESS SO WITH
THAT. I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A
VOTE AND THINK YOU THANK THANK
YOU SENATOR IS THERE IN A
FORTUNE WE DO NOT HAVE A QUORUM
YET SO WE CAN'T- TAKE A MOTION
OR TAKE IT UP YET BUT AS SOON
AS WE ESTABLISH A QUORUM-
POLICE HAVE A SCORE OF WE'LL DO
SO THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR
PRESENTATION. THANK YOU. ALL
RIGHT. IS THAT SOME OF OUR-
LORD YEAH HYSTERIA THAT'S WHAT
THE PLEXIGLASS AND DOES HE
RECOGNIZE YOU ALL RIGHT SO NOW
MOVE ON TO ITEM NUMBER THREE
EIGHTY TWO. TO EIGHTEEN BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER WARD WELCOME AND.
GIVE US A MOMENT TO TIDY UP THE
PODIUM FIRST. THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS SO ACCORDING
TO A TWO THOUSAND FIFTEEN
SURVEY OF TRANSGENDER
INDIVIDUALS IN THE U. S. ONLY
11% OF RESPONDENTS REPORTED
THAT THEY- THAT THEIR IDENTITY
DOCUMENTS- MATCH THE PREFERRED
NAME AND GENDER IDENTITY.
POSSESSING ACCURATE AND
CONSISTENT IDENTIFICATION
DOCUMENTS IS ESSENTIAL TO BASIC
SOCIAL AND ECONOMIC FUNCTIONING
IN OUR COUNTRY. YET FOR MANY
TRANSGENDER PEOPLE OBTAINING
IDENTITY DOCUMENTS THAT MATCH
THEIR GENDER IS A HUGE HURDLE.
EIGHTY TWO EIGHTEEN SIMPLY
ALIGNS THE PROCESS FOR UPDATING
TRANSGENDER MARRIAGE
CERTIFICATES AND THE BIRTH
CERTIFICATES OF THEIR CHILDREN.
BUT THE PROCESS ALREADY IN
PLACE FOR UPDATING THEIR OWN
BIRTH CERTIFICATE. THIS GIVES
TRANSGENDER INDIVIDUALS. THE
TOOLS THEY NEED TO OBTAIN
ACCURATE IDENTIFICATION
DOCUMENTS FOR THEMSELVES. IN
THE CHILDREN PROTECTING THEIR
PRIVACY AND THEIR WELL BEING.
OPERATED AMENDMENTS TO ADDRESS
CLUSTERS VETO MESSAGE OF S. B.
SEVEN FORTY ONE AND WE ARE
WORKING ITH CD P. H. M. TODAY
MINISTRATION TO ENSURE THAT
THEIR CONCERNS ARE PROPERLY
ADDRESSED. ON THE LINE WE HAVE
MY WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL TOMMY MARTIN THE
LEGISLATIVE DIRECTOR OF
EQUALITY CALIFORNIA AND AMIRA.
HEALTH AND BUSH THE FOUNDER OF
ALL FAMILY LEGAL. THANK YOU SO
MUCH DECEMBER AWARD- LOW
MODERATOR PLEASE BRING ON THE
LINE TOMMY MARTIN FOR QUALITY
CALIFORNIA AND AMIR HOSSEN BUSH
FROM ALL FAMILY LEGAL WILL
BEGIN WITH TOMMY MARTIN YOU
EACH HAVE TWO MINUTES TOTAL
FOUR MINUTES TOGETHER. SO
PLEASE BEGIN WHEN YOU'RE READY.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR SHARING
COMMITTEE MEMBERS THIS IS TOMMY
MARTIN ON BEHALF OF EQUALITY
CALIFORNIA. SPONSOR OF EIGHTY
ONE EIGHT AND THIS IS A BILL
ABOUT ACCURATE VITAL RECORDS
YES BUT IT'S ALSO A BILL ABOUT
AUTHENTIC LIVING. ABOUT
PROVIDING THE HUMAN EXPERIENCE
WITH DIGNITY SO I'LL BE BRIEF
AND A MOMENT MIGHT COME IN AT
THE NEAR I WILL EXPLAIN THE
VERY REAL IMPACT OF THE BILL
WILL HAVE ON PEOPLE'S LIVES.
AND THE IMPACT OF FOREIGN OUT
BY THE DATA AS WELL AS- AWARDED
MENTIONED AS- ONLY A SMALL
FRACTION OF TRANSGENDER PEOPLE
HAVE THEIR CORRECT NAME AND
GENDER LISTED ON ALL OF THEIR
IDENTITY DOCUMENTS SUCH. AS
OVER ONE THIRD OF TRANSGENDERS
FUNDING TO REACH THE NATIONAL
SURVEY HAD BEEN ASSAULTED. I
BELIEVE OR OTHERWISE HARMED IN
SOME WAY SIMPLY FOR PRESENTING
AN IDENTITY DOCUMENT. THAT
LISTS THE NAME OR GENDER THAT
DID NOT MATCH THEIR GENDER
PRESENTATION. SO WE DO HAVE
MORE WORK TO DO HERE AND IT
STILL IS ANOTHER IMPORTANT
STEP. FOLLOWING IN THE
FOOTSTEPS OF FOR EXAMPLE THE
GENDER RECOGNITION ACT OF TWO
THOUSAND SEVENTEEN. BY SENATOR
AND NOT PRETEND TO ANY ACTION.
AMONG OTHER LAWS THAT LAID A
FOUNDATION FOR ACCURATE AND
AFFIRMING IDENTITY DOCUMENT FOR
ALL CALIFORNIANS. WILL BE
GRATEFUL BECAUSE I REMEMBER
WARD FOR PRESSING AHEAD ON THE
ISSUE RESPECTFULLY URGE. THE
COMMITTEE TO SUPPORT THE BILL
TODAY AS WELL THANK YOU. THANK
YOU NOW LET'S BRING AMIRA HASS
AND BUSH. USE GOOD AFTERNOON
AND THANK YOU FOR HAVING ME
HERE TODAY MY IS AMIR. SHERMAN
ALONG AND LOOK ANGELES COUNTY
THE FOLK ON L. INDIVIDUALS
FAMILIES FOR THE PART OF THAT
PRACTICE I SAID. CLIENTS
CONTAINING THE NAME AND CHANGES
ALPHABET APPLE YEARS WORKING
FOR LANES AND AN LGBT RESOURCE
YOU CAN CALLED. FOR A DRAFT OF
THE PROVIDED TECH ASSISTANCE
FOR BILL AND NOT LOTS OF A OF
THE G. B. T. FOR BRINGING THE
IDEA FOR THE BILL I WORK FOR
THE CLIENT WHO'S GOING TO AN
AMICABLE DIVORCE SHE DECIDED TO
TAKE BACK HER MAIDEN NAME AND
BOTH SHE AND HER HUSBAND AGREED
TO HYPHENATE THEIR CHILDREN'S
LAST NAMES OF THE RESULT.
HOWEVER WHEN SHE ASKED IF SHE
COULD MODIFY HER OLDER CHILD
BIRTH CERTIFICATE TO REFLECT
HER HUSBAND'S GENDER HE HAD
TRANSITIONED TO MALE BETWEEN
THE BIRTH OF THEIR FIRST AND
SECOND CHILD. ALL I COULD HELP
HER WITH THAT IT WOULD COST
MORE MONEY AND I COULDN'T
GUARANTEE THE OUTCOME. SHOULD
NOT MAKE THE CHANGE AT ALL AND
HE HAS THE LOOK OF THE CHILD'S
MOTHER ON THE BIRTH CERTIFICATE
WHICH I COMPLETED A NAME AND
GENDER CHANGE FOR ANOTHER
CLIENT ABOUT A YEAR AGO SHE
RECEIVED HER COURT ORDER NAME
AND GENDER CHANGE EIGHT WEEKS
AFTER WE FILED A PETITION WITH
THE COURT. BUT IT TOOK A LEGAL
MOTION COURT HEARING IN EIGHT
MONTHS OF ARGUING WITH VITAL
RECORDS TO MENTOR MARRIAGE
CERTIFICATE WHICH I SUCCEEDED
ON BEHALF OF MY CLIENT BUT THE
VAST MAJORITY OF TRANSGENDER
PEOPLE DO NOT HAVE THE
FINANCIAL RESOURCES TO HIRE
PRIVATE COUNSEL TO COMPLETE
THEIR NAME AND GENDER CHANGE
PAPERWORK. AND I HONESTLY DON'T
THINK THAT OUR MARRIAGE
CERTIFICATE A MOMENT COULD HAVE
BEEN COMPLETE WITHOUT THE
ACTUALLY THE LAWYER FRANKLY I
WASN'T EVEN SURE THAT I COULD
DO IT AND I'M NOT SURE
EVERYWHERE WE GET THE SAME
OUTCOME. IN THE LAST YEAR WE'VE
COME TO APPRECIATE HOW VITAL
ACCESS TO HOSPITALS AND
VISITING HER SICK LOVED ONES
AND- NO ONE WANTS TO BE DENIED
TIME WITH A CHILD OR SPOUSE
WHEN THEY'RE IN AN EMERGENCY
AND ADDING THE EXTRA
COMPLICATION THE FUNNY LOOKING
BIRTH CERTIFICATE OR MARRIAGE
CERTIFICATE WITH AMENDMENTS IN
TWO PAGES. COULD LEAD TO
CONFUSION ABOUT THE
DISCRIMINATION AT WORST THIS
BILL WOULD REDUCE AT LEAST ONE
BARRIER BY ALLOWING SUCH
DOCUMENTATION TO ACCURATELY
REFLECTS TRANSGENDER PEOPLE'S
NAME ENGENDERS. WITHOUT ADDING
CONFUSION. FOLKS TO BE ABLE TO
HOW THEIR LEGAL. AND GENDER- ON.
OF THEIR- DOCUMENTS. NOT THE
FIRST. THE FILM DO JUST. THANK
VERY MUCH FOR THEY'LL MOVE TO
THIS WITNESSES SUPPORT OF
EIGHTY TWO EIGHT. BECAUSE
PUBLIC SCENE ON PUBLIC ALLIES
WITH THE ROOM TWENTY FORTY
SCENERY IN ROOM TWENTY FORTY
FIVE GREATER PLEASE BRING ON
THE LINE WITNESSES WHO WAS TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT. OF EIGHTY
TWO EIGHTEEN NAME OR POSITION
POSITION ONLY. THANK YOU MR
CHAIR OR COMMENT IN SUPPORT OF
EIGHTY. TWO EIGHTEEN PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO. RECOMMEND
AGAIN ONE. ZERO LIGHTER ONE
HUNDRED EIGHTY EIGHT YOU'RE
LIKE ABOUT. GOOD AFTERNOON
SHARING MEMBERS CALL IN SCORES
OF THE CALIFORNIA PSYCHOLOGICAL
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU NEXT LINE. LINE ONE HUNDRED
FIFTY TWO. MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
OF ERIN EVANS ON BEHALF OF
NEIGHBOR ALL PRO CHOICE
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT THANK YOU
THANK YOU NEXT LINE. WHITE ONE
HUNDRED SIXTY NINE. HELLO AGAIN
SURE MEMBERS COULD STOP MAYOR
WITH THE AMERICAN FEDERATION OF
STATE COUNTY AND MUNICIPAL
EMPLOYEES AND STRONG SUPPORT OF
A. B. TWO ONE EIGHT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU NEXT LINE. A LINE OF
ONE HUNDRED THIRTY ONE. GOOD
AFTERNOON JACKET POCKET THE
NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL
WORERS CALIFORNIA CHAPTER INTO
COURT THANK YOU NEXT LINE. LINE.
ONE HUNDRED FIFTY EIGHT. GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIR AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS THE ONES WHO ARE ON
BEHALF EIGHT FAIRVIEW
CALIFORNIA ACTION IN COURT
THANK YOU THANK YOU NEXT LINE.
BETTER CARE THERE ARE NO
FURTHER COMMENT AT THIS TIME.
THANKS VERY MUCH WE'LL NOW MOVE
INTO. TESTIMONY IN OPPOSITION
TO EIGHTY TWO EIGHTEEN WE DO
NOT HAVE ANY LEAD OPPOSITION
REGISTERED FOR GIVING TESTIMONY
SOUL GO TO ADDITIONAL WITNESSES
IN OPPOSITION TOGETHER PUBLIC
GALLERY SCENE ON THE PUBLIC
GALLERY LET'S MOVE THROUGH
TWENTY FORTY SCENE IN ROOM
TWENTY FORTY. MODERATOR PLEASE
OPEN THE LINES TWO WITNESSES
WHO WAS TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION. TO EIGHTY TWO
EIGHTEEN NAME ORGANIZATION
POSITION ONLY. FOUR COMMENTS IN
OPPOSITION. TO EIGHTY TWO
EIGHTEEN PLEASE PRESS ONE AND
THEN ZERO. BACK COMMAND AGAIN.
ONE SEVEN ZERO. AND MISTER
CHAIR I SHOW NO COMMENTS COMING
THROUGH AT THE TIME THANK YOU
MODERATOR WILL BRING IT BACK TO
COMMITTEE ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM THE COMMITTEE
SENATOR RUBIO. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR- I ALSO WANT TO THINK OF
SOME REMEMBER WORD FOR BRINGING
THIS FORWARD- I THINK IT'S
REALLY IMPORTANT. AND I'LL
START BY HIGHLIGHTING THAT I'M
ALREADY A CO AUTHOR ON A BILL
FOR DEATH CERTIFICATES AND I
THINK THIS IS JUST ONE MORE WAY
TO SHOW. THAT CALIFORNIANS
RESPECT EVERY INDIVIDUAL AND-
DID THEIR RIGHT. TO LIVE THEIR
AUTHENTIC SELVES AND I THINK
THAT- SOMEONE HIGHLIGHTED I
THINK ON THE CALL- AND WE DON'T
EVEN THINK OF THESE THINGS HELP
DANGEROUS IT CAN BE WHEN YOU
PRESENT- A DOCUMENT THAT
DOESN'T REFLECT WHO YOU ARE NOW
AND- IT PUTS THEM IN HARM'S WAY
AND- I THINK THIS IS JUST.
COMMON SENSE BILL WE WANT TO
RESPECT AND PROTECT OUR
TRANSGENDER COMMUNITY AND SHOW.
THAT WE VALUE WHO THEY ARE AND
I WANT OUT OF THIS BILL FORWARD
WHEN APPROPRIATE THANK YOU.
VERY THANK YOU- WE WILL HAVE TO
STATUS QUORUM FIRST- I GUESS
YOU KNOW WHAT ACTUALLY CENTER
RUBIO THAT. BASICALLY SAID
EVERYTHING I WANT TO SAY IN THE
CLOUD AND IN A CALM THE COMMON
AS WELL ON THE BILL SO JUST GO
AHEAD AND LET YOU CLOSE ON THE
REWARD. THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN I
FULLY AGREE SENATOR RUBIO THANK
YOU FOR- REALLY A SICKLY
SUMMARIZING THE IMPORTANCE OF
THIS BILL I REALLY APPRECIATE
YOUR SUPPORT IN THIS SPACE AND
REALLY HAPPY TO ADD YOU AS A CO
AUTHOR AS WELL THAT YOUR
DESIRE- THANK YOU I RESPECT WE
CAN. ASK THE COMMITTEE'S
EITHER. THANKS SO MUCH ASSEMBLY
WARD AGAIN- WHEN WE ESTABLISH A
QUORUM WILL THEN TAKE UP THE
BILL FOR ABOUT THANKS SO MUCH
FOR YOUR PRESENTATION. RIGHT I
THINK I SAW SOME IMMIGRATION-
BACK THERE RIGHT SO GIVE US A
MONTH TIDY UP THE PODIUM BUT
WE'LL MOVE ON NOW TO ITEM
NUMBER FOUR. EIGHTY NINE BY
SUMMER BREAK GRAYSON. OKAY
WELCOME. PLEASE BEGIN WHEN
YOU'RE READY. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR AND GOOD AFTERNOON AND
COMMITTEE MEMBER. I AM PLEASED
TO PRESENT TO YOU A B. THREE
EIGHT NINE WHICH ILL CONTINUE
TO AUTHORIZE A COUNTY TO
CONTRACT FOR EMERGENCY
AMBULANCE SERVICES WITH THE
FIRE AGENCY AND TO PROVIDE
THOSE SERVICES TO RE WRITTEN
SUB CONTRACT WITH A PRIVATE
AMBULANCE SERVICE WITHIN MY
DISTRICT IN CONTRA COSTA COUNTY
THE FIRE PROTECTION DISTRICT
PROVIDES NINE ONE ONE EMERGENCY
AMBULANCE SERVICES. TO NEARLY
ONE MILLION COUNTY RESIDENTS
UNDER A LONG TERM EXCLUSIVE
OPERATING CONTRACT UNDER THIS
CONTRACT THE FIRE DISTRICT
PROVIDES AMBULANCE SERVICES TO
BE SUB CONTRACT WITH AMERICAN
MEDICAL RESPONSE WEST THIS
PARTNERSHIP IS KNOWN AS THE
FIRE EMS ALLIANCE. SOME THREE
REALIZATION FOR A COMBINED FIRE
EMS DISPATCH AND COMMUNICATIONS
CENTER MANAGED BY THE FIRE
DISTRICT THE OVERALL LEVEL OF
EFFICIENCY AND OPERATIONS. AT
CLINICAL QUALITY AND RESPONSE
TIMES HAVE IMPROVED
TREMENDOUSLY AND SERVES AS AN
EFFECTIVE MODEL FOR OTHER
COUNTIES TO BASE THEIR
PARTNERSHIPS OFF OF AB THREE
EIGHT NINE WILL INSURE THE
COUNTY TO RETAIN THEIR ABILITY
TO CONTRACT FOR EMERGENCY
AMBULANCE SERVICES WITH THE
FIRE AGENCIES SO THAT THIS
AFFECTED SUBCONTRACTING MODEL
FOR EMERGENCY AMBULANCE
DEPLOYMENT SYSTEMS WILL
CONTINUE. TO BE A VIABLE OPTION
IN PROVIDING EMERGENCY SERVICES
TO THE RESIDENTS THIS BILL WILL
ALSO REQUIRE BOTH COUNTIES AND
FIRE AGENCIES TO ADOPT A
WRITTEN POLICY ON
SUBCONTRACTING PRIOR TO ANY
SUBCONTRACTING AGREEMENT AND TO
ENSURE A COMPETITIVE BIDDING
PROCESS. FURTHER BY REQUIRING A
WRITTEN POLICY PRIOR TO ANY
WRITTEN SUBCONTRACT FOR THE
COUNTY AND FIRE AGENCY THIS
WILL ENSURE THAT THERE ARE
SAFEGUARDS IN PLACE FOR WORKER
PROTECTIONS SUCH AS REASONABLE
COMPENSATION BENEFITS AND
WORKER RETENTION TO JUST NAME A
FEW I AM AWARE THAT THE LATEST
SET OF AMENDMENTS DO NOT
COMPLETELY ADDRESSED. ALL OF
THE OPPOSITE SINCE CONCERNS
WHICH IS WHY A PRINT WTH AMID.
TO ADDRESS THIS MANY OF THEIR
MAIN CONCERNS I DO REMAIN
COMMITTED TO CONTINUING TO
COLLABORATE WITH ALL
STAKEHOLDERS INVOLVED. TO GET
THE BILL TO A PLACE WHERE ALL
PARTIES AGREE AND WE ARE ONE
WORD POSSIBLY AWAY FROM THAT SO
WE'RE SO VERY CLOSE WITH THAT I
WOULD LIKE TO INTRODUCE MY TWO
WITNESSES. TO THE CHECK. OUT
CHEAP LOUIS BOUCHARD BY THE
CONTRA COSTA COUNTY FIRE
PROTECTION DISTRICT AND VINCE
WELLS PRESIDENT OF CONTRA COSTA
COUNTY PROFESSIONAL
FIREFIGHTERS LOCAL TWELVE OF
TWELVE THIRTY AM FOR DISTRICT
VICE PRESIDENT FOR CALIFORNIA
PROFESSIONAL FIREFIGHTERS THANK
YOU. I THANK YOU SO MUCH
EMIGRATIONS I PRESUME FROM YOUR
TEST MADE WHICH I CONFIRM YOUR
ACCEPTING THE AMENDMENTS AND I
KNOW YOU'RE WORKING ON SOME
MORE OKAY YES. SIR THEY ARE
ACCEPTING THOSE MINUTES ALRIGHT
THANK YOU SO WE'LL GO TO GO TO
AND- TAKE WITNESSES AND SOME.
OF EIGHTY C. H. NINE AND I'VE
WE HAVE OPENED GALLERY. C.
SORRY. IS THAT. START NOW. THE
FIRE CHIEF WITH WELLS EVENTS
WELL YES CALIFORNIA FOR OKAY
YOU'RE START FOR ALL RIGHT-
BECAUSE I HAVE TO BE BY JOHN
ORDER. INTO WE'LL START WITH
VINCE WELLS AND FIRST OKAY
RIGHT SO WE CAN BEGIN WITH A-
SO. AND PROFESSIONAL
FIREFIGHTERS YOU DO HAVE- TWO
MINUTES IT'S FOUR MINUTES
BETWEEN THE TOES TWO IF YOU ARE
GIVEN TWO MINUTE WARNING ABOUT
YOU GO OVER THEN THAT SHORTENS
THE TIME FOR THE NEXT PERSON
JUST. FY I GUESS BUT- PLEASE
BEGIN. OKAY GOOD ALL. TO PANEL
AND MEMBERS. MY NAME IS VINCE
WELLS AND I'M THE PRESIDENT OF
THE CONTRAPOSITIVE.
PROFESSIONAL FIREFIGHTERS LOCAL
TWELVE THIRTY. AND ALSO
CALIFORNIA PROFESSIONAL
FIREFIGHTERS FOR DISTRICT VICE
PRESIDENT. THANK YOU FOR GIVING
ME THE TIME TO SPEAK TODAY ON
A. B. THREE EIGHTY NINE. A BILL
THAT IS IMPORTANT NOT ONLY TO
MY MEMBERS IN CONTRA COSTA
COUNTY BUT TO ALL FIRE AGENCIES
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA. WE ARE
GRATEFUL TO THE AUTHOR'S OFFICE
FOR THEIR HARD WORK MOVING THIS
BILL FOR. THIS FIRE ALLIANCE.
FOR A SUBCONTRACTING MODEL HAS
RESULTED IN NUMEROUS POSITIVE
OUTCOMES FOR BOTH THE COUNTY
FIRE DISTRICT IN OUR CITIZENS.
OVERALL EFFICIENCY OF ANIMAL
SERVICES HAS INCREASED ALONG
WITH THE TOTAL NUMBER OF
ANIMALS IS DEPLOYED. IN CALL
PRICES AND TIMES HAVE BEEN
DRASTICALLY REDUCED. AND OUR
RESPONSE TIMES HAVE BEEN
IMPROVED. COURTS HAVE BEEN
CLEAR REGARDING THE COUNTY.
REGARDING THE AUTHORITY OF A
PUBLIC AGENCY TO ENGAGE IN
CONTRACT WITH OTHER ENTITIES
PUBLIC OR PRIVATE FOR THE
DELIVERIES OF EMERGENCY ANSWER
SERVICES BUT RECENT ACTIONS BY
EMS MAY THREATEN THE CONTINUED
VIABILITY OF THIS MODEL. TO
ENSURE THE CONTINUED DELIVERY
OF EFFICIENT ANIMAL THAT'S A
PRETTY HOSPITAL SERVICES TO THE
RESIDENTS OF CONTRA COSTA
COUNTY. AB THREE EIGHTY NINE
CLARIFIESTHAT A COUNTY MAY
CONTRACT FOR EMERGENCY I WAS
SERVICES WITH THE FIRE AGENCY
THAT PROVIDES THOSE SERVICES
THERE WAS A CONTRACT WITH A
PRIVATE COMPANY. WE'RE
CONTINUING TO WORK WITH ALL
STAKEHOLDERS TO ENSURE THAT THE
BEST INTERESTS OF THE WORKERS
PROVIDING THESE SERVICES ARE
ACCOUNTED FOR. AND AT A FAIR
OPEN AND TRANSPARENT PROCESS
FOR THESE CONTRACTS IS
OUTLINED. THANK YOU AGAIN FOR
YOUR CONSIDERATION AND I HEARD
YOUR ALBUM. THANK YOU. THANKS
VERY MUCH AND THEN THAT'S-
MODERATOR PLEASE BRING ON THE
LINE LOUIS BOUCHARD FROM THE
COUNTRY BECAUSE THE FIRE
PROTECTION DISTRICT FOR ALSO IN
ADDITION FOR TESTIMONY IN
SUPPORT. AND. YOUR SHIP A
LITTLE OVER TWO MINUTES A
LITTLE- GET AFTER IT HAPPENED
IN CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE. MY NAME IS LOUIS
BROCHURE CARD CHEAPER CONTRACT
COUNTY FIRE IT IS MY PLEASURE
TO REPRESENT OUR COUNTY AND OUR
EMERGENCY AMBULANCE. PROGRAM
KNOWN AS THE ALLIANCE. SINCE
TWENTY SIXTEEN THE HIGHLY
SUCCESSFUL FINANCIALLY
SUSTAINABLE AND OPERATIONALLY
EFFICIENT AMBULANCE
SUBCONTRACTING MALL IN OUR
COUNTY HAS BEEN SERVING OVER
ONE MILLION RESIDENTS. THIS
MODEL IS FIRST OF ITS KIND IN
CALIFORNIA. HAS PROVEN THAT THE
COMBINED PROFESSIONAL
EXPERIENCE IN SERVICE OF THE
PUBLIC AND PRIVATE SECTORS WHEN
BROUGHT TOGETHER UNDER ONE
SYSTEM BRINGS A HIGHER LEVEL OF
SERVICE AND FISCAL
SUSTAINABILITY. THEN WHEN FIRE
AND EMERGENCY MEDICAL SERVICES
SERVE THEIR PUBLIC IN THE
SEPARATE SILOS. EIGHTY THREE
EIGHTY NINE IS NECESSARY TO
SECURE THE FUTURE OF
SUBCONTRACTING FOR NOT ONLY OUR
COUNTY BUT AS AN OPTION FOR
OTHER COUNTIES THROUGHOUT THE
STATE IN THE DELIVERY OF THEIR
EMERGENCY AMBULANCE SERVICES.
WITH A MODEL THAT HAS PROVEN
ITS VALUE AND ABILITY TO
IMPROVE RESPONSE TIMES INCREASE
DEPLOYMENT OF INDOLENCE
RESOURCES. INCREASE CAPITAL
INVESTMENT AND PARTICIPATE IN
INNOVATIVE PROGRAMS TO SHAPE
THE FUTURE OF EMS DELIVERY. AND
CONSISTENTLY EXCEED COMPLIANCE
WITH CONTRACTUAL REQUIREMENTS
FOR OVER FIVE STRAIGHT YEARS.
THERE SHOULD BE LITTLE DOUBT
THE SUBCONTRACTING SHOULD BE
SUSTAINED AS A MODEL FOR OUR
COUNTY AND IT'S AN OPPORTUNITY
FOR OTHER COUNTY IF IT FITS
THEIR NEEDS. EIGHTY THREE
EIGHTY NINE IS NOT A MANDATE
FOR COUNTIES TO PROVIDE
AMBULANCE SERVICES WITH THE
SUBCONTRACTING MODEL. IT'S A
LITTLE BITE OF CONTRACTING TO
STATUTE AS AN OPTION THAT WOULD
REMAIN AVAILABLE FOR ANY COUNTY
TO CONSIDER AND EVALUATE IN
RELATION TO THEIR NEEDS AND
THEIR UNIQUE CIRCUMSTANCES. ON
A STATEWIDE BASIS WE NEED TO
CONTINUE TO STRENGTHEN OUR
AMBULANCE TRANSPORT SYSTEMS AND
SUB CONTRACTING HAS PROVEN
ITSELF AS A VALUABLE OPTION IN
THE DELIVERY OF EMERGENCY
AMBULANCE SERVICES. THE URGENCY
OF THIS BILL IS NECESSARY TO
CLEAR UP THE CONFUSION ABOUT
THE STATUS OF SUBCONTRACTING
FOR EMERGENCY AMBULANCE
SERVICES. WE NEED TO MAKE
SUBCONTRACTING AN AVAILABLE
OPTION FOR ALL COUNTY.
ADDITIONALLY MISTER CHAIR WE
WILL NEED TO WORK WITH. THE
COMMITTEE TO REFINE SOME
LANGUAGE AS THERE MAY MAYBE
SOME MINOR CONCERT. CAN IN THE
BILL TAX. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
CONCERN. OF THIS BILL AND THE
OP. TO SPEAK THE STAFF. WE
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT OF A. B. THREE TWO ONE.
THANKS VERY MUCH WE WILL NOW
MOVE ON TO ADDITIONAL WITNESSES
AND SUPPORT AT EIGHTY THREE
EIGHTY NINE- WILL TOGETHER
PUBLIC GALLERY SCENE ON THE
PUBLIC GALLERY I'LL MOVE TO
ROOM TWENTY FORTY THREE DOLLARS
AND TWENTY FORTY MODERATOR
PLEASE OPEN THE LINES FOR
WITNESSES WHO WISH TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT OF EIGHTY THREE
EIGHTY NINE NAME OR POSITION
POSITION ONLY. MORE COMMENTS IN
SUPPORT OF EIGHTY THREE EIGHTY
NINE PLEASE PRESS ONE AND THEN
ZERO. THAT COMMAND AGAIN ONE
ZERO. WHITE ONE HUNDRED TWENTY
EIGHT AM I COULD OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON INTERNET NOT MOM- IN.
OR ON THE OF THE DISTRICT IF
YOU CAN CALL AND THE CALL FIRE
CHIEF SAYS HE THANK YOU THANK
YOU LINE. BETTER CARE THERE ARE
NO FURTHER COMMENT AT THE TIME
RIGHT THANKS VERY MUCH WE'LL
NOW MOVE INTO WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION. TWO EIGHTY THREE
EIGHTY NINE WE HAVE TWO
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION TO-
LISTED FOR TESTIMONY- WE HAVE A
LEAH GRIFFIN FROM ASKS ME WHO'S
IN THE GALLERY AND THEN FILL TO
T. TWO FROM THE INTERNATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF EMTS AND
PARAMEDICS WILL BE ON THE PHONE
LINE. I DO UNDERSTAND JUST TWO
OTHER WITNESSES WHO ARE
AVAILABLE ON THE PHONE LINE FOR
TECHNICAL QUESTIONS- AMY SKAGGS
FROM- ASK THE LOCAL FORTY NINE
ONE ONE AND JASON SORT FROM THE
MERITS AND RISKS MEDICAL
RESPONSE AGAIN THEY'RE JUST
THERE FOR TECHNICAL QUESTIONS
SO WE'LL BEGIN. WITH A LEAF
GRIPPING FROM THAT- FROM ASK
ME- YOU HAVE TWO MINUTES AGAIN
IT'S FOUR MINUTES TOTAL FOR TWO
FOR BOTH WITNESSES SO PLEASE
WELCOME PLEASE BEGIN. THANK YOU
MR CHAIRMAN OF THE COMMITTEE
FOR THE RECORD ONLY OCCUR THING
WITH THE AMERICAN FEDERATION OF
STATE COUNTY AND MUNICIPAL
EMPLOYEES. HERE WITH AN OPPOSE
UNLESS AMENDED POSITION THE
RECENT AMENDMENTS UNFORTUNATELY
DON'T ADDRESS OUR CONCERNS
ADEQUATELY ENOUGH TO REMOVE
OPPOSITION AT THIS TIME. BUT I
APPRECIATE THE AUTHOR'S
COMMENTS AND THE SPONSORS
WILLINGNESS TO CONTINUE TO WORK
WITH US. WE DO APPRECIATE THE
IMPROVED LANGUAGE PERTAINING
PERTAINING TO THE WAGES AND
BENEFITS THE OTHER CONCERN
HIGHLIGHTED IN OUR LETTER IS
AROUND HOW THIS MODEL HINDERS
OUR MEMBERS ABILITY TO BARGAIN
OVER WORKING CONDITIONS. SUCH
AS DEPLOYMENT SCHEDULE UNIT OUR
UTILIZATION AND THE T. RELIEF.
UNDER THE CURRENT PRACTICE IN
CONTRA COSTA COUNTY AND THE
MODEL THAT THIS BILL WOULD BE
AUTHORIZING. THE FIRE DISTRICT
CAN IMPOSE OPERATIONAL CHANGES
OUT RATE WHICH CUTS OFF OUR
RATES TO RECEIVE ADEQUATE
NOTICE FOR ME OVER THE IMPACTS
SINCE THESE CHANGES ARE COMING
FROM ABOVE THE FIRE DISTRICT
LEVEL. AND NOT AT THE
DIRECTOR'S LAWYER LEVEL WHO IS
A PARTY THAT WE HAVE A CONTRACT
CONTRACTUAL RELATIONSHIP WITH.
THIS IS REALLY OUR OPPORTUNITY
TO ENGAGE IN A DIALOGUE. AND
POSSIBLY PRESENT ALTERNATIVE TO
WHAT'S BEING PRESENTED
PROPOSED. AND IDENTIFY A WAY TO
MEET THE GOAL- IN A DIFFERENT.
WAY THAT WE THINK IS LESS
HARMFUL. OUR WORK FORCE AND THE-
ARE BETTER SIR WHEN THERE IS A
DUTY TO ENGAGE WORK FOR AS A
ASPECTS. AND INVOLVE THEM IN
THIS PROCESS AND WITHOUT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR NO VOTE
WITHOUT FURTHER AMENDMENTS
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
WE'LL NOW MOVE ON TO- ACTUALLY
MODERATOR PLEASE BRING ON THE
LINE PHIL PETITE FROM THE
INTERNATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF
EMTS AND PARAMEDICS. TO TESTIFY
SO PLEASE BEGIN WHEN YOU'RE
READY. HONORABLE MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK TODAY MY
NAME IS BILL BUT HE THE
NATIONAL DIRECTOR FOR SEIU
LOCAL FIVE THOUSAND I PROBABLY
WORK WITH. OVER THREE THOUSAND
EMS PROFESSIONALS ACROSS THE
GREAT STATE OF CALIFORNIA OVER
THE PAST FEW WEEKS OUR MEMBERS
IN YOUR FIRST RESPONDED TO MAKE
IT CLEAR TO ME. THAT EIGHTY
THREE EIGHTY NINE OF THOUGHT
HELPS SIX YEAR MASTER UMASS
OVERSIGHT ACROSS THE STATE
BACKED EIGHTY THREE NINE POSES
A NEW CHALLENGE THESE CRITICAL
FIRST RESPONDERS. UTILITY FOR
ADVOCATES LIKE MYSELF TO
NEGOTIATE BETTER WAGES.
BENEFITS AND WORKING CONDITIONS
ON THEIR BEHALF. HE MESSES IN
INDUSTRY IN CALIFORNIA AND
EVERY OTHER STATE IN THE NATION
IS FACING SEVERAL CHALLENGES IN
COMING YEARS. STAFFING LEVEL
CONCERNED STAGNANT
REIMBURSEMENT RATES AND OTHER
ISSUES CONTINUE TO MOUNT.
FURTHER ENCOURAGEMENT TO
ENTRUST CONTROL OF SUCH
DELICATE BALANCE BY DISTRICTS
IS NOT A FIX TO OF THE
INDUSTRY. FIREFIGHTERS ARE
TRAINED PROFESSIONALS THAT
SHOULD BE LAUDED FOR THEIR
EFFORTS TO ZEROS IN RESPONDENTS
BUT THEY SPECIALIZE IN FIRE
SUPPRESSION. IN THEIR INTERESTS
WILL ALWAYS LAY IN THAT AREA.
WHAT COULD HAVE RELEASED WITH
PROVIDER THERE. AND THE
COMMUNITY SO SERVE CATCH
CARACAL. WITH GLOBAL PANDEMIC
AS ONE RESPONSIBLE FOR
PROTECTING THESE FIRST LINE
RESPONDERS. QUESTION MUST BE
ASKED DOES EIGHTY THREE EIGHT
NINE IMPROVE THE SITUATION. WE
SAY NOW THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANKS VERY MUCH WE'LL NOW MOVE
ON TO ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION TWO EIGHTY THREE
EIGHTY NINE I WILL BEGIN WITH
THE PUBLIC GALLERY SCENE ON THE
PUBLIC DOLLARS WITH THE ROOM
TWENTY FOURTEEN SCENE NO ONE
ROOM TWENTY FORTY- MODERATOR
PLEASE BRING ON THE LINE
WITNESSES WHO SHOULD TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION. TWO EIGHTY THREE
EIGHTY NINE NAME ORGANIZATION
POSITION ONLY. FOUR COMMENTS IN
OPPOSITION TO IT EIGHTY THREE
EIGHTY NINE PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO. THAT COMMAND ONE
MORE TIME IS ONE. ZERO AND
MISTER CHAIR WE DO HAVE A FEW%
COMMENTS COMING THROUGH ONE
MOMENT PLEASE WHILE WE PROVIDE
THEM WITH ONE. AND A LINE OF
ONE HUNDRED NINETY TWO OF YOUR
MY GET UP. SURE MEMBERS
JONATHAN. FELDMAN ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA AMBULANCE
ASSOCIATION I APPRECIATE THE
COMMITMENT FROM THE ALL AND
COURT AGAIN. TO WORK ON THE
BILL BUT OPPOSED AS DRY DAY
THANK YOU. THANK YOU NEXT LINE.
FIND ONE HOW EIGHTY- RIGHT
ABOUT THREE T. NINETY MS
WORKERS AT THE LOCAL ONE NINE
ONE ONE AND WE ARE CLOSED AT
THE MINUTE. THANK YOU NEXT LINE.
WHITE ONE HUNDRED NINETY ONE.
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS ANY BROWN
ON BEHALF OF THE- AMBULANCE
PROVIDERS THAT LINE- STILL POSE
A LOOKING FORWARD TO OUR
CONTINUED WORK WITH THE AUTHOR
THANK YOU. THANK YOU NEXT LINE.
INVESTORS ARE THERE NO FURTHER
COMMENT AT THIS TIME. THANK
YOU- NOW OF BRING IT BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
CASEY A NINE. SEVEN GRAYSON-
REALLY APPRECIATE YOUR WORK ON
THIS BILL I KNOW THIS IS A-
LONG STANDING- SITUATION AND
TAX CUTS IN TERMS ARRANGEMENTS
AND- WANTED TO CONTINUE WHAT.
APPEARS TO BE A- OVER VERY WELL
WORKING MODEL FOR YOUR
COMMUNITY- APPRECIATE YOU
CONTINUING THE DIALOGUE WITH
THE OPPOSITION- I HOPE THAT-
FIREFIGHTERS AND ASKED ME WHO I
WAS REPRESENTING ALSO- YOU DO
YOU CAN DO. THAT AND HOPEFULLY
RESOLVE ANY THE REMAINING
ISSUES- SO REALLY APPRECIATE-
YOU WHILE WORKING FOR BUT- I
THINK- WE ALSO WANT TO BE ABLE
TO ALLOW THE EXISTING MODEL
THAT IS RAVEN PLACE CONTRA
COSTA TO BE ABLE TO CONTINUE-
SO WITH THAT- WHICH LIKE THE
CLOTHES. THANK YOU MR CHAIR AND
FOR THE RECORD WE HAVE BEEN
CONSISTENTLY WORKING VERY
CLOSELY WITH BOTH ASHLEY AND A.
M. ARE. AND WILL CONTINUE TO DO
SO AS I AM ACCEPTING MEMBERS
TODAY AND MORE TO COME. SO
THANK YOU AND I RESPECTFULLY
ASK WHEN I VOTE WHEN THE TIME
IS RIGHT OKAY THANK YOU WE DO
NOT YET HAVE A QUORUM SO WE-
BUT ONCE WE DO ESTABLISH A
QUORUM WE HOPE WE WILL THEN
TAKE UP A BILL. FOR THAT SO
THANK YOU SO MUCH FRENCH WE
WORK ON THIS AND LOOKING
FORWARD TO CONTINUING PROGRESS
ON THAT THANK YOU THANK YOU
MISTER FRENCH. ALL RIGHT I SEE
CENTRE ADMINS HERE I UNDERSTAND
THAT YOU ARE PRESENTING ITEM
NUMBER FIVE ON BEHALF. OF THE
CENTRE BUT CHRISTINA GARCIA.
OKAY YOU WISH TO IT FROM YOUR
DAD- THE- PLEASE BEGIN. I
CERTAINLY WILL IF YOU'LL- IF IT
DOES. DO YOU DO YOU HAVE THE
WHO THE WITNESSES ARE MISTER
CHAIR YES I YES I DO- SO I I'LL
TAKE CARE OF THAT PART IF YOU
WISH ME TO OKAY BECAUSE I WILL
BE I WILL SURELY DEFINE MY
TALKING POINTS RIGHT NOW BUT I
KNOW THE BILL I CAN CERTAINLY-
PRESENT THE BILL TO YOU TODAY
AND A AND A LIST OF THE
WITNESSES FOR AND AGAINST FCS
PART. SO THANK YOU VERY MUCH
YOU'RE PRESENTING THIS BILL ON
BEHALF OF ASSEMBLYMEMBER
CRISTINA GARCIA EIGHTY FIVE OLD
ONE HAVING TO DO WITH- THE
COMPOSTING OF HUMAN REMAINS- AS
YOU KNOW WHAT- ACTUAL BODY CAN
THAT CAN RELEASE A BUNCH OF CAR
A BUNCH OF CARBON UP INTO THE
ATMOSPHERE AND AS WE CONTINUE
TO THINK ABOUT HOW OLDER KINDER
TO THE EARTH AND- AND SEE
OURSELVES AS PART OF IT- THERE
HAS BEEN A MOVEMENT HAS PASSED
IN A COUPLE STATES COLORADO
WASHINGTON AND I THINK- OREGON
LEGISLATURE JUST PASSED IT. TO
LET PEOPLE BE ABLE TO ENTER
INTO A PROCESS TO TIP FOR THEIR
BODIES TO BE DECOMPOSED AND
THEN USED AS ORGANIC MATTER IN-
IN IN THE EARTH SO IT IS A
PRETTY SIMPLE PROCESS BECAUSE
UNTIL I GOT DECOMPRESSION TANK
THE BODY WELL AFTER SOMEBODY'S
A DECEASED AND OF COURSE THEY
WILL THEY WILL MAKE THESE.
WISHES KNOWN PRIOR- AND THEN IT
TAKES A SERIES OF TIME IT JUST
SPEEDS UP THE PROCESS OF THE D.
COMPACT THAT DECOMPOSITION OF
THE BODY- WHICH IS THEN READY
TO BE TO BE SPREAD AROUND SO
THIS- INNOVATIVE IDEAS SOME
IT'S AGAIN IT'S ONLY A CHOICE-
IT WILL CONTINUE TO BE
REGULATED UNDER THE BUREAU OF
FUNERAL AND CEMETERY- AND WE
HAVE WITNESSES ON THE LINE IN
SUPPORT. OKAY THANKS REC CENTER
ADMIN. THE BRING ON THE-
WITNESS AS A- OF EIGHTY FIVE
OH. SO PLEASE BRING ON THE LINE.
DR LYNNE CARPENTER BOGGS FROM
WASHINGTON STATE UNIVERSITY AND
CAITLIN DOUGHTY- A SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA MORTICIAN AND
FUNERAL HOME DIRECTOR AND
AUTHOR. SO YOU EACH HAVE TWO
MINUTES SO WE CAN BEGIN WITH DR
LYNNE CARPENTER BOGGS. HI THIS
IS K. ON DUTY I THINK THAT I
WAS GOING TO SPEAK FIRST OF
THAT- OKAY NO WE CAN DO IN THE
OTHER ORDERS WELL THAT'S WHAT
THE TWO OF YOU DECIDED AND
LET'S BEGIN WITH KATE AND DODI
THAT. THANK YOU SO MUCH CARE
AND TO THE COMMITTEE- I'M A
FUNERAL DIRECTOR AND FUNERAL
HOME OWNER IN SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA. GIVING MY FULL
SUPPORT TO ASSEMBLY BILL FIVE
OH ONE. THE MAJORITY OF MY
CLIENTS AND CALIFORNIANS IN
GENERAL ARE CREMATED. AND WHILE
THIS IS A DIFFERENT PROCESS. OF
BREAKING DOWN THE BODY AFTER
DEATH. FIFTY ONE EYES AND
BUREAUCRACY WISE. NATURAL
ORGANIC PRODUCTION WOULD WORK
VERY MUCH. LIKE CREMATION.
THERE'S A SYSTEM WE ALREADY
FOLLOW AND FUNERAL HOMES. THAT
I WOULD. THINK WOULD BE QUITE
EASILY TRANSFERRED. TO NATURAL
ORGANIC PRODUCTION. AND FROM
READING THE AMENDMENT. FROM THE
CEMETERY AND FUNERAL BUREAU.
THE RESULTING SOIL FROM THE
PROCESS WOULD BE TREATED LIKE
CREMATED REMAINS. AFTER
CREMATION. THE FACILITIES WOULD
BE INSPECTED IT MUCH LIKE
CREMATORY. YOU WOULD BE SIMILAR
PERMITS ETCETERA. AND I THINK
THIS PROCESS WOULD QUIT. WOULD
FIT. REALLY QUITE WELL INTO
WHAT FUNERAL HOMES THROUGHOUT
THE STATE. ALREADY UNDERSTAND
AND USE DAILY. R. FOR WHY THE
BILL IS CEMEX. FOR US FUNERAL
DIRECTORS FIRST THIS PAST YEAR
THE PANDEMIC HAS CAUSED EXTREME
BACKUPS WITH CREMATORY RUNNING
TWENTY FOUR HOURS A DAY AND
BURIAL NOT HAPPENING SOMETIMES
FOR MONTHS. WE REALLY COULD
HAVE USED ADDITIONAL METHODS OF
BODY POSITION LIKE THIS WILL
PROVIDE. AND SECOND OPTIONS FOR
FAMILIES ARE SO IMPORTANT
CREMATION DOESN'T WORK FOR
EVERYONE WHETHER FOR RELIGIOUS
FOR ENVIRONMENTAL REASONS.
TRADITIONAL BURIAL ALSO DOESN'T
WORK FOR EVERYONE BECAUSE OF
THE HIGH COSTS FOR WORKING
FAMILIES. NOT TO ORGANIC
PRODUCTION IS ANOTHER OPTION
FOR OUR FAMILIES ONE THAT IS
BEING RAPIDLY ADOPTED FOR A
CALMER CLEANER MORE PERSONAL
END OF LIFE EXPERIENCE. I THANK
YOU FOR YOUR TIME AND YOUR
IPHONE. THANKS VERY MUCH LET'S
NOW- BRING ON DOCTOR LYNN
CARPENTER BOGGS THESE BEGIN.
MODERATOR ARE WE IS- DR LYNNE
CARPENTER BOGGS AVAILABLE. YES
WE SHOW THAT- DOCTOR CARPENTER
BOGGS LINE IS OPEN OKAY- YOU
MAY BE NEEDED OR- THANK YOU CAN
YOU HEAR ME NOW YES WE CAN HEAR
YOU NOW. OKAY PLEASE BE ON DR
LYNNE CARPENTER BOGGS BUT I'M A
PROFESSOR OF SCIENCE AND
SUSTAINABLE AGRICULTURE AT
WASHINGTON STATE UNIVERSITY IN
PULLMAN. FIVE HUNDRED SEVENTY
TOTAL PLANT FOR THIRTY YEARS
WITH A FOCUS ON ORGANIC FARMING
AND COMPOSTING THIS INCLUDES
TWENTY THREE YEARS EXPERIENCE
WITH LIVESTOCK MORTALITY
COMPOSTING. IN TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN ANOTHER RESEARCH
PROJECT AT WASHINGTON STATE
UNIVERSITY IN PARTNERSHIP WITH
THREE COME CLOSE TO STUDY
NATURAL ORGANIC PRODUCTION. OUR
RESEARCH CONCLUDED THIS PROCESS
IS SAFE AND EFFECTIVE AS A
MEANS OF THE PHYSICIANS FOR
HUMAN. THE FINISH MATERIAL IN
FILING AN UNRECOGNIZABLE
VISUALLY CHEMICALLY OR MICRO
BIOLOGICALLY AS HUMAN REMAINS.
IN COLLABORATION WITH THE
COMPOSER I HAVE NO SUPERVISED
THE TESTING- FORTY BODIES AND
THEY'RE CONVERTED INTO FOIL IN
WASHINGTON STATE. I CAN ATTEST
THAT THE FINISHED PRODUCT NEEDS
ARE ACHIEVED THANKS YOUR
REQUIREMENTS FOR PEOPLE CALL
FARM BACTERIA SALMONELLA
ARSENIC CADMIUM LEAD MERCURY SO
ANY AND ALL ANY. HEAVY METALS.
BUT- RICHARD THE FINAL MATERIAL
IS ALSO AN ECOLOGICAL SOIL
AMENDMENTS I CAN THINK OF
SECONDLY NURSE FOR LAND. LANDS
AND FORESTS. THE PRODUCT IS
SAFE AND EFFECTIVE AS A DOCTOR
CHOICE FOR CALIFORNIANS
PUBLISHED AND I SUPPORT THIS
BILL THANK YOU FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION. THANKS VERY MUCH
YOU WILL NOW MOVE ON TO
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES AND
SUPPORT OF EIGHTY FIVE OH ONE-
WILL BEGIN PUBLIC GALLERY SCENE
ON THE PUBLIC OUT OF MIKE
PHILLIPS MOVED THROUGH TWENTY
FORTY. THREE NO ONE ROOM TWENTY
FORTY MODERATOR PLEASE BRING ON
THE LINE WITNESSES WHO WISHES
US A FIGHT AND SUPPORT AT.
EIGHTY FIVE OH ONE NAME
ORGANIZATION POSITION ONLY. OR
COMMENT IN SUPPORT OF H. B.
FIVE OH ONE PLEASE PRESS ONE
AND THEN ZERO. THAT COMMAND
AGAIN. ONE ZERO. LINE ONE
HUNDRED THIRTY FOUR PLEASE GO
AHEAD. EAGLESON WITH
CALIFORNIANS AGAINST WASTE AND
SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK YOU
NEXT LINE. MR KERR THERE ARE NO
FURTHER COMMENT AT THIS TIME
RIGHT THANK YOU I WILL NOW MOVE
ON TO THE OPPOSITION TO EIGHTY
FIVE OH ONE WE DO NOT HAVE A
LEAD OPPOSITION WITNESS
REGISTERED TO TESTIFY- SO WE
COULD MOVE ON TO ADDITIONAL
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION EIGHTY
FIVE A ONE GO TO PUBLIC GALLERY
SCENE ON THE PUBLIC ALLEY SOME
ROOM TO ROOM TWENTY FORTY
SEEING NO ONE ROOM TWENTY
FORTY. AS I CAN SEE ROOM TWENTY
FORTY AND US GOING THERE- WILL
BATTERY- PLEASE BRING ON THE
LINE WITNESSES WHO WISH TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION. TO
EIGHTY FIVE OH ONE. NAME OR
POSITION POSITION ONLY. FOUR
COMMENTS IN OPPOSITION TO IT
EIGHTY FIVE OH ONE PLEASE PRESS
ONE AND THEN ZERO. BACK COMMAND
AGAIN ONE THEN THERE. AND
MISTER CHAIR WE HAVE NO COMMENT
AT THIS TIME RIGHT THANK YOU I
LET'S BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE OF YOUR QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS ABOUT EIGHTY FIVE A
ONE. OKAY SAYING NONE- SORRY I
MEANT THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
PRESENTING THIS BILL ON BEHALF
OF THE CENTRE CHRISTINA GARCIA
HAD OPPORTUNITY ALSO HERE THIS
BILL AND- THIS IS PROFESSIONS.
I THINK IT'S GREAT WE'RE GIVING
PEOPLE AN OPPORTUNITY FOR
DISPOSING THE BODY AND A-
DIFFERENT WAY THAT- MAYBE MORE
IN LINE WITH THEIR VALUES- AND-
CERTAINLY ARE. FOR OUR
COMMITTEE WILL ENSURE THAT IT'S
A SAFE PROCESS BOTH. FOR
EVERYONE WHICH- FOR PUBLIC
HEALTH THAT YOU LEAVE. AS
EXPRESS THAT SO WITH THAT WE'D
LIKE TO CLOSE. YES I DID I
THINK THE AUTHOR SHARES YOUR
CONCERNS AND THAT'S WHERE WE
GET EXTENDED THE IMPLEMENTATION
DATE FOR PUBLIC HELP TO REALLY
TAKE A GOOD LOOK AT. THE THE
PROCESS AND WITH THAT I WOULD
ASK FOR THE I. BUT WHEN A
QUORUM IS PRESENT THANK YOU.
THANKS VERY MUCH- SO AGAIN ONCE
WE HAVE A QUORUM WE WILL. THEN
TAKEIT UP FOR A VOTE. ALL
RIGHT LET'S MOVE ON TO ITEM
NUMBER SIX EIGHTY. FIVE THIRTY
FIVE BY CENTER AT YOUR CURRY
WELCOME. THANK YOU MR. SINCE
THE OPPONENTS OF THIS BILL
SOMEHOW FOUND IT OFFENSIVE TO
PUT THE WORDS ALL OF OIL IN THE
DISCLOSURE OF HOW MUCH ALL OF
OIL IS IN THE BOTTLE OF OLIVE
OIL I WILL RESPECT YOUR WISHES
AND ACCEPT YOUR MOMENT TO
REMOVE THOSE WORDS FROM THE NEW
DISCLOSURE REQUIREMENTS. I WANT
TO THANK YOUR COMMITTEE STAFF
FOR THEIR EFFORTS TO ASSIST US.
AND TO THINK SENATOR HER TADO
SENATOR A MINNESOTA WINTER FOR
THE CO AUTHORING OF THIS BILL.
I BELIEVE THE AMENDMENT WILL
REMOVE THE REMAINING OPPOSITION
TO THE BILL SO I WILL KEEP THIS
SHORT. THE WORST PLAYERS IN THE
OLIVE OIL MARKET HAVE CONTINUED
TO USE A LOOPHOLE. IN CURRENT
LAW TO REPRESENT THE PRODUCT AS
CALIFORNIANS EVEN THOUGH THEY
USE AS LITTLE AS FOURTEEN
PERCENT. CALIFORNIA OLIVES IN
THE BALLOONS. CHEAPER
INTERNATIONAL OLIVES UNDERCUT
CALIFORNIA FARMERS AND BRANDS
IS IT HERE TO THE HIGHEST AND
MOST EXPENSIVE ENVIRONMENTAL
LABOR AND CONSUMER STANDARDS IN
THE WORLD YOU KNOW WE TALK A
LOT ABOUT SUPPORTING OUR FAMILY
FARMERS IN THIS CAPITAL BUT
FRANKLY WE DON'T DO A WHOLE LOT
TO PROTECT THEM. IN THE MARKET
PLACE. SENATORS WITH THIS
DISCLOSURE REQUIREMENT FOR THE
PERCENTAGE OF CALIFORNIA ALL OF
WELL BEING USED. IN THE PRODUCT
MARKETED AS CALIFORNIA. WHEN IT
IS NOT A 100% CALIFORNIA ALL OF
THIS IS OUR CHANCE TO SHOW THAT
WHILE WE ASK A LOT WE WILL
FIGHT FOR THEM. AND SURE TRUTH
IN LABELLING. I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR A FIVE VOTE WITH ME
TODAY IS LOUIS BROWN FOR THE
COALITION IN TRUTH IN ALL OF
OIL LABELING. AND CAROLINE
BEALE HUNTER ON THE HALF OF THE
YEAR TO DO HE WENT TO NATION
THANK YOU. THANK YOU SUMMER-
CURRY AND I DECIDED THAT FIRST
OF ALL I. THANK YOU FOR YOUR-
LONG. WORK ON THIS AND DO
APPRECIATE YOU TAKING THE
AMENDMENTS- SO THANK YOU- WILL
NOW MOVE ON TO THE WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT OF EIGHTY FIVE THIRTY
FIVE- SO WE HAVE- MODERATOR
PLEASE BRING ON THE LINE. LOUIS
BROWN FROM THE COALITION FOR OF
TRUTH FOR ALL OF OIL LABELING
AND CAROLINE DEAL HUNTER FROM
THE- FUTURE DATE WHEN TO
NATION. WILL BEGIN WITH A LOUIS
BROWN YOU HAVE TWO MINUTES.
TOTAL FOR MINUTES BETWEEN THE
TWO OF YOU. PLEASE BE AWARE OF
ANY. THANK YOU. THIS IS LOUIS
BROWN CALLING ON BEHALF OF THE
COALITION FOR TRUTH AT ALL OR
LABELING. THE EFFORTS YOU AND
YOUR COMMITTEE ONSULTANT MADE
ON THIS- I'LL KEEP OUR COMMON
SHORT- BECAUSE THE OFFICER-
EXPLAINED THE PURPOSE OF THE
BILL. REALLY WLL BUT I THINK
FOR. TWENTY FIVE YEARS THE
CALIFORNIA ALL OF THE OIL
INDUSTRY HAS. REALLY MADE. AN
EFFORT TO SET OURSELVES APART.
FROM ALL OF WILL PRODUCE ALL
OVER THE WORLD. WITH THE
HIGHEST QUALITY STANDARDS IN
THE WORLD AND WE'VE BEEN REALLY
FOCUSING ON THE IDEA OF. MAKING
THE BRAND CALIFORNIA OLIVE OIL
SPECIAL AND UNIQUE. SO IT'S
IMPORTANT THAT IS WE NOW
SEARCHING IN THE MARKETPLACE
BLENDED ALL OF OIL. HOW TO
UTILIZE HIS TERMS OF CALIFORNIA
ON LABELS THAT CONSUMERS KNOW.
THE ACTUAL PERCENTAGE OF
CALIFORNIA ALL OF WELL IN THOSE
BOTTLES SO THEY CAN MAKE PROPER
DECISIONS- WHEN PURCHASING AT
ALL WELL WE WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT. CALIFORNIANS AND
CONSUMERS AROUND KNOW THAT WHEN
THEY'RE BUYING CALIFORNIA OLIVE
OIL THAT THE ERSON USED TO
STAND THERE AND EVERY OTHER
TIME WHEN THEY CAN IT'S
ACTUALLY 1100% CALIFORNIA ALL
ALSO- WITH. THE CHANGES IN THE
BILL WE THINK IT PROVIDES GOOD
CONSUMER DISCLOSURE HI KRISTIN
IN LABELING AND FOR THOSE
REASONS WILL ASK FOR AN ARTICLE
TODAY THANK YOU. THANK YOU
LET'S NOW BRING ON NATURAL
UNTIL HUNTER. PLEASE BEGIN
LATER THIS IS THE- YES
MODERATED BY MODERATOR WE DO
NOT SHOW THAT CAROLINE BEALE
HUNTER HAD CONNECTED. OKAY ALL
RIGHT WELL- PLEASE LET ME KNOW
WHEN SHE DOES WE'LL JUST GO
AHEAD AND- TAKE ON- THAT MOVE
ON TO ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT OF EIGHTY FIVE THIRTY
FIVE SO BEYOND THE PUBLIC
GALLERY- SEE NORTH OF THE
GALLEYS ROOM TO ROOM MOVED TO
ROOM TWENTY FORTY SEEN ON ROOM
TWENTY FORTY MODERATOR- PLEASE
OPEN THE LINES FOR WITNESSES
WHO WISH TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT
OF EIGHTY FIVE THIRTY FIVE.
NAME OR POSITION POSITION ONLY.
THANK YOU MR CHAIR FOR COMMENTS
IN SUPPORT OF EIGHTY. FIVE
THIRTY FIVE PLEASE PRESS ONE
AND THEN ZERO. AT COMMAND AGAIN.
ONE ZERO. LINE TWO HUNDRED ONE
YEAR MIKE ECHO. I APOLOGIZE WE
LOST ONE TWO HUNDRED ONE LIFE
TO UNDER TWO YEAR MIGHT. THANK
YOU CHAIRMAN PANEL MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE THIS IS CAROLINE
BEALE HUNTER ON BEHALF OF YOUR
TODAY HE WENT TO NATION A
FEDERALLY RECOGNIZED TRIBE IN
YOLO COUNTY AND COSPONSORED
MAYBE FIVE THREE FIVE. IN
NINETEEN EIGHTY FIVE YO TODAY
HE OPENED UP A SMALL BINGO HALL
WHICH IS TRANSFORMED INTO WHAT
IS NOW KNOWN AS CACHE CREEK
CASINO RESORT. WHAT WAS ONCE A
TRIBE WITHOUT BASIC RESOURCES
LIKE WATER AND FOOD IS NOW
POSSIBLE STEWARD OF THEIR
ANCESTRAL LAND. GROWING A WIDE
VARIETY OF CAREFULLY NURTURED
CROPS ONE OF WHICH IS OLIVE OIL
TREES. OLIVE TREES THE TRIBE
ALL BUILDING DEFECTOR HEALED
FOR THE ROLLING HILLS IS
SURROUNDED BY HIGHLY IT IS IT'S
AROUND IT BY A HIGHLY REGARDED
WORLDWIDE MOST RECENTLY
RECEIVED THE GOLD AWARD AT THE
TWENTY TWENTY NEW YORK
INTERNATIONAL OLIVE OIL
COMPETITION. THE TRIBE OF THE
PROPERTIES OF OLIVE OIL MADE
WITH 1100% CALIFORNIA GROWN
OLIVES AND THIS MAKES ALL THE
DIFFERENCE. THE MEDITERRANEAN
CLIMATE MAKES THE REGION AN
IDEAL PLACE TO GROW ALL TREES
IN THE TRIBE THAT'S A LOT OF
TIME AND RESOURCES INTO
BUILDING A STATE OF THE ART ALL
APPEAL TO START GROWERS IN THE
REGION. AT SECOND HILL TO TRY
TO USE THE MOST MODERN GROWING
AND HARVESTING TECHNIQUES SUCH
AS MECHANIZED HARVEST OF MEDIUM
DENSITY VARIETY GIVING
CUSTOMERS. MORE FLAVOR PROFILES
TO ENJOY. FINALLY SETTLED.
TRUCK TO THE OR ENABLES ALL OF
BE BUILT IN. I HARVEY TO
PRESERVE THE FRESH. THE TO
PROVOKE REDUCED A HIGH. VIRGIN
OLIVE OIL. THERE IS AN APPEAL
TO MAKE CHEAPER IMPORTED OIL
FOR SOME CALIFORNIA OIL USING
THE GOLDEN STATE'S REPUTATION
TO IMPROVE PROFIT MARGINS. BUT
IT IS UNETHICAL AND UNSAFE TO
PULL CONSUMERS JUST WAIT AND
UNFAIR TO PRODUCERS LIKE WE
TRIED TO PUT IN THE EXTRA
EFFORT TIME AND RESOURCES. TO
PRODUCE QUALITY CALIFORNIA
OLIVE OIL. EIGHTY FIVE THIRTY
FIVE PROTECTED CALIFORNIA OLIVE
OIL. FIVE YEARS AGO YOU KNOW TO
DO HE WORK WITH THEN ASSISTANT
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WALKED TO
ESTABLISH LABELING REGULATIONS.
EIGHTY FIVE THIRTY FIVE
POSSIBLY CLARIFIES WITH THE
BILL REALLY INTENDED TO DO.
ACKERLEY. LABEL CALIFORNIA
GROWN OLIVE OIL. THANK YOU AND
I DON'T DRIVE OUT. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH ALL RIGHT- THE
WITNESSES WHO WISH TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT OF EIGHTY FIVE
THIRTY FIVE ON THE TELEPHONIC
LINE. LINE ONE HUNDRED NINETY
EIGHT YOU'RE MY COULD OPEN.
GOOD AFTERNOON THE MIND THE
HEART ON BEHALF OF THE FAMILY
WINEMAKERS UP CALIFORNIA IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU NEXT LINE.
LINE TWO HUNDRED ONE. K. RANKS
AND COMMUNITY ALLIANCE WITH
FAMILY FARMERS IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU NEXT LINE. MISTER CHAIR
THERE ARE NO FURTHER COMMENT AT
THIS TIME. THANKS VERY MUCH
WE'LL NOW MOVE ON TO OFFICE TO
A FIVE THIRTY FIVE. WE DO HAVE
ONE LEAD WITNESS OPPOSITION
WITNESS THIS ALBION E. FROM
CALIFORNIA OLIVE RANCH SHOES
BELIEVE UP IN THE GALLERY- YOU
HAVE UP TO FOUR MINUTES- SO FOR
A COUPLE OF TIMES BUT YOU DON'T
NEED TO TAKE ALL OF THAT.
PLEASE BEGIN WE'LL BE QUIT
THANK YOU THANK YOU JEREMY HAVE
A CALIFORNIA OLIVE RANCH
LARGEST GROWER AND MILLER OF
CALIFORNIA OLIVE OIL IN
CALIFORNIA AND ALL ITS ROLE OF
OIL WE APPRECIATE THE WORK OF
YOU DR PAN THE CONSULTANT MR
MARSHALL ON THE AUTHOR.
ASSEMBLYMAN ASSEMBLYWOMAN HECK
WE ARE CURRY AND THE SENATE AG
CHAIR CENTER BORDER SOME
WORKING ON THIS CALIFORNIA ALL
GRANTS APPRECIATE THE AUTHOR'S
COMMITMENT TO TRANSPARENCY AND
CONSUMER AWARENESS WHICH IS A
CORE VALUE THE BOTH OF US
SHARE. AND WITH THE AMENDMENTS
WE ARE NEUTRAL ON THE BILL AND
APPRECIATE YOUR WORK THANK YOU.
I THANKS VERY- WILL NOW MOVE ON
TO ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION TO EIGHTY FIVE
THIRTY FIVE I SEE NO ONE ELSE
IN THE PUBLIC GALLERY IT'S
MOVED TO ROOM TWENTY FORTY.
THREE KNOWN ROOM TWENTY FORTY
MODERATOR PLEASE OPEN THE LINES
FOR WITNESSES WHO WISH TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION. TO
EIGHTY FIVE THIRTY FIVE. FOUR
COMMENTS IN OPPOSITION TO IT
EIGHTY FIVE THIRTY FIVE PLEASE
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO. THAT
COMMAND AGAIN. ONE ZERO. AND
MISTER CHAIR WE HAVE NO
COMMENTS COMING THROUGH AT THIS
TIME ALL RIGHT THANKS VERY
MUCH- QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS A CENTER
RUBIO. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR-
FIRST OF ALL I THINK THE AUTHOR
FOR BRINGING THIS FORWARD I.
REALLY DO APPRECIATE WHAT HE'S
TRYING TO DO HERE WITH THIS
BILL. IT REALLY DOES PUT
CALIFORNIA FIRST AND- IT IS
APPROPRIATE THAT WE- REALLY
HAVE PUT IMPORTANCE IN OUR OWN
FARMS AND FARM WORKERS IT
REALLY DOES- HELP THE ECONOMY
IT HELPS. AN INDUSTRY THAT THAT
HAS REALLY WORKED REALLY HARD
AND WE ALL KNOW ESPECIALLY
DURING THIS PANDEMIC THEY JUST
KEPT WORKING SO. I WANNA REALLY
JUST HIGHLIGHT HAUNTING FULL-
THAT SHE'S WORKED SO HARD IN
THIS BILL AS EVIDENCED BY THE
FACT THAT. SHE DOESN'T HAVE
OPPOSITION I HAD MET WITH.
EVERY STAKEHOLDER AND I KNOW
THERE WAS A LOT OF DEBATE AND-
REALLY PLEASED TO SEE THAT THEY
CAME TO AN AGREEMENT BECAUSE I
THINK IT'S JUST IMPORTANT THAT.
WE SUPPORT THIS BILL AND THAT
WE PUT FOCUS ON CALIFORNIA
GROWN PRODUCTS- AND WITH THAT I
WOULD LIKE TO MOVE TO THE BILL
WHEN IT'S APPROPRIATE AND WE
HAVE A QUORUM THANK YOU. OKAY
THANK YOU. AT THE CENTER OF THE
LENDERS. THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN-
ASSETTO ASSEMBLYWOMAN- I. HAVE
A- THE TO MACULA LIBERAL
COMPANY IN MY DISTRICT AND THEY
HAD. SOME CONCERNS ABOUT THIS
BILL AND SO WE HAD A LENGTHY
DISCUSSION WITH THEM BETWEEN
THE COMMITTEE CONSULTANTS. AND
THE OWNERS TO MAKE SURE THAT
THIS WASN'T GOING TO ADVERSELY
AFFECT THEM IT APPEARS THAT-
THEY WILL BE FINE AND IT SOUNDS
AS THOUGH PERHAPS THE
OPPOSITION. THAT WAS ORIGINALLY
ON THE BILL WITH THE AMENDMENT
THAT YOU HAVE AGREED TO DATE
THEY WILL BE FALLING AWAY WHICH
IS GREAT NEWS AND I'M SURE
YOU'RE VERY HAPPY ABOUT THAT
THAT'S ALWAYS NICE WHEN THAT
HAPPENS- IT SO I'D BE. HAPPY TO
SUPPORT YOUR BILL TODAY THANK
YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH. RIGHT
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
SAYING NONE OF THEM ARECURRY.
REALLY APPRECIATE YOUR
LEADERSHIP IN FIGHTING FOR
FAMILY FARMERS IN CALIFORNIA I
KNOW YOU WENT TO A LOT. ON THIS
BILL. AT ISSUE WORKING WITH THE
COMMITTEE- BE ABLE TO REMOVE
ALL THE OPPOSITION- AND I'M NOT
JUST SAYING THAT BECAUSE I
REALLY LOVE YOUR T. SHIRT. THAT
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE YEAH
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND I. I
WANT TO THANK GOODNESS REVIEW
FOR HER COMMENTS A SUPPORTING
OUR FARMERS HERE IN CALIFORNIA
IN OUR PRODUCTS. LET'S FACE IT
THIS PULLS BOLSTERS THE
CALIFORNIA ECONOMY. WITH THAT I
SIMPLY ASKED FOR A VOTE ALL
RIGHT THANKS VERY MUCH- WHEN WE
ESTABLISH A QUORUM WE WILL THEN
TAKE YOUR BILL UP FOR A VOTE.
AND FOR ALL ANYONE WHO'S
WATCHING THIS- FROM A COMMITTEE
OFFICE WE ARE ONLY ONE SHORT OF
A QUORUM SO IF THERE'S A
COMMITTEE MEMBER WHO CAN RUN
DOWN HERE WE CAN STEP TO CORE-
AT THE MOMENT WITH THIS ONE
SHORT. THANK YOU. JUST AN
ANNOUNCEMENT ALL RIGHT. LET'S
SEE WHO IS HELP THEY SEE THERE
YOU GO SORRY I'M LOOKING TO-
THE PLEXIGLASS LET'S MOVE ON TO
ITEM NUMBER. EIGHT EIGHTY EIGHT
FIVE EIGHT BY SOME MEMBER JOHN
SAWYER. WELCOME GIVE US A
MOMENT TO TIDY UP THE PODIUM
HERE. ALL RIGHT WELCOME PLEASE
BEGIN. THANK YOU THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR I WOULD LIKE TO
START BY ACCEPTING AMENDMENTS
PROPOSED IN THE COMMITTEE
ANALYSIS. REALLY THANK YOU TO
COME THE COMMITTEE CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE STAFF FOR WORKING
WITH MY OFFICE. THESE
AMENDMENTS ADDRESS RAISED BY
THE COMMITTEE TO CLARIFY THAT
A. B. EIGHT FIVE EIGHT DOES NOT
PREVENT HOSPITAL FROM DIRECTING
HEALTHCARE WORKERS TO FOLLOW
LEGITIMATE. NATIONALLY
RECOGNIZED QUALITY IMPROVEMENT
AND STANDARD OF CARE GUIDELINES
THIS BILL ALLOWS HEALTHCARE
WORKERS PROVIDING DIRECT
PATIENT CARE TO OVERRIDE A
HOSPITAL ALGORITHM WHEN IS
WITHIN THEIR SCOPE OF PRACTICE
WHICH INCLUDES. PHYSICIAN
APPROVAL AND ULTIMATELY IN THE
BEST INTEREST OF THE PATIENT.
WELL I RHYTHMS ARE AN IMPORTANT
TOOL USED TO HELP DECIDE THE
BEST COURSE OF TREATMENT FOR
MILLIONS OF PATIENTS A YEAR ARE
RHYTHMIC BIAS AND SPECIFICALLY
RACIAL BIAS IN THE HEALTHCARE
INDUSTRY A WELL DOCUMENTED
ISSUES. IN TWENTY NINETEEN
RESEARCHERS STUDIED THE OUTPUT
OF A WIDELY USED HOSPITAL
ROBBERY THEM IF FOUND EXHIBITED
SIGNIFICANT RACIAL BIAS WHEN
REFERRED BLACK PATIENTS TO
EXTRA CARE PROGRAMS
SIGNIFICANTLY FEWER THAN WHITE
PATIENTS. ALTHOUGH TECHNOLOGY
CAN COMPLEMENT THE SKILLS IN
DECISION MAKING OF HEALTHCARE
PROVIDERS IT IS NOT A
REPLACEMENT FOR REAL LIFE
EXPERIENCE. I HAVE HAD MY OWN
EXPERIENCE WITH INTERVENTION OF
A NURSE SAVE MY LIFE WHEN I WAS
FIRST DIAGNOSED WITH DIABETES.
IT WAS A NURSE. AND THE
ALGORITHMIC. THE STUDY THAT WAS
DONE. AND THE DOCTOR ALL COMING
TOGETHER TO GIVE ME A QUALITY
OF CARE. THAT TOOK ME OFF OF
INSULIN. AND CUT MY MET FOREMAN
ENCRYPTED SITE IN HALF. IT IS
THE IT IS THE COMBINATION OF
ALL THREE THAT ULTIMATELY
HELPED ME WITH MY HEALTH CARE.
WE AT THE LEGISLATURE HAVE
INCREASINGLY PASSED BILLS TO
ADDRESS THE IMPLEMENT IMPLICIT
BIASES OF INDIVIDUALS SUCH AS
TECHNOLOGY BECOMES MORE MORE
INGRAINED IN OUR SOCIETY IS
ONLY RIGHT THAT WE TAKE SOME
SOME SOME THOSE SAME STEPS TO
ADDRESS ITS LIMITATIONS AS
WELL. MAJOR HOSPITAL SYSTEMS
ACROSS THE STATE ALREADY
RECOGNIZED THIS NEED AND HAVE
INCORPORATED THE SAME
RETALIATION PROTECTIONS THIS
BILL IS CREATING. INTO THEIR
OWN POLICIES ULTIMATELY WHEN WE
ALLOW ALGORITHMS. DOCTORS AND
NURSES TO WORK TOGETHER TO
PROVIDE THE BEST CARE AND
REDUCE THE IMPACT OF THOSE
BIASES IN ALL ASPECTS OF HEALTH
CARE WE WILL SAVE LIVES. EIGHTY
EIGHT FIVE EIGHT PROMOTES
PATIENT WELL BEING IMPROVES
PATIENTS QUALITY OF CARE BY
PUTTING THEIR TRUST BACK INTO
THE HANDS OF THE WORKERS
PROPERLY TRAINED TO DO THEIR
JOB. WITH ME TODAY. TO PROVIDE
TESTIMONY OVER THE PHONE IS
TAYLOR JACKSON ON BEHALF OF THE
BILL SPONSORED THE CALIFORNIA
NURSES ASSOCIATION. AND JANICE
FORMALITY BUT THE CALIFORNIA
LABOR FEDERATION. MEMBERS ARE
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR NEITHER.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH SENATOR
JOHN SAWYER AND AGAIN THANK YOU
SO MUCH FOR- WORKING WITH THE
COMMITTEE STAFF AND TAKING THE
AMENDMENTS. SO WITH THAT LET'S
MOVE ON TO- MODERATOR PLEASE
BRING ON THE LINE OUR LEAD
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT AT TAYLOR
JACKSON FROM CALIFORNIA NURSES
ASSOCIATION AND JANICE M. ALLEY
FOR THE CALIFORNIA LABOR
FEDERATION. LET'S BEGIN WITH
TAYLOR JACKSON YOU HAVE TWO
MINUTES TOTAL FOR MINUTES
BETWEEN BOTH WITNESSES. THANK
YOU MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS TAYLOR
JACKSON WITH THE CALIFORNIA
NURSES ASSOCIATION. WE ARE THE
PROUD SPONSORS OF EIGHTY EIGHT
POINT EIGHT AND THANK YOU TO DR
PAN AND COMMITTEE STAFF FOR
WORKING WITH THAT. IDON'T
REMEMBER PLAYER THAT IMPLICIT
BIAS IS HUGE ISSUE IN HEALTH.
DATA SHOWN BIASES INHERENT IN
THE ALGORITHM USED IN HOSPITALS
WHICH DO EVERYTHING FROM
SETTING PRESCRIPTION PLANS
DESIGNATING PATIENT ACUITY AND
DETERMINING WHEN YOU'LL BE GETS
CHARGED. EIGHTY EIGHT FIVE
EIGHT ENSURES THAT A NURSE CAN
DISAGREE WITH THE CLINICAL
ALGORITHM TO MAKE THE BEST
TREATMENT DECISION FOR THEIR
UNIQUE FEATURE WITHOUT FEAR OF
PUNISHMENT FROM THEIR EMPLOYER
SOLELY FOR THAT POSITION. THE
BILL ALSO CREATES OPPORTUNITIES
FOR GREATER WORKER ENGAGEMENT
WITH TECHNOLOGY AT THE-HOSPITAL. ASKING THAT WORKERS
BE NOTIFIED WHEN NEW TECHNOLOGY
AFFECTING THEIR JOB IS BEING
BROUGHT IN. THAT WORKERS GET
THE OPPORTUNITY TO GIVE SOME
INPUT ON WHAT KIND OF
TECHNOLOGY IS SELECTED.
EMINEM'S LAWYERS PROVIDE
ADEQUATE TRAINING FOR THE NEW
TECHNOLOGY. NURSES ARE ALREADY
BOUND BY THEIR LICENSE HEALTH
AND SAFETY CODE AND REGULATIONS
AND THEIR TIRELESS COMMITMENT
TO THEIR PATIENTS TO DO WHAT IS
RIGHT AND PROVIDE THE BEST CARE
AND TREATMENT POSSIBLE. HOWEVER
WITHOUT A CLEARLY OUTLINED
RETALIATION. HEALTH CARE
WORKERS WILL CONTINUE TO BE PUT
IN THE POSITION FOR THE FACT
HERE THEY'RE PROVIDING FOR
THEIR PATIENTS. PUT THEIR JOB
AND LIVELIHOOD ON THE LINE. IT
IS IMPORTANT TO NOTE THIS DOES
NOT MEAN HEALTHCARE WORKERS
WOULD BE FREE FROM OVERSIGHT
MONITORING OR GET SOMEONE
CALIFORNIA HAS STRONG FEELING
OUR LICENSING BOARDS THAT
OVERSEE THEIR MEMBERS AND
DISCIPLINE. BENT OVER ROW BOTH
LIFE. WHEN APPROPRIATE AND THE
FIELDS OF NOTHING TO CHANGE
THOSE PROFIT. HOSPITAL WOULD
ALSO RETAIN THE ABILITY TO
DISCIPLINE A WORKER OR ENGAGING
IN UNSAFE PRACTICES. I WOULD
FURTHER NO CLINICAL ALGORITHMS
AND TECHNOLOGIES HAVE NO STATE
OVERSIGHT PROCESS AND THERE ARE
NO HEALTH AND SAFETY LAWS AND
HOW THEY ARE USED OR
IMPLEMENTED. ON LIKE ACTUAL
HEALTH CARE WORKERS. TREATMENT
OF NEVER A ONE SIZE FITS ALL
FORMULA AND THE PROVISIONS IN
THE BILL WILL BE IN THE NURSE'S
PRIORITY CAN REMAIN THEIR
PATIENTS. FOR THAT REASON FEE
AND I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR.
I. KNOW DONT EAT IT THANK YOU.
THANKS FOR MUCH NOW LOOKS UP
JANICE- MALLEY FROM CAL LABOR
FEDERATION YOU HAVE A MINUTE
FIFTY FIVE SECONDS. GREAT THANK
YOU AND KERR AND MEMBERS- THIS
IS JENNIFER CALLING WITH THE
CALIFORNIA LABOR FEDERATION.
WHERE HERE IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
EIGHTY EIGHT FIVE EIGHT. THE
COVER NINETEEN PANDEMIC IS
PRESENTING A DISPROPORTIONATE
IMPACT ON MINORITIES TRUMP
ACTION RATE HOSPITALIZATIONS
AND MORTALITY. MANY BELIEVE
ARTIFICIAL INTELLIGENCE
SOLUTIONS TO GUIDE CLINICAL
DECISION MAKING FOR THE NOVEL
PROCEEDS. RESULTING IN A RAPID
DISSEMINATION OF UNDERDEVELOPED
AND POTENTIALLY BY MODELS.
WHICH MAY EXACERBATE THE
DISPARITY GAP. THERE IS HOPE
THAT AI CAN HELP GUIDE
TREATMENT DECISIONS INCLUDING
THE ALLOCATION OF SCARCE
RESOURCES WITHIN THIS CRISIS.
HOWEVER SHOULD NOT LIMIT
INDEPENDENT PROFESSIONAL
CLINICAL JUDGMENT OR HEALTHCARE
WORKERS ABILITY TO ACT AS A
PATIENT ADVOCATE. ALGORITHMS
SHOULD. NOT DETERMINE THE CARE
NEEDED BY PATIENTS. GIVEN THE
PERVASIVE OF BI I FAILURE TO
CROSS TO COME. MITIGATION
STRATEGIES DURING THE COPA
NINETEEN PANDEMIC. RISK
EXACERBATING EXISTING HEALTH
DISPARITIES AND HINDERING THE
ADOPTION OF A. I. TOOL CAPABLE
OF IMPROVING PATIENT OUTCOMES.
EIGHTY EIGHT HIGH BASED ON A
PATH TO MAKE SURE CALIFORNIANS
REGARDLESS OF THEIR ETHNICITY
OR ECONOMIC STATUS RECEIVE THE
BEST CARE FOR THEM. AND PROTECT
HEALTHCARE WORKERS FROM
RETALIATION IF THEY REQUEST
OVER A HEALTH INFORMATION
TECHNOLOGY AND CLINICAL
PRACTICE GUIDELINE. THE LABOUR
SAID IT'S PROUD TO SUPPORT AT
EIGHT FIVE EIGHT AM
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST. YOUR VOTE
ON THIS LEGISLATION THANK YOU.
THANKS FOR. WELL NOW ON TO
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
OF EIGHTY FIVE EIGHT WILL BEGIN
WITH THE PUBLIC. SO ON THE
PUBLIC ALLIES FROM TO ROOF
TWENTY FOUR SEEN ON ROUTE
TWENTY. FIVE RAIDERS BRING ON
LINE WHO WISH TO TEST IN
SUPPORT OF A FIVE. AND EIGHTY
EIGHT FIVE EIGHT NAME OR IS A
POSITION ONLY. FOR COMMON IN
SUPPORT OF EIGHTY. EIGHT FIVE
EIGHT PLEASE PRESS ONE TO SEND
ZERO. THAT COMMAND AGAIN. ONE
ZERO. AND WE HAVE NO COMMENTS
COMING THROUGH AT THIS TIME ALL
RIGHT THANK YOU WILL NOW MOVE
ON TO THE OPPOSITION TO EIGHTY
EIGHT FIVE EIGHT- MODERATOR
PLEASE BRING ON THE LINE OR
LEAD WITH OPPOSITION WITNESSES
WE HAVE RUN. BRAWNY PAPER DO GO
FROM THE CALIFORNIA HOSPITAL
ASSOCIATION AND GET IN BOMB I
BELIEVE IS A VEILED FOR JUST
TECHNICAL QUESTION SO- SO
BASICALLY FOR THE CALIFORNIA
HOSPITAL SAYS YOU SHOULD NEED
YOU HAVE UP TO FOUR MINUTES FOR
EQUIVALENT TIME. PLEASE BEGIN
WHEN YOU RAISE A RUNNY BIRD
VERDUGO. HI GOOD AFTERNOON
CHAIRMAN OF THE COMMITTEE-
RONNIE VERTIGO HERE ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA HOSPITALS
THAT THE ASIAN- WILL FEATURE
APPRECIATE THE WORK OF THE
COMMITTEE AND THE AUTHOR- WE
REGRETFULLY REMAINED FOLLOWS
UNLESS THE MANDATE. TO EIGHTY
EIGHT FIVE EIGHT I REALLY DO
THINK THIS IS A BILL WHERE WE
CAN FIND A MIDDLE GROUND- HI
REMAINING OUTSTANDING CONCERN
HOWEVER WITH THE BILL- IS THAT
THE PROVISIONS HAVE BEEN MOVED
INTO THE LABOR CODE- WHICH WILL
UNNECESSARILY EXPOSED HOSPITALS
TO PRIVATE RIGHT OF ACTION
LITIGATION. OR WHAT WE ALL KNOW
THE PART A LIABILITY OUR
HEALTHCARE WORKERS AVE MANY
PROTECTIONS UNDER EXISTING LAW-
INCLUDED PROTECTIONS WHEN
PROVIDING CARE FOR PATIENTS.
HOWEVER AS IT RELATES TO
POPULATE BILITY FOR SCOPE OF
PRACTICE THE ISSUES- WE FIND IT
INAPPROPRIATE AND FRANKLY A BIT
UNPRECEDENTED ACTION MOVIES
ISSUED OUT OF THE HEALTH AND
SAFETY CODE AND INTO THE LABOR
CODE- AND NOTED ON PAGE FIVE OF
THE COMMITTEE ANALYSIS- WE
OFFERED SEVERAL MODEST
AMENDMENTS ONE OF WHICH ONE OF
WHICH WHAT YOU. POSSIBLY MOVE
THE LANGUAGE INTO THE HEALTH
AND SAFETY CODE- WHICH WE FEEL
IS THE MORE APPROPRIATE
JURISDICTION ARE FOR WHAT THIS
BILL THEY NEED TO ACHIEVE
UNFORTUNATELY THE AMENDMENTS
TAKEN TODAY I FELT THAT THEY
COULD- THOSE CONCERNS INTO
CONSIDERATION. FOR THOSE
REASONS WE RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST- YOU KNOW BOTH- THANK
YOU FOR YOUR TIME YOU CONSIDER.
AND I'M SURE IF THEY ARE
GETTING BACK WHAT THEY WANTED
TO US BY. I HAVE TO TAKE ANY
QUESTIONS FROM THE COMMITTEE AS
WELL. RIGHT THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR NOW MOVING TO ADDITION
WITNESSES A OP. TO EIGHTY EIGHT
FIVE EIGHT WE'RE GOING TO
PUBLIC GALLERY SCENE ON PUBLIC
OUT MOVED TO ROOM TWENTY.
SENIOR ONE TWENTY. MODERATOR
BRING ON THE LINE WITNESSES WHO
WISH TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION
TO EIGHTY EIGHT FIVE EIGHT.
NAME OR POSITION POSITION ONLY.
FOUR COMMENTS IN OPPOSITION TO
IT AP EIGHT FIVE EIGHT. PLEASE
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO. THAT-COMMAND AGAIN. ONE ZERO. MISTER
CHAIR THERE ARE NO COMMENTS
COMING THROUGH AT THE TIME OKAY
THANK YOU MODERATOR WILL BRING
IT BACK TO COMMITTEE QUESTIONS
COMMENTS FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
OKAY SAYING NONE. AS A MEMBER
AGAIN THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
WORKING WITH OUR COMMITTEE ONE
OF MY CONCERNS WAS TO BE SURE
THAT WE DIDN'T. HAVE A CONFLICT
WITH NATIONAL PRACTICE
GUIDELINES- I THINK WE ALL.
WANT TO TRY TO BE SURE WE
IMPROVE QUALITY AND- THERE AND
DID NOT CREATE YEAH I KNOW
THAT'S NOT THE INTENT OF
ORIGINAL BILL EVEN WITHOUT THE
AMENDMENT- BUT JUST A QUICK
CLARIFICATION ON THAT POINT. SO
I DO APPRECIATE YOU WORKING
WITH ME ON THAT- BUT CERTAINLY
WE WANT TO ALSO RESPECT THE
PROFESSIONAL TANAMI OF
SOCIETY'S PROFESSIONALLY HELP
PROFESSIONALS. THAT WHICH
REALLY CLOSE. I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR VOTE. RIGHT THANK
YOU THANK YOU SO WE'VE EVER-
WE'LL HAVE TO WAIT FOR CORN FOR
THAT BUT THANKS SO MUCH FOR
PRESENTATION. THANK YOU. OKAY
NEXT ITEM IS ITEM NUMBER TEN
EIGHTY FIVE SO JUST REMINDED I
AM NUMBER NINES ON CONSENT ITEM
NUMBER TEN EIGHTY FORTINO SEVEN
BY SOME MEMBER BURKE. WELCOME
THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN SENATORS
I'D LIKE TO START BY THANKING
THE COMMITTEE FOR WORKING WITH
MY STAFF ON THIS MEASURE AND I
WILL BE TAKING THE COMMITTEE
SUGGESTED AMENDMENTS TO
STREAMLINE. THE REQUIREMENTS
FOR THE NEW GRADUATES IN THE
PERINATAL NURSES AND TO ALSO
CLARIFY THE CONTINUING
EDUCATION REQUIREMENT FOR
LICENSEE WITHIN THEIR FIRST TWO
YEARS OF LICENSURE. AB FORTINO
SEVEN SPONSORED BY THE
CALIFORNIA NURSES ASSOCIATION
REQUIRES NURSING PROGRAMS AND
HOSPITALS TO INCLUDE IMPLICIT
BIAS EDUCATION FOR NURSES THAT
WILL HELP BRING EXISTING
DISPARITIES AND NEGATIVE HEALTH
OUTCOMES TO AN END. EVIDENCE
EXISTS THAT SUGGESTS THAT THE
PRESENCE OF IMPLICIT BIAS AND
HEALTHCARE SYSTEM LEADS TO
DIFFERENCES IN THE QUALITY OF
CARE GIVEN TO PATIENTS. THE
EVIDENCE ALSO SHOWS THAT MORE
OFTEN THAN NOT PEOPLE OF COLOR
AND WOMEN ARE THE ONES TO BE.
SENT TO BE NEGATIVELY IMPACTED
BY THIS BIAS. IN A HEALTHCARE
SETTING DECISIONS AFFECTED BY
THIS BIAS CAN HAVE LIFE AND
DEATH IMPLICATIONS AS IT
MANIFESTS ITSELF THROUGHOUT
SUBTLEDIFFERENCES IN HOW
HEALTH CARE PROVIDERS INTERACT
WITH PATIENTS OR DIFFERENCES IN
HEALTH CARE TREATMENTS. THIS IS
UNACCEPTABLE AND MUST BE
ADDRESSED. EFFORTS HAVE BEEN
MADE TO REDUCE IMPLICIT BIAS IN
THE HEALTH CARE SYSTEM AND
THERE IS DEMONSTRATED
COMMITMENT BY THE HEALTH CARE
FACILITIES AND EDUCATORS
TOWARDS MITIGATING NEGATIVE
HEALTH CARE OUTCOMES. THESE
EFFORTS MUST CONTINUE IF WE
WERE TO MAKE STRIDES TOWARD
ADDRESSING THE HEALTH NEEDS OF
OUR STATES MANY DIVERSE
POPULATION. EIGHTY FORTINO
SEVEN WILL BROADEN THESE
EFFORTS BRINGING AWARENESS TO
THESE ISSUES BY REQUIRING
IMPLICIT BIAS TRAINING FOR
NURSES IN OUR STATE AND ANOTHER
STEP. IN THE RIGHT DIRECTION
TOWARD MEETING THE NEEDS OF
CALIFORNIA'S DIVERSE
COMMUNITIES. THIS MEASURE
PASSED OFF OF SIMPLY FOR WITH
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN I. VOTE
IN SUPPORT OVER THE PHONE IT'S
CURTIS LANE WITH THE CALIFORNIA
NURSES ASSOCIATION. RIGHT
THANKS SO MUCH AS A MEMBER
BURKE AND AGAIN THANK YOU FOR
WORKING ON THE CANADIAN TAKING
AMENDMENTS. WE'LL PUT IT BACK
IN WITH- WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
OF EIGHTY FORTINO SEVEN SO
PLEASE BRING OUR MODERATOR
PLEASE BRING ON THE LINE CURTIS
LANE FOR THE CALIFORNIA NURSES
ASSOCIATION YOU HAVE TWO
MINUTES TO PRESENT. PLEASE
BEGIN. THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS FIRST ONE OF THE
GOVERNOR'S LOCATION PROBLEM
SPONSORS OF AB FOURTEEN OH
SEVEN. THANK YOU MR CHAIR ALSO
AND COMMITTEE FOR WORKING WITH
US ON THIS BILL- IF YOU COULD
BUY IT EXISTS AMONG PEOPLE ALL
PROFESSIONS. HOWEVER WHEN
IMPLICIT BIAS PERSISTS AND
HEALTHCARE SETTING IT MAY
CONTRIBUTE TO THE HEALTH CARE
DISPARITIES EXPERIENCED BY
MEMBERS OF RACIAL. ETHNIC OR
RELIGIOUS MINORITIES AND OTHER
GROUPS. THE PREVALENCE OF
IMPLICIT BIAS IN THE HEALTHCARE
SETTING IN RESPECT OF THE
INADEQUACIES. WITHIN THE
HEALTHCARE SYSTEM AND
STRUCTURE. TOO OFTEN THE THIRTY
FAILED TO LOOK AT THE COMMUNITY
THEY SERVE. THOSE COMMUNITIES
NEEDS. AND THEIR RESOURCES.
OPPORTUNITIES NEED TO TAP TO
FILL THOSE NEEDS. HEALTH CARE
FACILITIES AND EDUCATORS MUST
DEMONSTRATE THEIR COMMITMENT.
TO ENDING RACIAL. HEALTH
DISPARITIES AND WORKING TO
TOWARD HEALTH EQUITY BY
AGGRESSIVELY PURSUING
STRATEGIES. THAT ELIMINATING
IMPLICIT BIAS WITHIN THE
HEALTHCARE SYSTEM. EIGHTY
FORTINO SEVEN RECOGNIZES THAT
AWARENESS. AND EDUCATION IS AN
ESSENTIAL STEP. TOWARD
ELIMINATING IMPLICIT BIAS IN
THE HEALTHCARE SETTING.
EDUCATING THE FUTURE HEALTHCARE
WORKFORCE. SO THAT THEY ARE
MINDFUL ABOUT THE IMPACT OF
IMPLICIT BIAS. TO THE PATIENTS
THEY SERVE IS PARAMOUNT TO
BRING THIS PART OF THE NON NON
TUNE IN. ACCORDINGLY WE
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I.
BOATS. ON THE B. FOURTEEN OH
SEVEN. AND I'M AVAILABLE TO
ANSWER ANY. TECHNICAL QUESTIONS
TODAY THANK YOU. OKAY THANK YOU
FOR MUCH FOR YOUR CUSTOM LET'S
MOVE ON ADDITIONAL AS A- AND
EIGHTY FOUR SAID. WE WITH GALA
SINGLED ALLEY LET'S MOVE TO
ROUTE TWENTY SEEN UNTIL FORTY.
PLEASE BRING ON THE LINE
WITNESSES WHO WISH TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT OF EIGHTY FORTINO
SEVEN DAME ORGANIZATION
POSITION. FOUR COMMENTS IN
SUPPORT OF AV FORTINO SEVEN
PLEASE PRESS ONE AT THE END
ZERO. THAT COMMAND AGAIN ONE
ZERO. LINE TWO HUNDRED EIGHT
YOUR MICROSCOPE. THANK YOU
CHAIR MEMBERS JENNIFER VALLEY
WITH THE CALIFORNIA LABOR
FEDERATION IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU NEXT LINE. ONE HUNDRED
FIFTY TWO. GOOD AFTERNOON MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS THIS IS ERIN
EVANS ON BEHALF OF THE BLACK
LEADERSHIP COUNCIL IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU THANK YOU NEXT LINE.
A LINE OF ONE HUNDRED FORTY
NINE. GOOD AFTERNOON THIS IS
KELLY BROOKS ON BEHALF OF THE
COUNTY HEALTH EXECUTIVES
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU NEXT LINE.
AND MISTER KERR THERE ARE NO
FURTHER COMMENT AT THE TIME
OKAY THANK YOU WILL NOW MOVE ON
TO WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION TO
EIGHTY FORTINO SEVEN WE HAVE NO
LEAD WITNESS OPPOSITION
WITNESS. TO TESTIFY SO WE'LL GO
TO THE PUBLIC GALLERY SCENE ON
THE PUBLIC GALLERY WAS MOVED TO
ROOM TWENTY FORTY SEEING NO ONE
ROOM TWENTY FORTY- BUT-
MODERATOR PLEASE OPEN THE LINES
FOR WITNESSES WHO WAS TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION TO EIGHTY
FOURTEEN OH SEVEN NAME
ORGANIZATION POSITION ONLY. FOR
COMMENTS IN HOUSE PRODUCTION TO
EIGHTY FOURTEEN OH SEVEN PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO. THAT COMMAND
AGAIN. ONE ZERO. AND WE HAVE NO
COMMENTS COMING THROUGH AT THIS
TIME ALL RIGHT THANK YOU
MODERATOR WILL BRING IT BACK TO
COMMITTEE QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS. OKAY
CENTER RUBIO. I'M SORRY BUT IT
SEEMS LIKE I'VE BEEN TALKING A
LOT TODAY BUT I JUST WANTED TO
SAY THANK YOU TO THE IT TO THE
ASSEMBLY. MEMBER FOR BRINGING
THIS FORWARD AND I ALSO WANT TO
BE A CO AUTHOR ON JUST
RECENTLY- AUTHORED A BILL ON
IMPLICIT BIAS IN THE REAL
ESTATE MARKET I THINK WHEN
WE'RE DEALING WITH PEOPLE'S
HEALTH IT'S EVEN MORE IMPORTANT
THAT. WE MAKE SURE THAT PEOPLE
ARE GIVEN PROPER HEALTH CARE
TREATMENT AND ALSO- REGARDLESS
OF THE COLOR THAT EVERYONE IS
TREATED FAIRLY SELF WITHOUT
ALMOST THE BILL WHENEVER. IT'S
APPROPRIATE IN CAMP. THANK YOU-
SO AGAIN WE DON'T YET HAVE A
QUORUM JUST ONE SHORT AT THE
MOMENT- SO SOMEONE MEMBER AGAIN
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR BRINGING
THIS BILL FORWARD- WE KNOW THAT
THERE'S- TREMENDOUS-
PERSISTENT. DISPARITIES IN
HEALTH OUTCOMES THAT WE SEE IN
SOME OF THAT UNFORTUNATELY
WE'VE IDENTIFIED AS BEING
DIFFERENCES IN CARE PEOPLE
RECEIVE. EVEN THOUGH THEY HAVE
THE SAME INSURANCE COVERAGE
EVEN IF THEY HAVE THE SAME
SOCIO ECONOMIC STATUS- AND- WE
NEED TO. HAVE HEALTH
PROFESSIONALS DRESS THE BIAS-
THE DAY MEANS THEMSELVES
UNFORTUNATELY AND- NOT BE AWARE
OF- AS WELL AND TO BRING IT OUT
TO RECOGNIZE IT AND TO HAVE
THAT SELF AWARENESS AGAIN I
THINK PART OF THE MEN. WAS
ACTUALLY TO IT'S REALLY A SELF
ASSESSMENT. THAT BRING THAT
SELF AWARENESS AND EDUCATION
NEED TO FOLLOW FROM THAT SO
AGAIN REALLY APPRECIATE YOUR
BILL UP. ELECTRICAL. HANG IN
THERE WE HAVE TO HAVE A VOTE ON
YOUR BILL OKAY. SO CONSULTANT
AT LEAST CALL THE ROLE TO
ESTABLISH A QUORUM PAN HERE CAN
HEAR MELINDA'S. EGGMAN EGGMAN
HERE GONZALEZ GONZALEZ HERE
GROW FURTADO YEAH THE TOTAL
HERE LLEVA. LABOR HERE EARLY
MON HERE WE MOAN HERE ROSS
RUBIO. PRESIDENT RUBIO HERE
WINNER. MELINDA'S HERE THANK.
K. THE CONSULTANT NOTES THAT WE
HAVE- WE HAVE ESTABLISHED A
QUORUM IS THERE A MOTION ON
EIGHTY FORTINO SEVEN OF ICE
OKAY CENTER ADMIN GOT THERE
FIRST- SO IT'S BEEN REVISED HER
ADMIN I SAW THERE'S A RACE
THERE THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED THE FIRST AMENDED
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS- CONSULTANT
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL PAN HI CAN
I AM MELINDA'S EGGMAN. EGGMAN
AIKEN SOLACE HI CAN SELL US ON
A GROWTH HER TADO HER TITLE I
LEAVE THAT HI LISA HIGHLY MON
HI THE MON HI ROSS RUBIO. HI
RUBIO I WINNER. OKAY SO THE
CURRENT ROLE THAT COUNTER SEVEN
ZERO PUT THE BILL ON CALL THANK
YOU. ALL RIGHT AND I THINK I
SEE A CELL NUMBER CHECK OUT ALL
RIGHT SO THE NEXT ITEM IS ITEM
NUMBER ELEVEN EIGHTY FOURTEEN
THIRTY SIX BY SOME MEMBER
CATHOLICS GIVE US A MOMENT TO
TIDY UP THE PODIUM HERE. RIGHT
WELCOME PLEASE BEGIN. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MR CHAIRMAN AND
SENATORS SO I YOU WANT TO START
BY ACCEPTING THE AMENDMENTS
WORKED OUT WITH THE COMMITTEE.
AS REFLECTED IN THE MOCK UP
THAT WAS CIRCULATED BY THE
COMMITTEE. THE AMENDMENTS NO
LONGER CLASSIFIED DIGITAL
HEALTH PRODUCTS BUSINESSES AS
PROVIDERS OF HEALTH CARE. BUT
INSTEAD OF REQUIRED THEM TO GET
WRITTEN CONSENT. FROM THE
CONSUMER PRIOR TO SHARING THEIR
PERSONAL HEALTH INFORMATION. I
THANK THE CHAIR AND ALSO THE
COMMITTEE SOUTH FOR A WORKING
WITH MY TEAM. A DIGITAL HEALTH
PRODUCTS ARE GIVING HEALTH CARE
PROVIDERS NEW WAYS TO GET
USEFUL INFORMATION ABOUT THEIR
PATIENTS. FOR EXAMPLE A DIGITAL
I AND MOBILE CONNECTED INHALER.
CAN DETECT WHEN A DEVICE IS
USED TO MEASURE THE STRENGTH OF
THE USER'S INTERPOLATION AND
TRANSMIT THIS INFORMATION TO
THE- USERS DR. ALSO SEVERAL
FORMS OF DIGITAL PILLS ARE
ALREADY IN USE. THESE PILLS CAN
RECORD THE TIME IN QUANTITY. A
DRUG IS TAKEN A PERSON'S
TEMPERATURE. ACTIVITY LEVEL AND
HEART RATE ALL OF THIS
INFORMATION CAN BE HIGHLY
SENSITIVE. AND WOULD UNDER
OTHER CIRCUMSTANCES BE
PROTECTED UNDER CLIA AND HIPAA.
HOWEVER FOR DATA TO BE
CONSIDERED MEDICAL INFORMATION.
IT NORMALLY NEEDS TO BE
GENERATED BY A HEALTH CARE
PROVIDER. INFORMATION GENERATED
OR COLLECTED AT A PATIENT LEVEL
AND OUTSIDE OF A MEDICAL
FACILITY WILL NOT BE CAPTURE.
UNDER A MEDICAL PRIVACY LAWS.
FURTHERMORE THIS KIND OF
PERSONAL DATA IS COLLECTED BY
BUSINESSES. AND OFTEN TIMES
SHARE WITH OTHER THIRD PARTIES.
WITHOUT THE USERS KNOWLEDGE OR
CONSENT. FOR EXAMPLE A TWENTY
NINETEEN STUDY INDICATED THAT
CERTAIN DEPRESSION AND SMOKING
CESSATION APPS SHARE
INFORMATION WITH FACEBOOK AND
GOOGLE. THAT COULD BE USED FOR
MARKETING PURPOSES. AND
DIFFERENT IT'S A SCENARIO AND
ENSURE A BOUGHT HEALTH RELATED
DIGITAL DATA OF ABOUT THREE
MILLION PEOPLE FROM A DATA
AGGREGATOR. THE BOTTOM LINE IS
EXISTING LAWS DO NOT
SUFFICIENTLY PROTECT THE
PRIVACY OF MEDICAL APP USERS.
AT FOURTEEN THIRTY SIX WILL
BRING THESE TECHNOLOGIES AND
INFORMATION THEY COLLECT UNDER
C. M. I. A. BY PROHIBITING. ANY
BUSINESS THAT OFFERS SUCH AN
APPLE. DEVICE FROM SELLING OR
SHARING THAT USERS HEALTH DATA
WITHOUT THEIR WRITTEN CONSENT.
THIS WILL ENSURE THAT SENSITIVE
HEALTH DATA IS TREATED THE SAME
WAY AS OUR DATA GENERATED IN A
TRADITIONAL MEDICAL SETTING. I
HAVE A ONE WITNESS TO TESTIFY
ON IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL.
THANKS VERY MUCH- SUMMER CHILD
AND AGAIN THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
TAKING THE AMENDMENTS- SO I
WOULD MAKE NOTE THAT- THERE TO
LEAD OPPOSITION WITNESSES SO WE
WILL ALLOW YOUR ONE LEAD-
SUPPORTING WITNESS TO HAVE UP
TO FOUR MINUTES FOR TESTIMONY
SO. MODERATOR PLEASE BRING ON
THE LINE MAUREEN MAHONEY FROM
CONSUMER REPORTS YOU HAVE. UP
TO FOUR MINUTES TO PRESENT
TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT OF AT
FOURTEEN THIRTY SIX. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE THANK YOU AGAIN FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK TODAY
MY NAME IS MAUREEN MAHONEY I'M
A SENIOR POLICY ANALYST AT
CONSUMER REPORTS. WE SUPPORT AT
FOURTEEN THIRTY SIX BECAUSE IT
WOULD EXTEND THE EXISTING
STRONG HEALTH PRIVACY LAW
CONFIDENTIALITY OF MEDICAL
INFORMATION ACT. THE SENSITIVE
HEALTH INFORMATION GENERATED BY
NEW FORMS OF HEALTH TECHNOLOGY.
STRONG PROTECTIONS OVER THIS
INFORMATION IS ESSENTIAL FOR
EXAMPLE CONSUMER PROTESTING
HAVE FOUND THAT MENTAL HAVE
HELPED OUT SHARE INFORMATION
ABOUT YOU WITH TECH COMPANIES
ATTRACTOR BEHAVIOR ACROSS OTHER
APPS. THAT INFORMATION CAN BE
COMBINED WITH OTHER DATAAND
USED TO TARGET ADS TO YOU BASED
pHEALTH STATUS AND DOWN THE ROAD
IT COULD BE OBTAINED BY OTHER
THIRD PARTIES AND USED TO MAKE
IMPORTANT DECISIONS ABOUT YOU
KNOW. CONSUMERS SHOULD BE ABLE
TO REACH OUT FOR HELP WITHOUT
WORRYING ABOUT HOW THAT DATA
MIGHT BE SHARED OR MISUSE.
ANALYSTS TRUE THAT THE
CALIFORNIA CONSUMER PRIVACY ACT
ARE YOU PRICES DATA. THE LAW IS
NOT A STRONG FOR EXAMPLE THE
TCPA ALLOWS CONSUMERS TO STOP
THE SALE OF THEIR PERSONAL
INFORMATION. BUT THE CMA BY THE
FALL PROHIBITS MOST PIECES OF
SHARING AT ALL IN CONSUMER
REPORTS TESTING AGAIN FOUND
THAT CONSUMERS OFTEN EXPERIENCE
DIFFICULTY UP TOGETHER STILL
THERE INFORMATION UNDER THE
CCPA. SENSITIVE MEDICAL
INFORMATION SHOULD BE GOVERNED
BY WEAKER SET OF LAWS JUT
BECAUSE IT'S COLLECTED BY AN
ONLINE SERVICE OR OTHER NEW.
TECHNOLOGY WITH RESPECT BETWEEN
THE MEMBERS WE HAVEN'T TAKEN A
POSITION ON THOSE WE NEED A BIT
MORE TIME TO EVALUATE BUT WE
APPRECIATE THE CONTINUED WORK
ON THE BILL AND URGE YOU TO
KEEP THE BALL MOVING FOR
TODAY'S WERE. VERY MUCH IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL PRINT THANK
YOU. THANKS VERY MUCH WILL NOW
TAKE ON ADDITIONAL WITNESSES
HERE FROM VISUAL WITNESSES AND
SUPPORT AT FOURTEEN THIRTY SIX
WE GOT THE PUBLIC GALLERY SCENE
ON PUBLIC OUT OF THIS ROOM.
NEUTERING TWENTY FORTY SCENE ON
ONE TWENTY FORTY. MODERATOR
PLEASE OPEN THE LINES FOR
WITNESSES WHO WISH TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT OF AT FOURTEEN
THIRTY SIX. NAME OF PARTITION
POSITIONALLY. FOUR COMMENTS IN
SUPPORT OF A. B. FOURTEEN
THIRTY SIX PLEASE PRESS ONE AND
THEN ZERO. RECOMMEND AGAIN. ONE
SEVEN ZERO. ONE ONE HUNDRED
EIGHTY TWO YEAR MIKE IS OPEN.
REMEMBER CATALINA SANCHEZ WITH
CORBETT AND KINDER ON BEHALF OF
THE ELECTRONIC FRONTIER
FOUNDATION AND PRIVACY RIGHTS
CLEARINGHOUSE WE ARE IN SUPPORT
OF THE BILL IN PRINT AND LOOK
FORWARD TO REVIEWING TV
COMEDIAN. THANK YOU THANK YOU
NEXT WITNESS. WHITE. ONE
HUNDRED THIRTY ONE. WHITE ONE
HUNDRED THIRTY ONE YEAR MIKE IS
OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON THIS IS
JENNIFER POP WITH THE NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL WORKERS
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER IN SUPPORT
OF EIGHTY. ONE FOUR THREE SIX
THANK YOU SO MUCH THANK YOU
NEXT WITNESS. AND MISTER CHAIR
WE HAVE A COUPLE MORE COMMENTS
COMING THROUGH JUST NOW B. ONE
MOMENT PLEASE HOLD WHILE WE
PROVIDE THEM WITH LIGHT NETWORK
THANK YOU. LINE TWO HUNDRED
THIRTY YOUR BIKE IS OPEN. HELLO
QUENTIN LEVEQUE ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA HEALTH COALITION
ADVOCACY IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU
EXLINE. Y. TWO HUNDRED TWENTY
NUMBERS DRASTICALLY BAY ON
BEHALF OF THE COMMITTEE
CONSIDERATION OF CALIFORNIA AND
SUPPORT. THANK YOU NEXT LINE.
MISTER CHAIR THERE ARE NO
FURTHER COMMENT AT THE TIME
THANK YOU SO MUCH WILL NOW MOVE
ON TO WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION
TO AT FOURTEEN THIRTY SIX
MODERATOR PLEASE BRING ONTO A
LINER TO THE OPOSITION
WITNESSES. SHOW OF MUHAMMAD-
FROM THE CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE AND FIELDING GRAVES
FROM ADVAMED WILL BEGIN WITH-
SHOWED MUHAMMAD YOU EACH HAVE
TWO MINUTES UP TO FOUR MINUTES.
BETWEEN THE TWO OF YOU- SO
PLEASE BEGIN WHEN YOU'RE READY.
THANK YOU JERRY MEMBERS WHICH
WILL MONITOR THE CALIFORNIA
CHAMBER OF COMMERCE WE
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE THIS BILL-
WELL WE APPRECIATE THE
AMENDMENTS PUT FORWARD
YESTERDAY IN THE AUTHOR'S
WILLINGNESS TO HEAR OUR
CONCERNS WE MUST UNFORTUNATELY
OPPOSE THIS BILL AS IT REMAINS.
OVERBROAD WITH UNCLEAR
DEFINITIONS AND DISMISSES THE
CALIFORNIA PRIVACY FRAMEWORK
THAT WAS PASSED BY VOTERS LAST
NOVEMBER IN PREPARATION FOR AN
OLDER STATUTE. THAT IS ILL
EQUIPPED TO DEAL WITH THIS
INFORMATION. ALTHOUGH THE STATE
IS ALREADY GOVERNED BY FIFTY.
AND CPR EIGHTY FOURTEEN THIRTY
SIX TAKE THE DATA OUT OF THE
EXISTING PRIVACY FRAMEWORK AND
PLACES IT IN A WHOLLY DIFFERENT
CODE SECTION THAT WAS NOT
DESIGNED TO HANDLE CONSUMER
DATA PRIVACY. THIS DISRUPTION
TO EXISTING CALIFORNIA LAW IN
THE PRIVACY FRAMEWORK THAT THIS
LEGISLATURE PASSED IN TWENTY
EIGHTEEN AND VOTERS PASSED
AGAIN TWENTY TWENTY OVER
COMPLICATE AN ALREADY COMPLEX
AREA FIRST IMPRESSION. AND
SHE'S NO BENEFICIAL OUTCOME FOR
CONSUMERS G. P. AND G. P. R. A.
OR SO NEW IN FACT THAT MANY OF
THE PROVISIONS OF CPR AND NOT
EVEN TAKEN EFFECT YET. AND THE
DIGITAL HEALTH PRODUCT INDUSTRY
IS STILL IN THE PROCESS OF
INVESTING VERY CONSERVATIVELY
TENS OF MILLIONS OF DOLLARS
INTO BUILDING OUT COMPLEX
COMPLIANCE PROGRAMS WITH
LAWYERS. STAFF AND VARIOUS
INTERNAL BUSINESS PROCESSES
DESIGNED TO RESPOND TO CONSUMER
REQUESTS. UNDER THE NEWLY
ADOPTED CALIFORNIA PRIVACY
RIGHTS ACT OF TWO THOUSAND
TWENTY ACCORDINGLY WE LOCATING
SOME OF THE PROVISIONS OF THIS
BILL DOES. MAKING SWEEPING
CHANGES TO A BRAND NEW PRIVACY
LAW AND DISRUPTING COMPLIANCE
EFFORTS SO SIGNIFICANTLY MAKES
LITTLE SENSE PARTICULARLY WHEN
NOTING THAT CONSUMERS CURRENTLY
ENJOY THE EXACTING RIGHT. UNDER
C. P. AND C. P. R. A. THOSE ARE
THE RIGHT TO OPT OUT OF THE
TAYLOR SHARING OF INFORMATION
AND THE RIGHT TO ACCESS THEIR
INFORMATION. LIKE HAT
CONSUMERS MAY EXERCISE TODAY
UNDER EXISTING LAW TODAY. THE
LAWS UNDER WHICH CONSUMERS CAN
EXERCISE THESE RIGHTS ARE NOT
OLD OR OUTDATED. THEY WERE
PASSED IN TWENTY EIGHTEEN BY
THE LEGISLATURE AND AGAIN
TWENTY TWENTY BY BALLOT
MEASURE. AND A SECURE FOR
CONSUMERS THEACTING
PROTECTIONS THAT THIS BILL
REPLICATE. MINING DIVISIONS
WITH THE OVERALL NATURE OF THE
BILL DROPPING AS NOTING AS
NOTED IN THE ANALYSIS MAKE THIS
BILL DESTRUCTIVE NOT JUST
CONFUSING. FOR EXAMPLE AS NOTED
IN THE ANALYSIS WITH REGARD TO
THE DEFINITION OF PERSONAL
HEALTH RECORD SYSTEM THE
RAMIFICATIONS. OF SUCH A BROAD
DEFINITION ARE STILL ON CLEAR.
THESE ARE JUST SOME OF THE
REASONS MUST FIRST. FOR THIS
BILL THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME.
US THANK VERY MUCH- WELL MOVE
ON TO- FIELDING GRAVES SAID
ADVAMED. YOUR PARTNER WAS RIGHT
ON TIME SO YOU HAVE TWO MINUTES.
THANK YOU AND MISTER CHAIR
FEELING REALLY ADVANCED MEDICAL
TECHNOLOGY ASSOCIATION WE
APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
WORK WITH THE OPPORTUNITY
KNOWLEDGE ABOUT THE STEAK AND-
BASS SAID WE REMAINOPPOSED TO
THE BILL BEFORE YOU TODAY
BECAUSE WE'RE FUNDAMENTALLY
OPPOSED TO MOVING THIS MUCH
INFORMATION OUT OF THE SEAT.
AND THE CONFIDENTIALITY OF
MEDICAL INFORMATION ACT WE JUST
PASSED THE COMPANY PRIVACY
RIGHTS ACT IN THE BAMBERG
REGULATES ALL THIS INFORMATION
CLEARLY. IT'LL HELP TO THE NEW
AND EVOLVING AREA HOLDS
TREMENDOUS PROMISE FOR PATIENTS
CONTROL THEIR HEALTH AND FOR
HEALTHCARE SYSTEMS EIGHT
BILLION. BUT THIS REMAINS A
NAGEL AS INVOLVING CONCEPT OF A
WIDE RANGE OF PRODUCTS DURING
THE BREEZE OF COURSE THIS IS
WHAT WE THINK OF ITS
TRADITIONAL HEALTH CARE AND THE
SENSITIVITY COMES WITH IT.
FITNESS APPS WORKOUT TRACKER
APPS IN THE GYM PERSONAL NOTES
ABOUT AN INJURY A PERSONAL
DIARY THAT INCLUDES FEELINGS
ABOUT DEPRESSION ANXIETY. UNDER
THIS BILL COVERS ALL PERSONAL
INFORMATION RELATED TO A
PHYSICAL OR MENTAL CONDITION
THIS COVERS A VAST ARRAY OF
PRODUCTS AND APPLICATIONS AND
THE POTENTIAL FOR UNINTENDED
CONSEQUENCES HERE IT'S EQUALLY
FAST. IS HE NOW SAYS RAY
RIGHTLY POINTS OUT THE
RAMIFICATIONS OF SUCH A BROAD
DEFINITION ARE UNCLEAR AND WHY
WOULD WE GO IN THIS DIRECTION
CALVARY PRICE RIGHT THAT COVERS
ALL OF THIS IS THAT THE
PERSONAL INFORMATION REQUIRING
AFFIRMATIVE OPT IN FOR NEWS.
AND CREATE A WHOLE NEW SET OF
OBLIGATIONS FINALLY AT THE HHS
FOR STUDYING THESE ISSUES WERE
VERY LIKELY TO PROPOSE NEW
REGULATIONS CORPORATE FIFTY
APPLICATIONS WE OFTEN SAY THAT
C. M. I. A. AS CALIFORNIA'S
FIRST WHAT HAPPENED BUT THE
BILL BEFORE YOU WOULD RECEIVE
BY. FAR BEYOND THE SCOPE OF
HIP- GREAT HARMFUL DIVERGENCE
IN THE SPACE OF A SPINAL
REGULARS. WORKED GREAT PROCRIT
REGULATIONS. HEATING
MISINFORMATION REGULATE BY THE
KELP PRIVACY RIGHTS AT. IN
PARTS INFORMATION AND DOES NOT
MEET MORE. WE URGE YOU TO
WITHHOLD YOUR- TO. AND THANK
YOU. THANKS VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
TIME WILL NOW GO ON TO
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION TO AT FOURTEEN
THIRTY SIX WE GOT A PUBLIC
GALLERY SCENE ON THE PUBLIC
ALLIES MOVED TO ROOM TWENTY
FORTY SEEN ON TWENTY FORTY.
MODERATOR PLEASE OPEN THE LINES
FOR WITNESSES WHO WISH TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION TO AT
FOURTEEN THIRTY SIX NAME
ORGANIZATION POSITION ONLY.
FOUR COMMENTS IN OPPOSITION TO
AT FOURTEEN THIRTY SIX. PLEASE
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO. THAT
COMMAND AGAIN ONE ZERO. LINE
TWO HUNDRED TWELVE YEAR MIKE IS
OPEN. GOOD ATERNOON THIS IS
JUST A MATTER WITH THE SILICON
VALLEY LEADERSHIP GROUP- WE
MUST RESPECTFULLY OPPOSES THE
TIME THANK YOU. THANK YOU NEXT
LINE. LIKE. TWO HUNDRED TWENTY
SIX. Y. TWO HUNDRED TWENTY SIX
YOUR MIKE IS OPEN. BY TWO
HUNDRED ELEVEN. MISTER CHAIRMAN
I THINK ON BEHALF OF THE
NATIONAL PAYROLL REPORTING
CONSORTIUM WERE ALSO OPPOSE FOR
THE REASONS PREVIOUSLY STATED
THANK YOU THANK YOU NEXT TIME.
AND ACTUALLY GO TO LINE UP ONE
HUNDRED FORTY SIX LINE ONE
HUNDRED FORTY SIX YEAR MIKE IS
UP. GOOD AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN
AND MEMBERS- COULD QUICKLY ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA LIFE
SCIENCES. WE ARE OPPOSED TO
THIS MEASURE THANK YOU THANK
YOU NEXT LINE. BETTER CARE WE
HAVE ONE MORE COMMENT COMING
THROUGH ONE MOMENT PLEASE WHILE
WE PROVIDE THEM WITH A LARGE
NUMBER. WHITE TWO HUNDRED
TWENTY SIX- MY COULD OPEN.
PETER PETER MEMBERS CAME TO
MEET HIM IN A PROTECTIVE AND
RESPECTFUL DISCUSSION ABOUT.
THANK YOU NEXT LINE AND IN MY
TWO HUNDRED TWENTY. HI DON
HOFFMAN ON BEHALF OF THE
INTERNET ASSOCIATION
RESPECTIVELY THANK YOU THANK
YOU NEXT TIME. MR KERR THERE
ARE NO FURTHER COMMENT AT THE
TIME RIGHT THANKS VERY MUCH TO
THE SPRING AFFECTED TOO MANY
OTHER QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS. K.
SAYING NINE. SEPARATE CHARGES
AGAINST ONE THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR WORKING OTHER COMMITTEE-
YEAH I. YEAH WE TRY TO DRESS
MADE ISSUES ARE BROUGHT UP BY
THE OPPOSITION- I WOULD MAKE
NOTE JUST TO SIT BACK THAT- I
KNOW YOU'VEBEEN WORKING ON
PRIVACY FOR VERY LONG TIME IT'S
SEEN A LOT OF THE LEGISLATION
THAT YOU'VE CHAMPIONED HERE ON
THE FLOOR. THINGS HAVE ALWAYS
TALKED ABOUT IT WAS THAT HEALTH
INFORMATION WHERE HE HAD A BODY
PRIVACY LAWS LIKE HIPAA AND SEE
MY EIGHT ROUNDS HEALTH.
INFORMATION HOWEVER WHAT WE'RE
SEEING IS MORE MORE HEALTH
INFORMATION IS BEING GATHERED
OUTSIDE SO THE HEALTHCARE
SETTING RIGHT SO NORMALLY WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT THINGS LIKE OKAY
FINE WE'LL HAVE A HOLTER
MONITOR DATA CARDIOLOGISTS
ORDERS THAT'S GOING TO TRACK
YOUR HEART RATE TO SEE WHAT YOU
HAVE TO RID ME OF IT NOW YOU
HAVE AN APPLE WATCH THAT'S
ACTUALLY MONITORING YOUR
RHYTHM. RIGHT SO WITH THAT THAT
THAT THE LANDSCAPE HAS SHIFTED
AND SO I APPRECIATE THE
OPPOSITION SAID WELL YEAH WE
HAVETHESE PRIVACY IT CETERA
FORTY ON THE COMMERCIAL SIDE
BUT WHAT HAPPENS WHEN ON THE
COMMERCIAL SIDE YOU ARE
INTENTIONALLY COLLECTING HEALTH
INFORMATION SO I GET THE IDEA
ABOUT. YOU KNOW WELL YOU HAVE A
WORD PROCESSING PROGRAM YOU'RE
PUTTING IN STUFF ABOUT YOUR
MOOD IS THAT NOW A HEALTH
DEVICE NO BUT YOU DO HAVE
COMMERCIAL DEVICES ARE
INTENTIONALLY- CAPTURING. HOW
IF. VISIT INFORMATION OTHER
TYPES OF THINGS AND- I THINK.
THE PUBLIC'S. UNDERSTANDING
EXPECTATION AT LEAST OUR
GENERAL. SENSE IS THAT WELL
THAT. YOU KNOW WHAT IT IS HOW'S
THAT GOING TO BE USED MOST
PEOPLE BECAUSE OF THE EXISTING
HEALTH LAWS DON'T THINK IT
COULD BE ABUSED. BUT
UNFORTUNATELY- SOMEONE TO HOUSE
IT DOES HEALTH SERVICES
RESEARCH. YOU CAN TAKE THE
PHYSIOLOGICAL DATA AND START.
PULLING ALL SORTS OF
INTERESTING CONCLUSIONS OUT OF
THAT ESPECIALLY BEING
INTEGRATED WITH OTHER OTHER
DATA SETS. I THINK THAT'S THE
IT CERTAINLY FOR ME THAT ONE OF
THE ISSUES THAT'S REALLY
IMPORTANT. I THINK THAT WE NEED
TO BE CAREFUL THAT. COMMERCIAL
COLLECTION OF HEALTH
INFORMATION IS NOT ABUSED IN A
WAY THAT. ARE NOT USED IN WAYS
THAT THE PUBLIC DOESN'T EXPECT
IT TO BE USED RIGHT. BECAUSE
THEY MAY NOT BE AWARE OF HOW
MIGHT BE USED. INAPPROPRIATELY
AND WE NEED TO PUT THOSE
PROTECTIONS IN PLACE SO THAT
WHEN PEOPLE ARE ASKED ABOUT
WHETHER THEY WANT TO OPT IN OR
OPT OUT OR WHATEVER ELSE. THEY
KNOW WHAT THE IMPLICATIONS OF
THAT ARE SO- APPRECIATE YOU
WORKING WITH THE COMMITTEE- YOU
KNOW IT'S A COMPLICATED AREA SO
I DON'T KNOW WE GOT ENTIRELY
RIGHT. BUT I THINK WE TRY TO
MAKE THE RIGHT STRIDES WE
DIDN'T WANT TO MAKE THESE
DEVICES HEALTHCARE PROVIDERS
BECAUSE- YOU KNOW WE DIDN'T
EXACTLY HAVE TO STORE FOREVER
SOME OTHER ISSUES BUT WE ALSO
WANT TO FIND A PLACE WHERE. WE
COULD WORK ON. THIS PRIVACY
ISSUES THAT SPACE FOR DATE FIT.
MORE APPROPRIATELY. TO BE SURE
THAT THE INFORMATION WAS AN
ABUSE AGAIN REALLY APPRECIATE
YOU WORKING ON THIS ISSUE- WITH
THIS BILL WORKING WITH THE
COMMITTEE AND ALSO YOUR
LEADERSHIP IN THE AREA. AND
WITH THAT WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MISTER CHAIR I THINK THAT'S A
GREAT CLOSE- THAT'S WHEN I
THANK YOU FOR YOUR COMMENTS
AND- THANK YOU FOR YOUR CALL
SO. YOU KNOW WORKING WITH US
AND- HOW YOU GOT I EXACTLY
RIGHT I THINK TO YOU KNOW THE
INTENT OF THE BILL IS NOT TO
CAPTURE EVERY SINGLE DEVICE OR
APPLICATION UNDER THE SUN. I
THINK YOU KNOW THERE ARE VERY
UNIQUE SITUATIONS THAT WE WANT
TO CAPTURE. SO YOU KNOW WE ARE
TALKING ABOUT HEALTH
INFORMATION YOU KNOW. WE'RE NOT
TRYING TO CAPTURE THINGS LIKE A
LAPTOP OR- OR LET'S SAY- DID
YOU KNOW WHAT A SCALE FOR
EXAMPLE. IN WHICH IS THE REASON
WHY WE TOOK HIM IN A WE DID.
AND- YOU KNOW STICK. CAN TO
GROW I THINK WE NEED TO BE.
VIGILANT I THINK WE NEED TO.
TRY TO KEEP PACE AND ALSO. I
TRY TO- PROTECTED HEALTH
INFORMATION SO IF THIS IS A
VERY MODEST ATTEMPT- TO DOING
THAT SO WITHOUT I RESPECTFULLY
ASK RIVAL. THANK YOU. OKAY
THANK YOU. IS THERE A MOTION ON
THIS BILL AND IT'S BEEN MOVED
BY SENATOR LEYVA. MY SHEET
HERE. OKAY LET'S MOVE RIGHT
THERE LIVE IN THE BUSHES DO
PASSES AMENDED THE FIRST
AMENDED REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
CONSULT PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
PAN HI CAN I AM MELINDA'S.
MELINDA'S NO EGGMAN. EGGMAN
ITEMS SOLACE. GONZALEZ I'D GROW
HER TADO HI HER TOTAL I. LEIVA
HI LEAVE A HIGHLY MON HI THE
MON HI ROSS. RUBIO WINNER
WINNER HI. SEVERAL SEVEN ONE TO
THE BILL ON CALL THANK YOU VERY
MUCH SENATOR RIGHT THANK YOU
ALRIGHT LET'S NOW MOVE ON TO
ITEM NUMBER TWELVE EIGHTY
FIFTEEN FORTY TWO BY SEVER
MCCARTY AND- LET'S GIVE OR TAKE
A MOMENT HERE TO TIDY UP THE
PODIUM FIRST. OKAY WELCOME
PLEASE BEGIN THANK YOU I THINK
IN THE LAST BILL SO THANK YOU
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO COME
HERE THIS AFTERNOON TO PRESENT-
THIS IS A DISTRICT BILL- IT'S A
PILOT PROJECT IN ONE COUNTY ONE
**** COUNTY ALTHOUGH ONE COUNTY
ONLY YOLO COUNTY. WHICH IS THE-
SMALLER PIECE OF MY DISTRICT OF
COURSE CITY OF WESTPAC AND
DAVIS AND WHAT WHAT ARE THE
MAJOR CITIES THERE- THIS WOULD
OFFER THIS COUNTY AN
OPPORTUNITY TO CREATE AN
ALTERNATIVE. SENSUALLY
SENTENCING- PROGRAM FOR
INDIVIDUALS WITH DRUG ADDICTION
SO AND SO AS OPPOSED TO BEING
HOUSED FOR A LONG SENTENE IN
COUNTY JAIL OR STATE PRISON
INDIVIDUALS CAN GO AND WORK ON-
GETTING- NEEDED DRUG TREATMENT
HOPEFULLY I RETURNED BACK TO
SOCIETY WHEN THEIR SENTENCES
OVER AND HAVE THEIR RECORDS
EXPUNGED AND BECOME. A MEMBERS
OF THE COMMUNITY WITHOUT THE
DRUG ADDICTION BECAUSE WE KNOW
THE CURRENT SYSTEM IS NOT
WORKING. OUT OF THE GATE I DO
WANNA THANK YOU AND CAN YOUR
COMMITTEE FOR WORKING WITH US
AND WE WILL BE ACCEPTING. THE
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS I WILL
NOTE THAT SINCE JANUARY WE'VE
BEEN WORKING WITH THE
OPPOSITION AND ACCEPTED OVER
TWENTY AMENDMENTS. TO THIS BILL
TO CLARIFY WHAT THIS ISSUE IS
ALL ABOUT HI THIS IS A AGAIN AS
A PILOT IN BEEN IN OUR
COMMUNITY HERE IN YOLO COUNTY.
THIS IS 100% VOLUNTARY AND IT'S
NOT ABOUT CRIMINALIZING OVER
YOU KNOW WHICH IS A BRAIN
DISEASE OF ADDICTION. THERE ARE
TOO MANY PEOPLE GOING IN AND
OUT OF OUR CRIMINAL JUSTICE
SYSTEM THAT NEVER GET PROPER
TREATMENT- THIS PILOT PROP
PROGRAMS ABOUT PROVIDING AN
OPTION FOR THOSE SUFFERING FOM
SUBSTANCE. ABUSE DISORDER- THIS
BILL IS SOMETHING THAT- WEEK
CERTAINLYCAN CAN TEST OUT HERE
IN IN OUR OUR COMMUNITY IN YOLO
COUNTY WHICH ENDO CENTER YOU
AND I BOTH REPRESENTS- THIS
PROVIDES AGAIN A VOLUNTARY
OPTION FOR PEOPLE WHO HAVE BEEN
SENTENCED TO JAIL OR PRISON. TO
SEEK TREATMENT IN LIEU OF
INCARCERATION THESE ARE NOT
INDIVIDUALS THAT WOULD BE
OPPORTUNITIES TO GO HOME LET'S
SAY SERVED WITH AND GET AN
ANKLE BRACE AND A PROBATION
THESE ARE PEOPLE THAT OTHERWISE
WOULD BE GETTING. A JAIL
SENTENCE- THIS WOULD BE EITHER
BE ACCESSED BY. MEDICAL
PROVIDERS- PROFESSIONALS NOT BY
ADA OR A JUDGE TO FOCUS ON WHO
IS RIGHT FOR THIS PROGRAM. AND
IF THEY CHOOSE. AT ANY POINT
THEY DON'T WANT TO PARTICIPATE
IN THIS THAT IN GO BACK TO THE
RICH SENTENCE AND GO BACK TO
CENTRALLY. INCARCERATION ONCE
TREATMENTS COMPLETED THE
INDIVIDUAL THE OPPORTUNITY TO
EXPUNGE. THE FELONY RECORD OF
ALL UNDERLYING ARRESTS RELATED.
TO THESE- ADDICTION RELATED
CRIMES. WE MUST COME TOGETHER
WITH NEW SOLUTIONS BECAUSE WE
KNOW THE CURRENT SYSTEM IS NOT
WORKING- THIS PILOT WILL ALLOW
US TO TEND TO DO SO RIGHT HERE.
IN OUR COMMUNITY I LOOK FORWARD
TO THAT TO THE QUESTIONS AND
DIALOGUE HERE TODAY. WITH ME
HERE TO TESTIFY. IS THE DA OF
YOLO COUNTY JEFF REISIG. AS
WELL AS A COMMUNITY. LEADER
FOCUSING ON THEIR PERSPECTIVE
THANK YOU MR CHECK THANK YOU-
SOME RECORDING AGAIN THANK YOU
FOR SO MUCH WORKING WITH MY
COMMITTEE AND TAKING THE
AMENDMENTS. ALL RIGHT WE'RE
GOING TO NOW MOVE ON TO.
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT AND EIGHTY
FIFTEEN FORTY TWO- MODERATOR
PLEASE BRING OUT A LINER TO
LEAD WITNESSES AND TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT- JEFF REISIG YOLO
COUNTY DISTRICT ATTORNEY AND
ANTHONY BROWN. A REGISTERED
NURSE BEGIN WITH THE- DISTRICT
ATTORNEY R. RICE SICK- YOU
HAVE. TWO MINUTES EACH AND A
TOTAL FOUR MINUTES BETWEEN THE
TWO OF YOU SO- GIVE A TWO
MINUTE WARNING. WHEN YOU HAVE
TWO MINUTES PLEASE BEGIN. THANK
YOU A GOOD AFTERNOON THIS IS
THIS RETURNING JEFF REISIG OF
YOLO COUNTY. TOO MANY PEOPLE
WHO SUFFER FROM SERIOUS
SUBSTANCE ABUSE DISORDERS ARE
GOING TO PRISONS AND JAILS FOR
CRIMES THAT ARE MOTIVATED BY
THEIR ADDICTION. PRISONS AND
JAILS ARE SIMPLY NOT PLACES
WHERE SICK PEOPLE GO TO GET
BETTER. WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO DO
HERE IS STOP THE REVOLVING DOOR.
ABC FIFTEEN FORTY TWO PROPOSES
A LOCAL TREATMENT ALTERNATIVES
TO PRISON IN JAIL FOR THOSE
PEOPLE WHO HAVE BEEN CONVICTED
OF FELONY LEVEL CRIMES
MOTIVATED BY THEIR SERIOUS
ADDICTION TO DRUGS. BUT WE
SIMPLY POSE TOO MUCH OF A RISK
FOR A JUDGE TO RELEASE THEM
INTO AN UNSECURED RESIDENTIAL
FACILITY IN THE COMMUNITY.
WHERE THEY COULD SIMPLY WALK
AWAY OR CRAWL OUT A WINDOW ON
DAY ONE. AND POTENTIALLY CAUSE
MORE HARM TO THEMSELVES AND
OTHERS. INSTEAD AB FIFTEEN
FORTY TWO ENVISIONS CREATING A
SECURE. HOSPITAL LIKE TREATMENT
ENVIRONMENT WITHOUT JAIL BARS
AND GUARDS AND GUNS. THAT CAN
SERVE AS A SANCTUARY FOR
SERIOUSLY AND YOU CAN FELONY
OFFENDERS WHO VOLUNTARILY
CHOOSE TO TRY LOCAL COMMUNITY
BASED TREATMENT. AND WRAPAROUND
SERVICES IN A SAFE AND SECURE
SETTING INSTEAD OF MERELY BEING
WAREHOUSE BEHIND BARS IN
PRISON. WE CALL THIS POTENTIAL
PLACE HOPE YELLOW. I WOULD ALSO
MAKES THIS TREATMENT
ALTERNATIVE YOU NEED. IS IT AT
ALL IT WILL BE DESIGNED AND
STAFFED BY TREATMENT PROVIDERS
AND THEY WILL DECIDE WHO IS AN
APPROPRIATE CANDIDATE. AND WHO
IS NOT AND WHAT THE TREATMENT
SHOULD LOOK LIKE. FOR THOSE WHO
DO SUCCESSFULLY CHOOSE AND
COMPLETE TREATMENT OVER PRISON
THEY WILL HAVE THEIR
CONVICTIONS EXPUNGED. AND GET A
CLEAN STORE RIGHT HERE AT HOME
IN YOUR LITTLE COUNTY.
ULTIMATELY AB FIFTEEN FORTY TWO
IS A VERY MEASURED PILOT BILL.
THAT IS DESIGNED TO OFFER A
VOLUNTARY TREATMENT ALTERNATIVE
TO THOSE WHO ARE OTHERWISE ON
THEIR WAY TO PRISON OR JAIL. I
WOULD URGE THIS COMMITTEE TO
GIVE THIS PILOT A CHANCE THANK
YOU. THANK YOU NOW LET'S BRING
ON ANTHONY BROWN REGISTERED
NURSE AND YOU HAVE EXACTLY HE
ENDED RIGHT ON TIME SO YOU HAVE
TWO MINUTES. HI THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE HI MY NAME IS ANTHONY
BROWN. IT CURRENTLY A LICENSE
AS A PSYCHIATRIC PATIENT A
REGISTERED NURSE A PUBLIC
HEALTH NURSE OR CERTIFIED
ADDICTION TREATMENT COUNSELOR
THIRD LEVEL NURSE. AND ANOTHER
SCHOOL RIGHT NOW TO COME A
FAMILY NURSE PRACTITIONER- MY
EDUCATION BACKGROUND IS
ABSOLUTELY PART OF THE GREEN
EVERYTHING. APART FROM TWENTY
THREE. I CURRENTLY EMPLOYED AS
A DEALER MARK AT A SITE
HOSPITAL DOWN HERE IN SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA AS WELL AS A FULL
TIME PROFESSOR. AND A HOUSE FOR
HIS APPOINTMENT OUT OF THE
COLLEGE. I SHARE THIS WITH
INDIVIDUAL BECAUSE MY LIFE
WASN'T ALWAYS LIKE THIS- PRIOR
TO. THAT TWO THOUSAND ONE I
SPENT A TOTAL OF NINE AND A
HALF YEARS IN AND OUT OF JAIL
FOR PRESIDENT. I HAVE BEEN TO
PLACES LIKE RECRUIT- J. DONOVAN
CORRECTIONAL FACILITY
CHUCKWALLA VALLEY. STATE PRISON
I DON'T THINK PRESIDENT TRUMP
ARTISTIC PRESENT. CALIFORNIA TO
CONFIRM THAT ACCOUNT NOW
CALIFORNIA MEN'S COLONY. I
DIDN'T THINK CARBURETED BECAUSE
OF MY SUBSTANCE USE AND I'VE
BEEN IN AND OUT OF THE
PRESIDENT'S BOARD. OF SOMETIMES.
DIFFERENT THE PROGRAM SOME KIND.
I'M HERE TO SERVE THIS IS THE-
BECAUSE I BELIEVE THAT IF I TO
GET PRINT ONE OF LEVEL WHICH
EIGHTY FIFTY COULD ALL. BEING
CRITICAL TO THEIR PLAN. ANOTHER
PART OF THE STORE THAT I REALLY
WANT TO ENCOURAGE THAT A LOT OF
PEOPLE DON'T SEE IS THE
RAMIFICATIONS OF MY FUTURE
BECAUSE OF MY SUBSTANCE HERE.
ALL MY EDUCATIONAL BACKGROUND
IN SCHOOL I HAD TO GO THROUGH A
LOT OF DIFFERENT- COURT CASES
IN THE HEARING BECAUSE OF MY
FELONY. WHAT THIS BILL A BILL
WILL COME UP WITH A FREE CALLS.
BE ABLE TO GET THAT EXPUNGED
BUT IT DON'T THEY DON'T HAVE TO
GO TO A LOT OF COMPLICATIONS
AND TIMELY REPORT THAT ACTED
LIKE THE COMPLAINTS TODAY. SO I
WANT TO DEAL WITH IT AND HOPE
THAT YOU'RE ABLE TO CONQUER
FILLED BUT THE OTHER DIFFICULT
BECAUSE IT BECOME. INDIVIDUALS
LIKE ME TO PROVIDE A SEPARATE
STATE COMMUNITY. THANK YOU FOR
ALLOWING ME TO PROTECT MYSELF.
THANKS MUCH WELL NOW MOVE ON TO
THIS WITNESSES AS A FOUR OF A
FIFTEEN. TWO WILL BE IN THE
PUBLIC GALLERY SCENE ON THE
MICROPHONE THE THOUGHT THE GUY
WAS MOVED TO ROOM TWENTY FORTY
SINGH ON TWENTY FORTY.
MODERATOR PLEASE BRING ON THE
LINE WITNESSES WHO WISH TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF EIGHTY
FIFTEEN FORTY TWO NAME
ORGANIZATION POSITION ONLY.
FOUR COMMENTS IN SUPPORT OF
EIGHTY FIFTEEN FORTY TWO PLEASE
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO. HAT
COMMAND AGAIN. ONE ZERO. CAN WE
DO HAVE A COMMENT COMING
THROUGH ONE MOMENT PLEASE WHILE
WE PROVIDE THEM WITH THEIR LINE
FOR. GOING TO BE ONE MORE
MOMENT PLEASE. AND THE LINE TWO
HUNDRED THIRTY SIX PLEASE GO
AHEAD. ONE HUNDRED THIRTY SIX
PLEASE GO AHEAD. BY TWO HUNDRED
THIRTY FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
DON COOPER WITH NIELSEN WORKED
ON BEHALF OF YELLOW COUNTY WE
SUPPORT IN PRINCIPLE AND AB
FIFTEEN FORTY TWO THANK YOU.
THANK YOU NEXT LINE. MISTER
CHAIR THERE ARE NO FURTHER
COMMENT AT THE TIME. YOU WILL
NOW LET'S MOVE ON TO THE
OPPOSITION. TWO EIGHTY FIFTEEN
FORTY TWO WE'LL BEGIN BY WRITER
PLEASE BRING US A LINER TO LEAD
WITNESSES TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION. TO EIGHTY FIFTEEN
FORTY TWO. IT CUT EISEN- FROM
HEALTH RIGHT THREE SIXTY AND
TYLER REN DAY FROM THE CAL THE
CALIFORNIA PEOPLE HEALTH
DIRECTORS. YOU EACH HAVE TWO
MINUTES A TOTAL FOUR MINUTES
TOGETHER- SO BEGIN WITH THAT
CUT AISIN- PLEASE BEGIN WHEN
YOU'RE READY. I THINK I'M THE
CEO OF HELP FOR THREE SIXTY.
FIFTY NET CURTAINS USED TO SORT
OF TRICKLE PROVIDER IN
CALIFORNIA NOT TO REPRESENTING
BOTH K. P. AND G. B. HA THE
STATEWIDE ASSOCIATION THE BOOKS
NEXT. TO MENTAL HEALTH
TREATMENT PROVIDERS
RESPECTIVELY. IN AN ERA WHERE
WE ARE LOOKING FORWARD TOWARDS
MORE EVIDENCE BASED CARE FOR
PEOPLE WITH SUBSTANCE USE
DISORDER WELL AT THE SAME TIME
QUESTIONING THE WAR ON DRUGS.
AND THE NEGATIVE IMPACTS OF
PATENTS KNEW THE COLOR. THEY'LL
SIMPLY MOVED IN THE WRONG
DIRECTION ON BOTH COUNTS. BILL
GORDON YOU CAN FINANCE BETWEEN
THE RAINDROPS REFERRING TO THE
PROGRAM AS COLD VOLUNTARY. WELL
AT THE SAME TIME DESCRIBING A
PROGRAM THAT IS LOCKED. IN AN
INDIVIDUAL HEALTHCARE UNDER A
JUDGE'S ORDER THE ALTERNATIVE
BEING TO BE SENT TO A DIFFERENT
LOTS OF SILLY IT WILL BE IN
JAIL. IT SHOULD BE NOTED THE
YELLOW COUNTY JAIL ALREADY HAS.
AN INTENSITY SUBSTANCE USE
TREATMENT PROGRAM AS WELL AS
THE DRUG COURT PROGRAM BEGGING
THE QUESTION WHY DID YOU LOOK
AT HOW HE NEEDS NEW PROGRAM.
AND WANTED TO GIVE THE
LEGISLATURE'S. APPROVAL IF IT
ALREADY HAS TWO DIFFERENT.
CREAMY PROGRAMS MY- BY THE-
JUSTICE SYSTEM. NOT TO MENTION
A COMMUNITY. TREE SYSTEM NUMBER
HERE IN THE MEDICARE CONNECTED
BENEFITS. PART OF THE BILL
IMPLIES MEDICAL COULD SERVE AS
A KEY SOURCE OF THE PROPOSED
SECURE PROGRAM. BASED ON
EVERYTHING WE KNOW ABOUT MAKING
RULES. WE BELIEVE THAT THIS IS
NOT TRUE BECAUSE THE PROGRAM
PARTICIPANTS DO NOT HAVE
FREEDOM OF MOVEMENT A CORE
REQUIREMENT FOR YOU COULD NOT
COUNT AS A TASTE OR- MORE WE
KNOW THAT THERE IS NO CURRENT
LICENSING STANDARDS UNDER THE
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTHCARE
SERVICES WE SECURED RESIDENTIAL
TREATMENT PROGRAM. WHICH WOULD
ALSO PROHIBIT IT FROM DRYING
DOWN. MEDICARE WITH THE PACE OR
SO WHO PAYS FOR A LOCK PROGRAM
THE JAIL BY ANY OTHER NAME IF
NOT MEDI CAL. IT'LL
CONTEMPLATES THE FUTURE USE OF
THE MULTISTATE. OPIOID
SETTLEMENT FUND. ONCE AGAIN THE
SCORESOF OPPONENTS OF THIS
BILL BELIEVED THAT HE COULD
NOT. IN KEEPING WITH THE
PRINCIPLES OF EVIDENCE EQUITY.
DEVELOPED BY A BROAD SET OF
NATIONAL EXPERTISE THAT KEPT
THE COLDEST IT WOULD BE A
PAINFUL IRONY. THAT WHILE THE
TARGETS OF DEATH HOPE YOU LIKE
LOOK WHAT PEOPLE LOOK FOR YOU
THE OUTCOME. OF THAT CASE
RESULTS IN LOCKING UP MORE OF
THEIR VICTIMS. THE DRUG
OVERDOSE CRISIS IS URGENT WE
UNDERSTAND THE- DESIRE TO
EXPAND CARE TO MEET THE MOMENT
TWO MINUTE IS. NOT DO THAT. IN
AN EQUITABLE WAY PLEASE VOTE NO
THANK YOU. THANK YOU THE WELL
THIS ONTO. AND GOOD LUCK CHAIR
MEMBERS THE WITH THE COW HERE
FOR DRIVE TO THIRSTY
RESPECTFULLY WE ARE OPPOSITION
AT FIFTEEN FORTY TWO WHICH
CREATE AT YOUR RESIDENTIAL
TREATMENT PILOT PROGRAM IN ALL
ACCOUNTING FOR INDIVIDUALS
CONVICTED OF A DRUG MOTIVATED
CRIME WHILE WE RESPECT THE
AUTHOR IN ATTEMPTING TO FINDA
SOLUTION TO THE INDIVIDUALS
WERE HAPPY TO GET THE TRAFFIC
THAT. WE FUNDAMENTALLY DISAGREE
WITH MOCK TREATMENT THAT DOES
NOT MEET THE AMERICAN SOCIETY
OF ADDICTION MEDICINE STANDARD
EFFECTIVE CARE ALL MAJOR AT THE
TREATMENT ADVOCACY
ORGANIZATIONS OPPOSED THE BAIL
EVEN ADVOCATES THE NON GET OUT
REACH FROM THE AUTHORS I'M
SURPRISED ABOUT TRANSACTION NOT
ONLY SPOKEN ON MONDAY BASED ON
OUR OWN OUT REACH AT THE COURT
D. B. FIFTEEN FORTY TWO WILL
COERCE INDIVIDUALS CONVICTED OF
DRUG MOTIVATED CRIME. DOCTORS
MEN WHICH IS NOT EVIDENCE BASED
AND MAY ACTUALLY BE HARMFUL TO
THE INDIVIDUAL RESEARCH SHOWS
THAT LOCKED AT THE TREATMENT
PROGRAM DID NOT MEET CLINICAL
OUTCOMES AND DO NOT EFFECTIVELY
REDUCE YOUR- INDIVIDUALS WITH
THAT DO YOU HAVE A RANGE OF
NEEDS ABOUT UPON ANYTHING ON
THAT BACK NINE THEY'LL BE
PLACED IN THE DIFFERENT LEVELS
OF CARE. WHAT HAPPENS UNDER THE
BAIL ONE INDIVIDUAL WITH THAT
FACT TO BE CLINICALLY
APPROPRIATE FOR OUTPATIENT CARE
THE BILL DID NOT ENSURE THAT
TREATMENT PROFESSIONALS ARE
DETERMINING CLINICAL CARE HE
JUDGE MAKES THE DECISION AND
HAVE THE ABILITY TO OVERRIDE
CHRONICLE DETERMINATION. THE
BILL PAID LIP SERVICE YOU EIGHT
SALMON PIGEONHOLED INDIVIDUALS
INTERACTING THE LEVEL OF
SERVICE THAT MIGHT BE BLOCKED
FOR PARTICIPANTS READY TO STEP
DOWN AFTER A SHORT TIME FRAME
AND RESIDENTIAL CARE THE BILL
REQUIRED PRODUCT APPROVAL AND
THE FACT BEGIN COURT ORDER ANY
DELAY AND- STEPPING DOWN
INDIVIDUALS AT THE RIGHT TIME
CAN NEGATIVELY IMPACT THEIR
PROGRESS. ADDITIONALLY THERE IS
OVER THREE BILLION DOLLARS IN
NEW FUNDING COMING FOR BEHAVIOR
HEALTH INFRASTRUCTURE WORKFORCE
HOUSING AND EXPANSION OF
TREATMENT THE BUDGET AND
FEDERAL KOBE TO REPEAT WE
SHOULD SEE THE IMPACT OF THOSE
INVESTMENTS BEFORE ADVANCING
ITSELF WOULD BE HAPPY TO CUT
DOWN ON THE AUTHOR AND SPONSOR
IN A BROADER CONVERSATION BUT
NOT SUPPOSED TO BE FIFTEEN
FORTY TWO AND REQUEST YOUR NO
VOTE AT THIS TIME. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU HELLO MOVE ONTO
ADDITION WHAT THIS IS ENOUGH.
TO EIGHTY FIFTEEN TWO PUBLIC
GALLERIES ON PUBLIC. RE THROUGH
TWENTY FOUR SEEN ON TWENTY FOUR
MODERN PLEASE THE LINE FOR WITH.
WHO WHICH TESTIFY OUR- TO A
FIFTEEN FOR TWO. MAY OR EXIT
VISIT ONLY. FOUR COMMENT ENOUGH.
TO A FIFTEEN TWO PLEASE PRESS
ONE AT THAT ZERO. THAT COMMAND
AGAIN ONE ZERO. LINE TWO
HUNDRED SIX YOU'RE MY KID UP.
HIS LANGUAGE WHEN YOU COUNSEL
IF YOU NEED ANY BEHAVIOR HEALTH
AGENCIES AND THEY STOP
OPPOSITION OF EIGHTY FIFTEEN
FORTY TWO THANK YOU. ONE TWO
HUNDRED TWENTY TWO. THIS IS A
TRANSCRIPT HERECONFIDENTLY
ALONG WITH SOME ORIGINAL SCREEN
THEM ALL FROM A POSITION ALSO
REGISTERING PROJECT AMIGO AND
FROM GOING TO GLORY OPPORTUNITY
FOUNDATION A STRONG OPPOSITION
THANK YOU. BY. TWO HUNDRED
THIRTY FOUR. LINE TWO HUNDRED
THIRTY FOUR YEAR MIKE IS OPEN.
RIGHT ON ON BEHALF OF THE SAN
FRANCISCO PUBLIC DEFENDER IN
OPPOSITION THANK YOU NEXT LINE.
LINE TWO HUNDRED THIRTY EIGHT.
NAOMI ROMERO WITH THE
CALIFORNIA BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
PLANNING COUNCIL AND STRONG
OPPOSITION AT EIGHTEEN FIFTEEN
FORTY TWO. THANK YOU NEXT LINE.
LINE. TWO HUNDRED NINE. ROBERT
TERRORISTS ON THE APP
CALIFORNIA'S EIGHTY SIX
ENVELOPES AND THE POSITION
SPECIALIST IN THE TREATMENT OF
ELECTIONS IN WHICH A MORE
EXISTING POSITION. ONLY SO IF
HE'S IN YOUR POST. THANK YOU.
FIND LINE. TWO HUNDRED THIRTY
SIX. HELLO THIS IS JOHN RIFLING
WITH HUMAN RIGHTS WATCH OPPOSE
THE BILL THANK YOU NEXT LINE.
LINE ONE HUNDRED THIRTY ONE.
GOOD AFTERNOON JENNIFER POTTS
WITH THE NATIONAL ASSOCIATION
OF SOCIAL WORKERS CALIFORNIA
CHAPTER IN OPPOSITION THANK YOU
THANK YOU NEXT LINE. ONE TWO
HUNDRED THIRTY ONE. GOOD
AFTERNOON THIS IS MARCO GEORGE
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
PUBLIC DEFENDERS ASSOCIATION
AND RESPECTFUL OPPOSITION THANK
YOU THANK YOU NEXT LINE. A LINE
OF. ONE HUNDRED FIFTY. YEAH
CONSULTANT DISABILITY RIGHTS
CALIFORNIA AND ARE IN RESPONSE
TO OPPOSITION. THANK YOU NEXT
TIME. A LINE OF ONE HUNDRED
NINETY SEVEN. A LARGE BALL TO
TRIPLE IN THE DEFAULT COULD
COME IN BECAUSE ORIGINALLY
POSTED. FIFTEEN FORTY TWO THANK
YOU THANKS LINE. THE. ONE TWO
HUNDRED TWENTY SEVEN. HI JOSH
YOU TODAY ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ATTORNEYS FOR
CRIMINAL JUSTICE AND STRONG
OPPOSITION OF AB FIFTEEN FORTY
TWO THANK YOU NEXT LINE. LINE
TWO HUNDRED EIGHTEEN. HI
AMBROSE BROKE ON BEHALF OF
DIGNITY AND POWER NOW IN STRONG
OPPOSITION TO EIGHTY FIFTEEN
FORTY TWO THANK YOU NEXT LINE.
ONE TWO HUNDRED THIRTY SEVEN. I
WOULD CROP UP ON THE HALF THE
TRANSITION CLINIC NETWORK IN
STRONG OPPOSITION THANK YOU
EXLINE. FIVE TWO HUNDRED THIRTY
NINE. HI THIS IS GEORGE
VALENTINE WITH ELLA BAKER
CENTER FOR HUMAN RIGHTS AND
STRONG OPPOSITION THANK YOU
NEXT LINE. LINE. TWO HUNDRED
TWENTY FOUR. WHITEWATER TWENTY
FOUR YOU'RE MY COULD OPEN. LINE.
TWO HUNDRED THIRTEEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY
NAME IS MERRY GARCIA ON BEHALF
OF DRUG POLICY ALLIANCE IN
STRONG OPPOSITION TO EIGHT P.
FORTY FIFTEEN FORTY TWO THANK
YOU. NEXT TIME. MISTER CHAIR
THERE ARE NO FURTHER COMMENT AT
THE TIME. THANK YOU SO MUCH-MODERATOR FOR LET'S BRING IT
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS FROM COMMITTEE
MEMBERS. MR RUBIO. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR- NO I HAD A
DISCUSSION WITHOUT THE AUTHOR'S
WALLACE HAD THE CAR OUT THERE
AND YOU KNOW RIGHT NOW WHAT I
WAS TRYING TO SEE HERE IS- I
GUESS A LIST OF LATE OPPOSITION
THEY CAME AND SO WE DON'T HAVE
A CHANCE TO REALLY DISCUSS THIS
ISSUE FURTHER WITH THOSE THAT
OPPOSE AND- YOU KNOW I HAVE TO
TAKE NOTE. AND NOW THE
OPPOSITION RATE THEY RANGE FROM
THE SPACE OF BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
TO SOCIAL WORKERS HUMAN RIGHTS
ADVOCATES TOO YOU KNOW PUBLIC
DEFENDERS AND SO CLEARLY
THERE'S I THINK OPPORTUNITY
HERE TO SIT DOWN WITH THIS
GROUP OF OPPOSITION AND BRADY
TRY TO GET IT RIGHT AND I KNOW
THAT IT'S A PILOT PROGRAM
PROGRAM THAT'S VERY SPECIFIC TO
THE DISTRICT BY THAT- I THINK A
ONE AT THE CALLER SAID A BASS
YOU KNOW. I THINK IT DOES
REQUIRE A SIT DOWN WITH A MUCH
BROADER COALITION TO SEE IF WE
CAN REALLY WORK THROUGH SOME OF
THE ISSUES- I'M GONNA BE
SUPPORTIVE TODAY AS I HAD
ALREADY TOLD ME THE AUTHOR BUT
I DO WANT TO NOTE THAT THIS
STATE OPPOSITION REALLY GIVES
ME PAUSE AND I REALLY WANT TO
ENCOURAGE THE OPTED TO CONTINUE
TO SIT DOWN AND HAVE THESE
DISCUSSIONS. ARE THINKING
WITHOUT A MOVE THE BILL. OKAY
THANK YOU. OTHER QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS. REMEMBERS YES AND
AGAIN THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR-
WELL HE CERTAINLY HAVE A BUNCH
OF OPPOSITION SELLING THEIR
MCCARTY- I WILL SAY THAT- THAT
I AM SUPPORTIVE OF YOUR BILL IS
ONE PILOT PROGRAM I THINK.
CLOSING OFF OR MAYBE I'LL MAKE
A BAD PUN SAY LOCKING THE DOOR
ON- ONE FORM OF TREATMENT DOES
NOT GIVE IT A TRY DOESN'T FEEL
SHORT SIGHTED- SO- BUT I'D LIKE
YOU TO TALK TO ME A LITTLE BIT
ABOUT THE ABOUT THE FUNDING I
KNOW IT'S A PILOT. AND I HER
THIRD SOME AND I'M SORRY I
DIDN'T I WAS ABLE TO SEE THAT
IN THE ANALYSIS BUT WHERE
WHERE'S THE FUNDING COMING FROM
IS IT WELL THE COUNTY JUST
PROVIDED FOR THE FUND THE
OPIOID FIND THAT PEOPLE ARE
TALKING ABOUT THAT COULD BE
POTENTIALLY USED FOR THAT IS
THAT THE ONLY FUNDING SOURCE.
SURE THAT THERE'S NO STATE
FUNDING IN THIS THIS AGAIN AS A
PILOT- WE CLARIFIED IN THAT
FIRST HEALTH COMMITTEE THAT IT
WOULD NOT BE ON MEDICARE ALL
ELIGIBLE FOR REIMBURSEMENT SUCH
A 200% UP TO THE COUNTY BOARD
OF SUPERVISORS WHO HAVE
EMBRACES THEY'VE ENDORSED IT'S
ONE OF THEIR AGENDA ITEMS FOR
THIS YEAR. AND THEY'RE LOOKING
AT DIFFERENT COUNTY PARTS OF
RESOURCES INCLUDING THEIR
COUNTY GENERAL FUND INCLUDING
POTENTIAL ONE TIME MONEY LIKE
THEIR COUNTY ALLOCATION FOR
THIS OPIOID SETTLEMENT THAT'S A
PIECE BUT- THE TOURNEY I MEAN
SORRY THE DISTRICT ATTORNEY
TALKED ABOUT POTENTIALLY
GETTING A PHILANTHROPY AND
OTHERS TO LOOK AT IT BUT- ISN'T
IT IT'S NOT AT ALL THROUGH THE
STATE THAT WERE CERTAINLY WORK
WORK WE ARE AUTHORIZING THIS TO
HAPPEN IN STATE LAW THE
SENTENCING. STRUCTURE TO WORK
AND IT'S UP TO THEM TO FIND IT
OKAY ANNA AND JUST ONE FINAL
MORE OF A COMMON I GUESS I'M
SURE THERE'S A FINE STUDENT
THAT SEX DEDERT UC DAVIS-
PERHAPS. WHO COULD DO SOME. TO
DO SOME EVALUATE OF THIS THINK
IT'S GOING BE THAT'S ONE OF THE
THINGS THERE'S NOT A LOT
EVIDENCE. DEVICE OF THE
EFFECTIVENESS OF A LOCKED
FACILITY- SO I THINK IF WE'RE
GONNA GET A PILOT THAT SHOULD
BE GOOD TO. TO START GATHERING
THAT INITIAL DATA ABOUT BLINK
THE STAY HOW LONG PEOPLE STAY
WHAT WHAT THE- THE ACTUAL
TREATMENT WILL BE AND THEN THE
EFFECTIVENESS OF IT AFTER.
POSTING THAT'S A GOOD IDEA WHO-
OF MAYBE IN THE NEXT FEW CLEAR
TODAY THROUGH APPROPRIATIONS
PROCESS WE COULD PUT IN THERE
SOME TYPE OF. A MANDATED
EVALUATION PROCESS. OKAY THANK
YOU SEVERAL WINNER. THANK YOU
MR CHAIRMAN. SO I WHEN I FIRST
SAW THIS SO I HAD MY CONCERNS
ABOUT IT- FOR THE REASONS
ARTICULATED BY THE OPPOSITION I
HAD GOOD CONVERSATIONS BEFORE
THIS CAME TO THE PUBLIC SAFETY
COMMITTEE WITH THE AUTHOR- I
ALSO HAD. VARIOUS CONVERSATIONS
WITH THE OPPONENTS TO NUMBER
THREE MORE IN MY DISTRICT IN
ORGANIZATIONS THAT ARE VERY
CLOSE WITH AND WORK WITH VERY
VERY CLOSELY ON VARIOUS.
PROGRESSIVE DRUG POLICY.
APPROACHES TOWARDS ENDING THE
WAR ON DRUGS IN TREATING DRUGS
AS A HEALTH ISSUE. NOT A
CRIMINAL ISSUE- AND SO- I
ULTIMATELY IN PUBLIC SAFETY. WE
HAD A VERY VERY PRODUCTIVE
HEARING- AND- HOW LONG COLLOQUY
BETWEEN AMONG ME AND THE AUTHOR
AND THE- AND THE SPONSOR. ON
ABOUT. WAYS THAT THE BILL COULD
BE REALLY TIGHT END. AND A
NUMBER OF AMENDMENTS. THAT WERE
WORKED ON BY THE TWO COMMITTEES
COLLABORATIVELY CAME OUT OF
THAT DISCUSSION CENTER COM
LONGER WAS ALSO INVOLVED. IN
NARCOTIC WE- TO MAKE SURE THE
FIRST ONE NO ONE EVER WOULD
SPEND MORE MORE TIME- IF THEY
DO THIS DIVERSION- THAN THEY
WOULD UNDER THEIR EXISTING
SENTENCE- AND THAT INCLUDES THE
CREDITS THAT THEY WOULD BE
ENTITLED TO. IF THEY WENT
THROUGH THE NORMAL
INCARCERATION PROCESS- IN
ADDITION WE ARE HAVING STRENGTH
AND THE REQUIREMENT THAT A
MEDICAL- PERSONAL PHYSICIAN
WOULD ALTERNATELY MAKE THE
DECISION IS NOT UP TO A JUDGE.
TO DECIDE WHAT KIND OF
TREATMENT IS APPROPRIATE AND SO
I THINK WE WERE ABLE TO.
TIGHTEN UP THE BILL. ON THIS IS
IT IS A HARD ISSUE- AND THE WAY
WE'VE APPROACHED. BY DRUG USE
AND ADDICTION OVER THE LAST
FIFTY YEARS HAS BEEN ABYSMAL
FAILURE THAT WE'VE TAKEN THE
APPROACH THAT IF WE JUST ARREST-PEOPLE. ACROSS THREE PEOPLE TO
SOMEHOW STOP USING DRUGS
WITHOUT THAT HASN'T HAPPENED
IT'S ONLY GOTTEN WORSE. NOW WE
HAVE TO TAKE A HEALTHIER
APPROACH. BUT I ALSO THINK
THERE IS SPACE. FOR LIMITED
PILOT PROGRAMS- NO FANCY-
ACCOUNT IT'S NOT A SMALL COUNTY
BUT IT'S NOT LA COUNTY OR
ALAMEDA COUNTY IT'S A SMALLER
COUNTY- WONDERFUL COUNTY A
SMALL COUNTY. WHERE THEY TAKE A
LOOK AND SEE IF THIS. MAYBE
IT'LL BE UNTIL FELL. AND THEN
THE PILOT. EXPIRE BUT MAYBE FOR
SOME PEOPLE. WHO ARE ALREADY.
GOING TO BE HERE. ARE ALREADY
GOING TO BE INCARCERATED HAVE
COMMITTED A CRIME AND NON
VIOLENT CRIME. AND THIS GIVES
THEM AN OPTION AND I KNOW MY
FRIENDS DISAGREE WITH ME ON
THIS- BUT I DO BELIEVE THAT. AS
THE BILL HAS EVOLVED I THINK IT
IS WORTHY OF SUPPORT AND I'LL
BE SUPPORTING IT TODAY. THANK
YOU OTHER QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS. MANY MEMBERS YES IT
IS SENATOR RUBIO SORRY AND THE
NECESSARILY ALL RIGHT I WANT TO
GO. I THINK I KNOW WHICH MY
CLOTHES AND I JUST WANNA- ASK
ONE FOLLOW UP QUESTION I'M
SORRY I DIDN'T. ASK BEFORE- I
ATE. HERE WHEN I'M LOOKING AT
THE- OUTLINE BILL AND IT TALKS
ABOUT AN INDIVIDUAL CONTINUING
OUT PATIENT TREATMENT FOR A
PERIOD OF TIME. IT ALSO SECTION
EIGHT DISCUSSES- A
RECOMMENDATION COMPREHENSIVE
CONTINUUM OF CARE AND
RECOMMENDATIONS FOR OUTPATIENT
COUNSELING. AND OTHER VITAL
COMPONENTS CAN YOU PLEASE
ADDRESS. THE FOLLOW UP A TRUE
WOULD BE IN CHARGE OF MAKING
SURE THAT THERE IS FOLLOW
THROUGH AND- AND TO ENSURE THAT
THERE'S YOU KNOW SUCCESS IN THE
RECOVERY. KING A TRUST THAT
PLEASE SURE. WELL FIRST OF IT'S
INPATIENT FOR THE TERM OF THEIR
OF THEIR SENTENCE AND I THINK
YOU MEAN AFTER THAT AFTER THEY
SUCCESSFULLY COMPLETED THAT-
HE- POTENTIALLY THE PERSON
WOULD BE ON PROBATION AND THE
TERMS OF THEIR- PROBATION OR
PAROLE WOULD BE. THROUGH SOME
TYPE OF OUTPATIENT- TREATMENT
BUT- POTENTIALLY IF WE STILL
HAVE A LINE OUR OUR OUR
DISTRICT ATTORNEY IF WE COULD
HAVE HIM- APPOINTED ON THIS.
THIS IS SO MODERATE PLEASE
PRINT ON A DIFFERENT- YOU'RE ON
GOOD EXCELLENT PLEASE I AM ON
YES IS THE ANSWER TO THAT
QUESTION IS THE TREATMENT.
STAFF AND WHAT WE ENVISION HERE
IS THE DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH AND
HUMAN SERVICES IN YOLO COUNTY
WOULD BE- PRINCIPALLY
RESPONSIBLE FOR ALL OF THE
TREATMENT OVERSEEN THE
TREATMENT. AND THEY WOULD BE
MONITORING THE INDIVIDUAL
SUCCESS THROUGH BOTH THE END.
YOUR PORTION. AND THEN STEPPING
THEM DOWN. AS APPROPRIATE BASED
ON THEIR NEEDS WHERE THEY WOULD
CONTINUE TO BE MONITORED IN A
RESIDENTIAL FACILITY. AND THEY
CAN THEN BE STEPPED DOWN AGAIN
IN THE JUST STRAIGHT OUT
PATIENTS. BUT ALL ALONG THEY
WOULD BE MONITORED BY TREATMENT
PROFESSIONALS- AND ULTIMATELY
THE TREATMENT PROFESSIONALS
WOULD BE REPORTING BACK TO THE
COURT THAT THE PERSON HAS BEEN
SUCCESSFUL AND THAT COULD BE ON
A VERY EXPEDITED. TIMELINE
DEPENDING ON THE PERSON. THAT
ANSWERS MY QUESTION THANK YOU
FOR THAT. THANK YOU TO SENATOR
LEYVA. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR I
JUST WANT TO ECHO SOME OF THE
CONCERNS AND COMMENTS FROM MY
COLLEAGUES- I DO KIND OF
EMPATHIZE WITH OUR WITH THE
OPPOSITION IS SAYING I'M GOING
TO SUPPORT THE BILL TODAY
BECAUSE ULTIMATELY I BELIEVE
THAT MY COLLEAGUE FROM SAN
FRANCISCO IS SAYING TO. YOU
KNOW IT'S NOT WORKING IN
CONCERT INCARCERATING PEOPLE
FOR DRUG ADDICTION IS NOT
WORKING AND WE HAVE TO TRY
SOMETHING. MAYBE DIFFERENT
MAYBE NEW AND I THINK THIS
COULD BE IT SO- I WANT TO SEE
US MOVE FORWARD AND TRYING TO
GET TO A BETTER PLACE SO HAPPY
TO SUPPORT THE DATE OF THE BILL
TODAY BUT- IF YOU CAN PLEASE
LOOK AT SOME OF THE- ISSUES
THAT ARE THE OPPOSITION RAISE
BECAUSE I DO THINK SOME OF THEM
ARE LEGITIMATE. THANK YOU SIR
MELINDA'S. THANK YOU SO MUCH
MISTER CHAIRMAN- S. ASSUMING
MCCARTY I WANT TO THANK YOU FOR
BRINGING THIS BILL FORWARD- I
THINK EVERYONE IN THIS
COMMITTEE NOW HAS SAID THAT
WHAT WE HAVE DONE WHAT WE ARE
DOING SO FAR ISN'T WORKING AND
IT IS HEARTBREAKING TO SEE-
WHAT WE ALL SEE YOU DRIVING
INTO THE CAPITAL- THE PEOPLE
WHO DESPERATELY NEED HELP OUT
THERE AND JUST AREN'T GETTING
IT AND I WILL SHARE WITH YOU
THE CONVERSATION I HAD. WITH
SOMEONE IN MY DISTRICT IN THIS
HAPPENED LIKE FIVE YEARS AGO SO
WASN'T EVEN RECENT BUT THIS
BILL- REMINDING ME OF THAT
CONVERSATION AND THIS GENTLEMAN
YOU KNOW HE HE'S TYPICALLY ON
THE CORNER IN MY CITY ALL THE
TIME AND- HIS NAME IS GEORGE
AND I HAD A CONVERSATION WITH
GEORGE ONE DAY AND YOU KNOW HE
FREELY ADMITTED THAT HE WAS
ADDICTED TO DRUGS HE'D BEEN IN
AND OUT OF. PRISON IN JAIL OVER
THE YEARS HAD A LENGTHY RECORD
AND I ASKED HIM ABOUT IT. YOU
KNOW HAVE YOU TRIED TREATMENT.
TOM AND HE SAID HE DID AT ONE
POINT. BUT HE JUST. YOU KNOW
THE URGE WAS TOO STRONG AND SO
HE LEFT- AND I. YOU KNOW ASK
THEM BOWL WHAT WOULD HELP YOU I
MEAN WHAT WHAT WOULD IT TAKE TO
GET YOU INTO SOME KIND OF
TREATMENT AND HE LAUGHED AGAIN
THIS WAS FIVE YEARS AGO OR
SEVEN HE LAUGHED AND HE SAID.
THE ONLY WAY THAT YOU'RE GOING
TO HELP ME OR ANYONE IS GONNA
HELP ME IS IF YOU LOCK ME IN
THERE. AND I JUST. YOU KNOW
IT'S KIND OF PUZZLED BY THAT
BUT HE SAID I CAN'T I CAN'T
STAY. I JUST I CAN'T DO IT I
CAN'T DO IT ON MY OWN I NEED.
HIM I NEED SOMEBODY TO KIND OF.
PUT SOME HE DIDN'T USE THESE
WORDS BUT PUT SOME STRUCTURE.
IN THERE SO I THINK THERE'S
CERTAINLY A POPULATION IT WILL
RESPOND WELL. TO THIS TYPE OF
PROGRAM AND IT IS A SMALL.
PILOT PROGRAMS SO I YOU KNOW MY
COLLEAGUES ARE RIGHT IF IT
DOESN'T WORK THEN WE KNOW. IT
DOESN'T WORK BUT IT'S WORTH A
TRY. TO SEE IF IT DOES WORK-
AND IF IN THE END WE CAN EXPAND
IT ACROSS THE STATE I WOULD BE
MORE TENTATIVE. IF YOUR BILL
TODAY WAS TO. PUT THIS IN A
PLACE YOU KNOW STATE WIDE BUT I
THINK IT'S A MEASURED APPROACH
AND I THINK IT'S WORTH LOOKING
AT BECAUSE- WE ALL KNOW THAT
IT'S- WE'VE GOT TOO MANY PEOPLE
OUT THERE WHO HAVE THIS
ADDICTION OR CYCLING IN AND OUT
OF. OUR PRISON SYSTEM AND MANY
OF THEM YOU KNOW CAN BE HELPED
SO- THANK YOU FOR BRINGING THE
BILL FOR IT THANK YOU CHAD.
THANK YOU. OTHER QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS TO THE NUMBERS. K. C.
NINE APOLOGIZE I THINK- CENTER
LEYVA UNDERSTANDS HAVE BEEN
TOTALLY THE ANGLES ON THIS. SO
IT'S HARD TO SEE THE ARGUMENT-
SO SEVERAL CARTY- IT DO
APPRECIATE YOU BRINGING THIS
BILL FORWARD. YOU KNOW WE BOTH
REPRESENT THE SAME AREA YELLOW
COUNTY- PREHEAT THE OPRY TALK
TO DISTRICT ATTORNEY RIGHT SICK
ABOUT- THIS IDEA. I HAVE TO HIT
THAT WHEN I FIRST HEARD IT I
HAVE HAD. MANY CONCERNS- THAT
WATERS I THINK THAT IS THE
OPPOSITION HAS EXPRESSED- I
WOULD MAKE A NOTE THAT
GENERALLY- WHEN IT COMES TO
SUBSTANCE USE TREATMENT-
FORTUNATELY LOCKING THEM UP.
ACTUALLY DOESN'T WORK THE DATA
IS NOT THERE TO SHOW THAT-
HOWEVER IN THIS PARTICULAR
SITUATION- THAT CHALLENGES
THAT- THESE ARE PEOPLE WHO ARE.
GOING TO BE LOCKED UP NO MATTER
WHAT- UNFORTUNATE COMMITTED A
CRIME. NOW WE CAN HAVE A DEBATE
ABOUT WHETHER YOU KNOW IT FROM
THE JUSTICE SYSTEM WHO SHOULD
BE LOCKED UP ENOUGH AT LEAST
UNDER THE EXISTING LAW. THEY
WILL THEY ARE READY GOING TO BE
INCARCERATED NOW- I CERTAINLY
HOPE THAT- AND I KNOW MY
CONVERSATION WITH THE DISTRICT
ATTORNEY THAT THIS YOU KNOW
THIS PROGRAM IS NOT GONNA BE
FUNDED BY CUTTING. FUNDING TO.
SERVICE USED TO THAT HAPPEN IN
THE JAIL RIGHT NOW WE'RE NOT
GOING TO WE'RE NOT TRYING TO
TAKE ROB PETER TO PAY PAUL. BUT
WE WANT TO CREATE A DIFFERENT
OPTION- THAT IS- LESS- THAT
THAT ACTUALLY IS MORE FOCUSED
ON TREATMENT LESS ON
INCARCERATION- AND- THAT'S WHAT
HE TALKED ABOUT IT'S- IT IS
STILL IN CAR EIGHT YEARS SO
IT'S A SECURE FACILITY SO
PEOPLE ARE STILL. YOU KNOW
BLACKED OUT- IT'S DATE BUT THEY
HAVE ALSO COMMITTED A CRIME
SAID RELATED TRYING THAT
UNFORTUNATELY- THAT. NEEDS
UPDATING WE CAN'T LET THEM GO
FREE AND SOCIETY AT LEAST UNDER
CURRENT LAW- BUT THEY HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY IF THEY TYPICALLY
FOCUS ON SUBSTANCE USE
TREATMENT ACTUALLY. PERHAPS GET
OUT EARLY- AND ALSO GET THE
RECORD EXPUNGED SO I THINK
THOSE ARE POSITIVE THINGS. SO
IT IS A PILOT- I CERTAINLY- IS
HERE AT THE OPPOSITION THEIR
CONCERNS WE CERTAINLY DON'T
MAKE IT A HABIT THAT THAT THAT
THE STANDARD WE HEAD OF
SECURITY SO HE'S FOR SUBSTANCE
USE TREATMENT AS BEING THE
STANDARD FOR SUBSTANCE USE
TREATMENT. THAT'S NOT WHAT
WE'RE LOOKING TO WE'RE LOOKING
AT A PILOT THAT MAYBE CAN
CREATE AN ALTERNATIVE APPROACH
TO FOR. THAT GROUP OF PEOPLE
WHO UNFORTUNATELY- UNDER THE
CURRENT LAW WOULD HAVE STILL
HAVE TO BE INCARCERATED OR-
INTO SECURE- SETTING- AND- AND
SEE WHETHER THIS ACTUALLY HELPS
PEOPLE ACTUALLY GET. TAKEN CARE
OF EARLIER AND ALSO- I GIVE
THEM THE OPPORTUNITY TO RESTART
THEIR LIVES. WITH THEIR
SUBSTANCE USE- UNDER BETTER
CONTROL.AND SO- REALLY FISH
YOUR ON THIS- AGAIN IT'S A
PILOT- DEVELOPMENT WAS ACTUALLY
TO BE SURE TO ACTUALLY ASK THAT
TO THE PARTIAL CARE SERVICES
WHICH NORMALLY OVERSEAS THAT WE
WANT THE SERVICE OVERSIGHT OVER
THIS AND- THEY DO OVERSEE-
SERVICES TREATMENT PROGRAMS
ABILITY. ON SECURITY ONCE BUT
AT LEAST TO BE SURE THAT THE
TREATMENT. OVER THAT THE
OVERSIGHT OVER THE TREATMENT
IS- AND LONG WITH THE STANDARDS
OF THE STATE- THAT- THAT THE
PEOPLE WHO ARE IN THIS FACILITY
ARE TREATED APPROPRIATELY AND
FAIRLY- I THOUGHT THIS IS GONNA
TAKE SOME WORK BECAUSE THEY'RE
NOT NORMALLY TO SAY. IT THAT
THE STANDARD IS NOT A SECURE
FACILITY. BUT APPRECIATE THE
WORK ON THIS AND WITHOUT WHICH
I CLOSE. YES THANK YOU I
APPRECIATE THE- THE DIALOGUE I
JUST WANT TO ADDRESS A COUPLE
ISSUES. TO CENTER ADMIN THERE
ISN'T HERE AND I DID OVER LOOK
AT THERE IS A CLAUSE IN HERE
ABOUT AN OUTCOMES ASSESSMENT BY
AN INDEPENDENT EVALUATOR BUT
POTENTIALLY WE CAN CLARIFY THAT
AND MAKE SURE WE HAVE THE
COUNTY REPORT BACK TO. THE
LEGISLATURE. NOT JUST AN
EVALUATION AS FAR AS- WHAT THE
VALUES OF THIS PROJECT ARE AND
HOW IT COULD BE. POTENTIALLY
EXTENDED THROUGHOUT. CALIFORNIA
I GET THE BIG PICTURE IS AS AS
OTHERS SAID IT'S A BIG LIST OF
OPPOSITION. AND THIS IS IT THIS
JOB SOMETIMES PUTS US IN
UNCOMFORTABLE POSITIONS. THEY
HAVE TO SAY NO TO SOME PEOPLE
THAT WE WORK WITH- CERTAINLY
HAVE AUTHORED BILLS. ON THAT
WORK WITH MANY OF THE PEOPLE IN
OPPOSITION. TO REFORM THE
CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM. IF I
THOUGHT FOR ONE SECOND THAT
THIS BILL WOULD INCARCERATE
MORE INDIVIDUALS PUT MORE
PEOPLE. BEHIND BARS- FOR DRUG
RELATED CRIMES I WOULD NEVER
AUTHORED THIS BILL IN THE FIRST
PLACE AND I WOULD. DITCH IT
RIGHT HERE TODAY BUT THIS IS
NOT WHAT WE'RE DOING WE'RE
WE'RE LOOKING AT. THESE ARE
INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE OTHERWISE
AS YOU SAID CHAIRMAN PAN. GOING
TO BE IN A STATE PRISON OR
COUNTY JAIL FOR A LONGER PERIOD
OF TIME. POTENTIALLY THEIR DRUG
ADDICTION THERE COULD WORSEN WE
KNOW THAT DRUGS ARE BROUGHT
INTO PRISON AND JAIL
UNFORTUNATELY. SO THEY COULD
COME OUT YOU. REALLY SO THIS IS
AN OPPORTUNITY FOR INDIVIDUALS
TO MAKE A CHOICE. TO GO TO GO
TO. A DRUG TREATMENT OPTION.
AND POTENTIALLY REDUCE THEIR
SENTENCES HAVE EXPUNGEMENT. AND
SOMETHING THAT REALLY COULD
WORK IN OUR COMMUNITY CENTER.
BUT WE'VE ALL SEEN THE
DISASTERS IN OUR CITIES AND
ACROSS THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA-
DISTRICTS. JUST LAST WEEK LIKE
YOU. I WAS ON AN HOUR LONG ****
THIS CALL AND ASSUME COSTS WHAT
I DO DURING THAT HOUR. I WALKED
UP AND DOWN K. STREET. AND I
SAW THINGS FIRST HAND THAT YOU
KNOW THAT. I DON'T DON'T MAKE
ME PLEASANT HERE IN MY DISTRICT
TO MY COMMUNITY I TALKED TO ONE
RESIDENTIAL SHOP. HERE AND I
ASKED THEM ABOUT SOME OF THE
INDIVIDUALS WE'RE LOOKING AT
ONE. PERSON LIKE I SAY WHAT
SHOP WHAT PERSON. THEY SAID
YEAH I KNOW THIS PERSON. I KNOW
WHO THEY ARE. THEY HAVE A MAJOR
DRUG ADDICTION THEY'VE BEEN
COMING IN HERE AND- AND CAN
COMMIT A CRIME AND BREAKING IN
THIS TO. BREAK IN AND STEALING
STUFF ON A REGULAR BASIS. AND-
IF THEY EVER GET SENTENCED. YOU
KNOW THEY WON'T HAVE. TO TYPE
IN DRUG TREATMENT. IN THE
FACILITY WHERE THEY'RE GOING SO
YOU KNOW WE SEE IT. WE SEE IT
ON A DAILY BASIS THE CURRENT
SYSTEM. IS NOT WORKING- THE
BEST CASE THIS IS A PILOT THAT
WE CAN REPLICATE. TO THE OTHER.
FIFTY SEVEN COUNTIES ACROSS
CALIFORNIA. WORST CASE IS
SOMETHING THAT WE TRIED HERE
WHICH WE'RE TRYING TO MAKE A
DIFFERENCE BECAUSE- AGAIN. WE
HAVE TO GO ABOUT THINGS
DIFFERENTLY AND WITH THAT I DO.
APPRECIATE ALL THE DIALOGUE AND
I AND WE ARE WORKING- IT WITH
THE OPPOSITION EVERY KID EVERY
COMMITTEE WE'VE TAKEN CHANGES
AGAIN WE TAKEN OVER TWENTY.
AMENDMENTS LISTENING TO THE
OPPOSITION OVER THE PAST. FOUR
FIVE MONTHS. AND WE WILL
CONTINUE TO DO SO ALL THE WAY
TO THE FINISH SO WITH THAT. I
ASK YOU RIGHT THANK YOU. HEY
THANK YOU IS THERE A MOTION ON
THIS BILL. OKAY TO MOVE IT MOVE
BY SENATOR RUBIO THE MOTIONS
DEEP PASSES AMENDED THE FIRST
AMENDED REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE APPROPRIATIONS.
THAT'S ALL PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
CAN I CAN HI MELINDA'S HI
MELINDA'S BY EGGMAN. EGGMAN
EIGEN SOLACE CONSOLES I GROVE
HER TADO. HER TITLE I LISA.
LEAVE I. LEAVE ALONE. THE MON I
ROTH RUBIO. RUBIO I WINNER
WINNER I. THE BILLS CURRENTLY
NINE ZERO PUT THE BILL ON CALL
ALL RIGHT. OKAY NEXT ITEM IS
ACTION ITEM NUMBER THIRTEEN
EIGHTY THREE SIXTY NINE BY
SERRA COM LOCKER AT THAT'S A
VOTE ONLY I AM HOWEVER I WILL
TAKE THE PRIVILEGES CHAIR TO
SIMPLY MAKE A FEW STATEMENTS-
FIRST OF ALL I DO APPRECIATE
CENTER COM LOCKER- AUTHORING
THIS BILL TO ADDRESS STREET
MEDICINE AND- WANT TO SUPPORT
THAT CONCEPT UNFORTUNATELY WE
WERE NOT ABLE TO LAND ON A SET
OF AMENDMENTS TO ADDRESS WHAT I
CONSIDER TO BE IMPLEMENTATION
ISSUES TO MAKEIT SUCCESSFULLY
IMPLEMENTED- BECAUSE OF THAT I
PERSONALLY WILL BE STAYING OFF.
THE BILL HOWEVER- I ALSO KNOW
THAT MANY OF YOU HERE WANT TO
SUPPORT ST MEDICINE SO- AGAIN
EVERYONE OF COURSE IS ALWAYS
FREE TO VOTE THE WAY THEY WANT
AND EFFECT I HOPE THAT THIS
BILL COMES OUT OF THE COMMITTEE
AND AT THE CENTER WILL CONTINUE
WORKING ON THOSE IMPLEMENTATION
ISSUES I THINK THAT WOULD BE
IMPORTANT THAT IT- IT POINTED.
IT EVER HAS TO GO WHEN IT HITS
THE GOVERNOR'S DESK THAT- DEBT
THAT WILL BE SET- BUT
UNFORTUNATELY WE'RE NOT ABLE TO
SETTLE THAT IN THE WEEKS TIME
SO- WITH THAT JUST THAT'S THE
CIRCUMSTANCE- AND- WITH THAT-
CONSULTANT- THANK YOU I GUESS I
SHOULD PROBABLY TAKE A MOTION
FIRST BECAUSE IT'S BEEN MOVED
BY SENATOR LEYVA. AND MOTIONS
TO PASS REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS-
CONSULTANT PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
ON ITEM NUMBER THIRTEEN EIGHTY
THREE SIXTY NINE PAN. MELINDA'S
EGGMAN. AIKMAN AIKEN SOLACE
CONSOLE I GROW HER TADO ALL HER
TITLE I LISA HI LISA I LIMA HI
THE MOON I ROTH RUBIO HI RUBIO
I WINNER BY WINTER I. YEAH SO
THE VOTE IS CURRENTLY SEVEN
ZERO PUT THE BILL ON CALL RIGHT
NOW WE'RE GONNA START FROM THE
TOP OF OUR AGENDA AND AGAIN
BECAUSE WE HEARD BOTH THESE
BILLS A SUB COMMITTEES ON THE
MOTIONS ON THE CELL BEGAN WTH
ITEM NUMBER ONE EIGHTY SIXTY
ONE. IS THERE A MOTION. SOME OF
OKAY SEND YOU BY CENTER LABOR
THE MOTIONS TO PASS AS AMENDED
THE FIRST AMENDED REFERRED TO
THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS- CONSULTANT
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. PAN HI
CAN I MELINDA'S. MELINDA'S HI
EGGMAN. EGGMAN EIGEN SOLACE.
GONZALEZ I GROW FURTADO. FOR
TITLE I LEIVA. LEAVE OUT BY THE
MOON. THE MOON I ROSS. RUBIO.
RUBIO I WINNER BY WINTER I.
THAT THOSE CURRENTLY NINE ZERO
PUT THE BILL ON CALL. NEXT ITEM
NUMBER. TWO EIGHTY NINETY SEVEN
BY SOME MEMBER IN THIS AREA AND
THAT'S OUR MOTION. BUT IT'S
BEEN MOVED BY SENATOR THE
MOTIONS TO PASS THE FIRST
READING OF THE REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS A
CONSULTANT PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
CAN. MELINDA'S AIKMAN BY ADMIN
I CONSOLIDATES CONSOLES I GROW.
HER TADO FURTADO HI LISA HI
LISA RILEY MOON THE MOON I ROTH.
RUBIO HI RUBIO I WINNER WINNER
pSEVEN Z. IT'S CURRENTLY SEVEN
ZERO PUT THE BILL ON CALL BACK
DINERS ITEM NUMBER THREE EIGHTY
TWO ONE EIGHT BY SOME MEMBER OF
WARD- IS OUR MOTION AND MOVED
BY SENATOR RUBIO THE MOTIONS TO
PASS THE FIRST BE REFERRED TO
THE COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
THAT'S ALL PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
PAN HI AND I'M MELINDA'S.
MELINDA'S NO EGGMAN EGGMAN
EIGEN SOLACE AND SELES A GROVE
HER TADO FURTADO HI LISA HI I
LISA I LIVE. THE MOON HI ROSS
RUBIO FIVE RUBIO I WINNER.
WINNER I. THE CURRENT ROLES
EIGHT ONE PUT THE BILL ON CALL
NEXT ITEMS I'M NUMBER FOUR
EIGHTY THREE EIGHTY NINE BY
SUMMER GRAYSON ESSER A MOTION.
SOME OF THE DEVICE ARE LAY THAT
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED. THE TONE PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL CAN HI AND I'M
MELINDA'S. BELINDA'S NO AIKMAN.
HI EDWIN AIKEN SOLACE HI CAN
SOLICIT MY GROVE. HER TADO FOR
TITLE I LEAVE A LEAVE I LEE
MOON THE MOON I ROTH RUBIO HI
RUBIO I WINNER WINNER I. FOR
ROLES EIGHTY ONE WILL PUT THE
BILL ON CALL. NEXT ITEM IS ITEM
NUMBER FIVE EIGHTY FIVE A ONE
BY SUMMER CHRISTINA GARCIA AS
OUR MOTION FROM OF. OKAY IT'S
BEEN MOVED BY- CENTER THAT
LEAVE US SORRY ABOUT THE SERVER
DATA YES IT'S MOVEMENTS ARE
TITLED THE MOTIONS TO PASS AS
AMENDED THE FIRST AMENDED
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS THAT'S ALL
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL PAN HI AND
I'M MELINDA'S. MELINDA'S I
EGGMAN EGGMAN I. GONZALEZ.
GONZALEZ I GROW HER TADO FOR
TITLE HEY LISA. HI LEAVE A
HIGHLY MON HI LIMONEIRA ROTH
RUBIO. RUBIO I WEINER HI YOU
KNOW I. THAT BILL IS CURRENTLY
NINE ZERO PUT THE BILL ON CALL.
NEXT ITEM IS ITEM NUMBER SIX
EIGHTY FIVE THIRTY FIVE BASE
AMBER AGARI CURRY IS THERE A
MOTION SO MOVED OKAY OKAY WHO'S
AT FAULT OKAY YES SIR EDMUND
NARRATES THE MOVE I SAID SORRY
CAN WE STILL BE THE MOST SIR
EDMUND AT THE MOTIONS DO PASSES
AMENDED THE FIRST AMENDED
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS. A CONSULTANT-
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL CAN HI AND
I'M MELINDA'S MELINDA'S HI
EGGMAN EGGMAN. THEMSELVES BY
GROVE. FOR TOTAL I LEAVE A-
LEAVE OUT BY LEE MOON HI THE
MON I ROSS RUBIO. FIVE RUBIO I
WINNER WINNER I. CURRENT ROLE
HAVE CURRENT LOTUS NINE ZERO
PUTTHE BILL ON CALL NEXT ITEM
IS ITEM NUMBER EIGHT EIGHTY
EIGHT FIFTY EIGHT BYE S. IS A
MEMBER JOHN SAWYER IS THERE A
MOTION. SOME OF IT'S BEEN MOVED
BY SENATOR LEYVA THE MOTIONS TO
PASS AS AMENDED THE FIRST
AMENDED REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE APPROPRIATIONS THE
TONE PLEASE CALL THE ROLL CAN I
CAN I AM MELINDA'S. MELINDA'S
NO EGGMAN. EGGMAN ARGAN SOLACE
IN SOLACE HI GROVE. HER TADO.
FIVE HER TITLE HI LISA I LEAVE
I LEAVE ON. THE MOON I. ROSS
RUBIO. WINNER HI WE- I. THE.
THE CARD VOTE IS SEVEN ONE WILL
PUT THE BILL ON CALL. ALL
RIGHT- NEXT WILL TAKE UP THE
CONSENT CALENDAR WE ONLY HAVE
ONE ITEM ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR IS ITEM NUMBER. NINE
EIGHTY THIRTEEN OH SIX BY
SUMMER RAIN VILLA IS OUR MOTION
ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR. GETS
LIVE WITH THEIR LABOR- CONSOLE
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL TE
CONSENT CALENDAR HAND HI CAN I
MELINDA'S MELINDA'S I EGGMAN
EGGMAN HI. CONSOLES CONSOLES I
GROW HER TADO FURTADO I LIZA I
LIVE I LIVE ALONE. HI LIMONEIRA
ROTH RUBIO. HI RUBIO I WINNER
WINNER I. RIGHT SO THE CURRENT
VOTE ON THE CONTENT CALENDARS
NINE ZERO FOOT THE BILL THE
CONSENT CALENDAR ON CALL NOW
LIVE TO CALL ON ITEM NUMBER TEN
EIGHTY FOURTEEN OH SEVEN BY
SOME MEMBER BURKE. ITS OWN
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL ABSENT
MEMBERS. MELINDA'S. GROW GROVE
ROTH WINNER FIVE WINNER I.
THREE SIX. THE CURRENT ROLES
EIGHT ZERO PUT THE BILL ON
CALLED NEXUS ITEM NUMBER ELEVEN
EIGHTY FOURTEEN THIRTY SIX BY
SUMMER CHOW TOLD PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL ABSENT MEMBERS. THE
MOMENT I. GROSS ROTH RUBIO.
OKAY SO THE CAT CURRENT VOTE
BUT IT IS SEVEN ONE I WILL
LEAVE THAT BILL ON CALL LET'S
MOVE ON TO ITEM NUMBER TWELVE
EIGHTY FIFTEEN FORTY TWO BY
SUMMER CARTY- I DON'T THINK
WE'RE GOING TO HAVE AN
ADDITIONAL SENSE HE'S THE
LAWYER ADDED THAT CURRENTLY AT
NINE ZERO WILL KEEP THAT BILL
ON CALL AND THEN FINALLY ITEM
NUMBER THIRTEEN EIGHTY THREE
SIXTY NINE BY. ENTERCOM LAGER-
CFD IT'S CALLED THE ROLE OF
ABSENT MEMBERS. HAN MELINDA'S
GROVE ROTH OKAY THE LIBERTY
THAT THAT'S CURRENTLY SEVEN
ZERO PUT THE BILL ON CALL ALL
RIGHT AND- WE CAN LEARN CENTER-ROCK NO I KNOW HE'S BITS OF
SOMETHING AS SOON AS HE CAN GET
OVER HERE. AND THEN HOPEFULLY
WE CAN THEN HAVE BUDGET BILLS
START OKAY THANK YOU WE'RE
GOING TO RECESS UNTIL CENTER
ROCK APPEARS SO- THIS WEEK
SENATE COMMITTEE ON HEALTH WILL
NOW. BE IN RECESS. YEAH I KNOW
I KNOW EXACTLY SO.
OKAY RIGHT
THANK YOU WE ARE NOW GOING TO
LIFT THE CALLS ON THE BILLS
THAT WERE HEARD AT THIS HEARING
SO- CONSULTANT WILL BEGIN AND
THE FOLLOW ON ORDERS ARE
BEGINNING ITEM NUMBER ONE
EIGHTY SIXTY ONE- CONSULTANT
PLEASE CALL IT A DAY DAILY
BACKUPS ITEM NUMBER ONE EIGHTY
SIXTY ONE. BY SOME MEMBER
GABRIEL AND GIBSON- CONSULT
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL OF ABSENT
MEMBERS GROVE ROTH. THE BILL IS
OUT. NINE ZERO. THE ITEM NUMBER
TWO EIGHTY NINETY SEVEN BY SOME
MEMBERS OF THE SYRIAN
CONSULTANT PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
OF ABSENT MEMBERS PAN MELINDA'S
GROVE ROTH. THE BILL IS OUT
SEVEN ZERO. NEXT ITEM IS ITEM
NUMBER THREE EIGHTY TWO
EIGHTEEN BY SEVERAL WARD
CONSULT THESE CALL THE ROLE
THAT SOME MEMBERS GROVE ROTH
CAPITAL IS OUT EIGHT ONE. NEXT
ITEM IS ITEM NUMBER FOUR EIGHTY
THREE EIGHTY NINE BY SUMMER
GRACE AND ITS OWN PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL ABSENT MEMBERS GROVE
ROTH. THAT BILL IS OUT EIGHT
ONE NEXT ITEM IS ITEM NUMBER
FIVE EIGHTY FIVE A ONE BY
SUMMER CHRISTINA GARCIA
CANCELED PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
OF ABSENT MEMBERS GROVE ROTH
CAPITAL IS OUT. NINE ZERO. NEXT
ITEM IS ITEM NUMBER SIX EIGHTY
FIVE THIRTY FIVE I SUMMER AGAR
CURRY CONSULTING CALL THE ROLE
THAT SOME MEMBERS GROW ROTH.
THAT FILLS OUT NINE ZERO. NEXT
ITEM IS ITEM NUMBER EIGHT
EIGHTY EIGHT FIFTY EIGHT BY
SOME MEMBER JOHN SAWYER CONSULT
THESE CALL THE ROLE THAT SOME
MEMBERS. GROVE ROTH REBEL. OKAY
THIRTY AGAIN SORRY I THINK I
OVER GROVE ROSS RUBIO. OKAY
THAT BILLS OUT SEVEN ONE. NEXT
ITEM IS ITEM NUMBER TEN EIGHTY
TWO FOURTEEN OH SEVEN BY SOME
MEMBER BURKE CONSOLE PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL OF ABSENT MEMBERS.
MELINDA'S GROVE BROTH THAT BILL
IS OUT EIGHT ZERO NEXT ITEMS
I'M NUMBER ELEVEN EIGHTY
FOURTEEN THIRTY SIX BY SOME
MEMBER CHILD CANCELED PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL THAT SOME MEMBERS
GROW RALPH. RUBIO THAT BILL IS
OUT SEVEN ONE. NEXT ITEM IS
ITEM NUMBER TWELVE EIGHTY
FIFTEEN FORTY TWO BY SEVERAL
CARTY CONSULTANT PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL OF ABSENT MEMBERS
GROVE BROTH. THAT BILLS OUT
NINE EIGHT ZERO AT. NEXT ITEMS
I'M NUMBER THIRTEEN EIGHTY
THREE SIXTY NINE BY SEVERAL COM
LAGER. THAT CANCELED PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL OF ABSENT MEMBERS
PAN MELINDA'S GROVE ROTH. THE
BILL IS OUT SEVEN ZERO FINALLY-
THE CONSENT CALENDAR CONSULT
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL OF AFTER
NUMBERS ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
GROVER FROTH. CALENDARS OUT.
NINE ZERO. YEAH OKAY OKAY SO
THAT CONCLUDES THESE THIS
AGENDA THE SENATE COMMITTEE ON
HEALTH OR THANK ALL THE
INDIVIDUALS TO PARTICIPATE IN
TODAY'S PUBLIC TESTIMONY IF YOU
WERE UNABLE TO TESTIFY TODAY
PLEASE SUBMITYOUR COMMENTS AND
SUGGESTIONS IN WRITING TO THE
SENATE COMMITTEE ON HEALTH
HELLO THAT OUR OUR VISIT OUR
WEBSITE YOUR COMMENTS AND
SUGGESTIONS ARE IMPORTANT TO US
TO ONE THINK TO INCLUDE YOUR
TESTIMONY IN THE OFFICIAL
HEARING RECORDS. THANK YOU
APPRECIATE YOUR PARTICIPATION I
ALSO WANT TO THANK THE STAFF
WHO WORKED VERY HARD FOR BUT
THIS HEARING AND ACTUALLY SINCE
IT'S OUR LAST POLICY HEARING-
THAT WE'RE AWARE O WE COULD
HAVE SOME OTHERS LATER ON BUT
THAT SCHEDULE THEM I THINK THE
COMMITTEE STAFF FOR THEIR HARD
WORK ASO ALL THIS TECHNICAL
STAFF MAKES OUR HEARING. GOES
AS SMOOTHLY AS POSSIBLE I KNOW
SOMETIMES THERE'S SOME
CHALLENGES BUT THEY'VE WORKED
REALLY HARD TO MAKE SURE THAT
THE LOOKS A LOT EASIER THAN IT
REALLY IS SO WITH THAT I WANT
THANK EVERYONE FOR THEIR
PATIENCE AND COOPERATION WE
HAVE NOW CONCLUDED THIS AGENDA
OF THE SENATE COMMITTEE ON
HEALTH. THIS- HEARING IS NOW
ADJOURNED.